[Music]
[Music]
what is good
how you living how you feeling how you
doing br gridiron draft knight it is
your guy the l-e-f-k-o-e
man for the ninth straight year still
feels good to say the millennial mel
keiper connor rogers
the julia childs of jumping routes
michael felder it is draft night
if you were here with us last night you
were one of the hundreds of thousands
that tuned in to watch the draft live if
you just saw our clips and you went dan
that looks fun it was but this is where
the most fun is going to happen we will
also be joined by jason kelsey richard
sherman amanra st brown they will fill
us in but here at this desk this is the
epicenter of the 2022 nfl draft you said
something as we went off air last night
this is the more fun night for you for
them for everybody why did you say that
for everyone this is where the value is
right
once again anybody can make the picks in
the first round anybody can log on read
a mock draft and figure out what makes
sense tonight's the night where you're
looking for value you're looking for
players that should have probably went
in round one and fell and then there's
going to be guys that should have gone
in round two they're going to be there
in round three right and then obviously
things are going to get real crazy
tomorrow when felder and i are holding
it down and you're looking at rounds
four and five but man tonight i mean we
see superstars every year come out of
this out of jonathan taylor alvin kamara
on and on and on this is where
superstars are taking this is travis
kelsey richard it's a lot of fun like
all that yeah um
you
love man crushes
and
you love guys that go deeper in the
draft than the guys that go in the first
round anyway yes
some of your favorite players yeah that
we could see go early tonight who are
they let me see you see what i did you
can't what does that say my face my
favorite you've got you got man crushes
watching we know this my face i got a
list i haven't memorized the cobie dean
is on there for sure bruce hall's on
there jaquan brisker's on there logan
hall's on there chad mumma who we talked
about before he's on there i've got
jalen petrie on there baylor safety so
yeah we're going to see a lot of who is
this who's your favorite of the faves
it's nicoby right yeah absolutely
without a doubt it's nicoby d and i
think he's the most intelligent player
in the draft i think he's going to be
the most instantly productive player out
of everyone drafted i think he's a
plug-and-play starter i can't wait to
see him come off the board that will be
my like that's going to be my favorite
moment and so i'm ready to go as the
back of my shirt says your favorite
player's favorite player
listen that's what nicoby dean is going
to be your favorite player's favorite
player we will also be seeing by my
calculations nine teams drafting tonight
for the first time
bears browns broncos colts raiders rams
dolphins niners and bucks have not
drafted yet bucks of course traded out
of the first round
trading back
i believe with kansas city was it to get
out of the first round no jacksonville
jacksonville you're right because they
came up and they took uh mister
a heck of a pick again we are brought to
you by rocket mortgage so excited for
them to be on board i thought that the
vikings did a great job of picking up
multiple picks that we could see tonight
i thought the patriots did a really good
job of picking up multiple picks is
there anything that after you had time
to digest last night that you thought of
when man i really wish i got that in
last night i'm just fascinated to watch
the quarterbacks today right i mean
obviously this has been billed as an
underwhelming class we saw kenny pickett
go at 20 to the steelers no malik willis
in round one a bit of a surprise no
desmond ritter in round one a bit of a
surprise for a lot of teams that were
bracing themselves for that sam howell
and matt corral they will also come off
the board tonight as well
and usually i know they didn't go in the
first round because so you can't say
teams love them but usually teams will
make a move for quarterbacks on day two
that they might have thought that we're
gonna not be able to get in around once
we might see some movement for those
guys can we see conor's big board as we
continue to get us ready for round
number two we're starting off with it
goes tampa minnesota tennessee will be
the first three picks all of those
coming because of trades tennessee or
tampa of course because of devin lloyd
we just mentioned minnesota the trades
with detroit jameson williams and
tennessee because of the jermaine
johnson trade with the jets uh we've
talked before about the kobe dean but we
have not talked yet about david ojabo uh
who do you think could go maybe to tampa
bay
at this first pick see this is an
interesting one connor because for me
when i look at tampa bay they're a team
the idea of getting a weapon possibly
makes sense to me uh some help along the
defensive front which ojava would offer
but yep do you want to wait on him you
got a quarterback that doesn't have time
no no no so i don't know that you can
get a guy in the second round there you
need someone who's going to be able to
play so i don't know that a java fits
there even though he would be a good fit
in theory when you got a quarterback
that has already retired right i don't
know that you can go and get a guy
that's gonna be a one-year kind of
sitting weight yeah i'm with you fella i
would be a little surprised if it's a
jabbo it feels like an impact player
right away i think when you look at it
for this travis jones is in play here
obviously todd bowles is somebody who
plays very big fronts travis jones sue
is a free agent who's a free agent and
last year you can kind of see it
starting to finally fall off for two
where travis jones 325 pounds super
athlete that's a no doubter of a fit if
they go offensive offense do not be
shocked if they start the tight end
runner i was going to say we have not
had a running back drafted we have not
had a tight end drafted and gronk is
still a free agent he is
it would be trey mcbride jerry mcbride
would be the first time on the board uh
obviously
he's the most pro ready of the tight
ends because he was his offense at
colorado he's got maybe the best hands
in the entire draft he's good enough as
a blocker in line and on the move so
he's the sleeper cell i think of the
pick here let us welcome in some of our
esteemed guests let's go to jason kelsey
first jason kelsey
what a night
jason kelsey had last night coming back
with the cincinnati still looking
comfortable still looking suave
jason have you calmed down yet after
last night or are you still riding high
um no i mean
i've calmed down a little bit but i'll
just tell you i just uh met jordan davis
down at the facilities
um and he is literally the size of a
door so
in person meeting him uh was
even more impressive than watching his
tape so
i'm excited to do battles with him uh
the training camp what now that you
bring that up what has been the vibe
this last 20 or not even like 18 hours
since all these moves happened what
teammates have you talked to what
coaches have you talked to what are some
things that you're hearing that you'd
love to share so that we can get excited
well you know i mean obviously
everybody's excited um you know what aj
brown offers uh from uh
from a deep ball standpoint from
just an overall matchup standpoint i
mean it's something that's going to
severely enhance our offense
so i think that everybody's excited
everybody's texting everybody's been
calling um i mean it's just something
that's really going to expand our
our offense so
yeah the the mood in the building today
was uh very positive jason i i know
you're not a big social media guy but
apparently philadelphia was going nuts
last night so let's take a look at some
of the eagles fans losing their freaking
minds
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
how do we know what time it is it's her
season it's it's devonte smith season
and aj brown season it's jordan davis
teasing it's philly season we're getting
back to our whole way we're winning that
champ that's all i got to say baby
what do you think jk
i mean
i would expect nothing less from
philadelphia i love it never disappoints
i love it uh we will be checking in with
jason kelsey throughout the draft
whenever someone in the trenches is
taken jason thanks again for joining us
let's go check in with ammanra saint
brown his detroit lions were busy
yesterday as well aidan hutchinson a
trade for jamison williams who i was
reading a lot today
perfectly compliments a monroe st brown
aka
the clutch kid who only catches
touchdowns to win football games uh
amman ross st brown my question for you
is we have a lot of wide receivers are
going to come off the board today who
did you watch for us that you're like
man i'm excited to talk about this guy
uh i would have to go one guy that i've
been watching a little is john metchi
from alabama you know he had the acl
injury in the in the national
championship which kind of hurt but you
watch his tape
i think you know he's not the fastest
but
everything else that he does he's savvy
he comes out of his routes well he's
good after the catch and i think his
start and stop ability is what as a
receiver i think you know being able to
start and stop is huge and he has that
so i'm excited to see him come up the
board hopefully today and and talk about
him awesome i'm on ross st brown we'll
be breaking down the wide receivers
and i'm
drafting him on my fantasy team next
year last to check in with
the man that stole a microphone and then
stole our hearts and now has his own
podcast and will likely take over all
media companies for the rest of our
lives richard sherman uh
just give me big picture here richard
when you when you went to sleep and you
thought about what you had watched uh
the draft last night
what is the one thing that's sticking
out to you
well i mean i thought i thought you know
i thought people would get desperate i
thought malik willis would would go in
the first round i really did i thought
people would want control of that fifth
year option uh obviously they didn't
i thought andrew booth
the corner from clemson i thought he
would go earlier i really did i thought
he would be top 15 top 20 pick and he's
still sitting there at the beginning of
the second round so i'm sure a lot of
teams are excited there he's a heck of a
playmaker he's a he's a guy who
takes the ball you know he's a big time
hitter but that's what stands out to me
about his game man he he takes the ball
he's a high point turnover machine you
know when you throw it in his area
there's a danger you always hear about
hey he moved to db because he couldn't
play receiver or he couldn't catch you
you don't have that problem with him so
i would have expected him to go higher
obviously we knew who the top two
corners were but that's surprising
all right we will be on the lookout for
mr booth he could be going very early in
the second round richard sherman the man
we appreciate you will be checking with
you
soon enough i am seeing on television
right now the tampa bay bucks they're
not officially on the clock
but do we want to what i actually want
to ask a quarterback question malik
where do we think he goes
we're looking at this it's going to be
soon it's going to be real soon when you
look at it the vikings you don't rule
them out here even after they took kel
and mon last year oh that doesn't
i mean did you hear mike zimmer
say i see him practice every day and i
know zimmer's not there but that was not
a good uh sign endorsement yeah that
wasn't the best endorsement tennessee or
maybe i was gonna say 37.
the houston texans texans they really
like davis mills but why why not
honestly
why not so i look and then uh the big
one i think that would be exciting for
everyone would be seattle at 40 or 41
441 yeah they got the back-to-back picks
usually when teams are picking back to
back you try to move one and split your
cards a little bit but i look at that
and go man dru lock isn't firing up that
fan base right now malik willis can can
we see some malik willis footage and i
just want you guys falcons oh yeah
if he gets to all the way to 43. will
that be
especially with arthur smith and what
they're already doing with mariota can
we see some malik willis i just want you
guys to take me through
because i really haven't heard your
stances on him felder i i like him i
think he throws a pretty deep ball i
think he's got the ability to move
obviously move the pocket there eyes
downfield evade and then get off me
still there's some good strength he's
not the biggest guy but he does have
strength in his game and then he's got
the ability to deliver a hot ball i love
watching him the best play that he has
on film is against virginia tech and he
gets virginia tech it's a half roll half
roll guy closes in on him spins out of
it and then delivers a dime 35 40 yards
down the field
right at the one yard line where only
his guy can get it above up drops in
their bucket above the defensive right
above the defensive backs hands right
where his wide receiver's able to catch
it right there at the goal line and so
for me i love to see that out of him
recognizing the voids in cover too uh
people keep calling him a running back
that's a that's that plays quarterback
it's silly it's insulting quite honestly
the biggest thing for me watching him
play is he understands where his spaces
are on the field he understands where
he's supposed to be on the field can he
run yes
but what he does really really well is
throw the football
i'll say this my favorite thing about
him throughout this entire process was
being down at the senior bowl and just
seeing the day-to-day improvement while
working with an nfl staff he worked
under the lion staff down there and you
see day one i mean god it's got to be
uncomfortable you get down to mobile
alabama you're on a practice field with
mostly guys that you've never played
with in your entire life you're a
quarterback trying to build chemistry
right one on one seven on sevens eleven
on elevens then day two we're standing
out there in a monsoon nobody can get a
snap nobody can hold the ball nobody
could throw the ball malique willis you
would think he's throwing in a dome
there was no yeah the throws were great
he looked comfortable he's confident
people like him he can make big plays
outside of the pocket the green light is
coming on for plays inside the pocket
very heavy play action offense yeah so
you can cut the field in half with him
at the next level and simplify things
early if you want to play him right away
you had told me yesterday that the
pittsburgh steelers only draft guys that
they go to the pro days of and they were
very present at malik willis pro day i'm
curious have you heard anything in these
last 18 hours just about how they ended
up at kenny pickett and and did this
surprise other people as well i heard it
really about five days ago that it was
starting to gravitate towards kenny
pickett and i think when you look at it
maybe it was just the fact that they are
not as sold on mitch trubisky being the
stop cap this year as a lot of the media
reported where kenny pickett could come
in and give you more life and more juice
than mitch trubisky can while everybody
knows malik willis like desmond ritter
like sam howell like matt corral every
quarterback that will go today they
should get an nfl redshirt year that's
the reality of this situation i don't
feel that way about kenny pickett do i
think there's a significant upside no
but i do think he can come in and play
right away if you have playmakers that
he just needs to distribute the ball to
them
and that's the way the steelers leaned i
don't know if that's the right choice
i think the upside there was intriguing
when you have a bridge starter what are
so oh go for it how much better is mitch
chabicki than kenny pickett right now
i will say that he's not better than
kenny picky right now i really believe
that
where do we get here with how did we get
here mitch trubisky you spent a year up
in buffalo and you come out and you're
yeah everybody like good for you great
that's what always happens i mean listen
i think back to that draft right where
stephen nelson
stormed out yes after they gave up their
entire draft he wanted to sean watson
yeah and then we certainly yeah that too
if we circle all the way back around to
um
he's he's going to be the starter for
the steelers but if we don't think
there's a huge gap between him and can
he pick it
what are we doing like then we have an
open competition if we've got an open
competition let's play some football uh
i want you to kind of go into your
little notebook uh i'm sure you've been
making phone calls last night this
morning anything else that you're
hearing before we start focusing on the
buccaneers and kicking off round two
yeah the early guys you're gonna hear
today bruce hall is gonna be a hot name
he's clearly viewed as one you know the
best running back in this class the
athleticism the ability to be a pass
catcher as well he's a hot name that
teams in the top 40 are going i think
it's okay to take a running back now
because we think this guy can be special
right obviously travis jones is in that
light as well once again you're going to
see a very heavy wide receiver day today
the offensive line run kind of went uh
but boy mafia and arnold d mckady out of
the edge pass rushers along with nick
benito d'angelo malone guys like that uh
even sam williams and my jay sanders is
going to be another heavy pass rush day
we're not done after round one so those
are the big names as well and i think
there's going to be a lot of movement i
think there's a lot of phone calls right
now teams wanting to get up in this top
40 because they're looking at it and
going hey we got three guys left with
first round grades let's go up and get
one of those how many first round grades
do you have left let's take a look only
a handful it really went quick yesterday
and i'll be honest i was looking at my
sheets and i was using somebody else's
big board and it the first 23 all went
off so we didn't have a super high guy
fall which we sometimes have so how many
first rounds three first round grades
left for me uh i only did 24 this year
and for people at home that go how do
you not have you know obviously 32
that's not how you do it you you deem
players being worthy of that selection
you never have a draft where you have a
first rounder for every first round pick
that's just not how it works so i was
going to make the joke
yesterday that here at the bleacher
report draft that we're going to really
stay focused and we're going to talk
about football because that's what
tonight's about because when i grew up
there was nothing worse than them
talking about a jason aldean concert
instead of
i'm watching on nfl network right now
i think it's chris angel
i'm spinning around wearing just like a
leotard and i just want to say
sorry felder's leotard ripped yesterday
we can't do it um all right let's focus
on tampa bay tampa bay is a team 13-4
first in the nfc south lost to the rams
in the divisional round what an
off-season for them brady retires brady
unretires he comes back bruce arians
goes to the front office because
apparently there's an issue between tom
brady and bruce arians i wasn't even
planning on doing this but can i get
richard sherman really quick because
richard sherman played for this team
recently richard i
did you ever notice
anything between tom brady and bruce
arians when we're hearing all these
stories about the relationship or is
this just a media fabrication
it's a lot of speculation you know
obviously you know bruce and and
his group have been together for a long
time you know and he's been coached for
a long time he's 70 years old i think i
think it's more of a a time where it's
time for him to go be with his family
his grandkids and kind of kind of invest
less time in the football because he's
invested the majority of his life into
football and i think it's just it's just
one of those moments where it just came
at a time where he felt like he needed
to do something to keep his staff
because they're really like family he's
known a lot of those guys 20 30 40 years
from coaching some of them in college to
uh to being with them on that coaching
staff in college so i think it's just
one of those situations where the media
needed something you know there they
they heard you know some conversation or
somebody had a conversation with tom
where maybe there was something said
yeah and then they speculate the rest of
it you know and i think you never find
enough truth to did you think he was
going to stay retired you never hear
from bruce or were you one of the people
that were like i don't think he's done
no no no no he was never done i could
never believe that he was totally done
with football after the season he had an
outstanding season last year literally
was up for the mvp trophy and i don't
think you leave off that you know i
think if his arm felt like it's it's
thrown out and he can't do it or he
can't move where his body's aching he
takes great care of his body so i just
didn't see him sitting down after that
man especially he still had that hunger
it wasn't like he didn't put us in
position to win the last ball game you
know unfortunately cooper cup and matt
stafford had other plans but
i i i didn't think he could leave with
that kind of tasting though all right so
let's get your feel on this team right
here uh jpp damakunsu they're currently
free agents we don't know if gronk's
coming back so tight end could be an
option cornerbacks jamel dean and sean
murphy button they will be free agents
after this year levante david will be a
fridge after this year
knowing this roster what position do you
think they go here and also knowing this
team
uh i think they go corner you know i
think it's it's one of those like i said
it's a family atmosphere you know
they're going to give jpp time they're
going to give suit time and they're
going to see what they can get in this
draft you know but i think
at any point in time during the year
they're always open to have those guys
back you know i don't think they're
closing the door yeah on those guys and
you're probably circling both i think
that
no question no question i'm circling
booth because because of what you just
said i don't think he plays this year i
don't think they would need him to play
this year but they're like like
everybody saw i saw i experienced tampa
had a lot of injuries at the corner spot
last year and really got stretched thin
late in the late in the year and i don't
think they want to run into that issue
either way so i think having both in
there and in that room to back those
guys up initially maybe compete for a
starting spot just give them the kind of
depth they need to go forward awesome
yeah and i'll always richard thank you
so much for the insight i'll add on to
obviously what richard said is that i
mean they're gonna have a lot of free
agents on the back end in 2023 and you
know they've done a really good job
keeping their guys but todd bowles he
nobody takes care of the secondary more
than him so they're always going to be a
year ahead on that
and i mean booth is a guy that i sell
mocked in the first round a lot so the
value to get down here at the first pick
of the second round is definitely up
there if he was able to test throughout
this process uh booth
he had a good shot at being a first
rounder a former five-star good athlete
good measurables but he's been hurt i
believe he's had a hamstring issue a
couple different issues just hasn't been
able to test and that definitely kept
him out of the first round yeah he's
good
the kid's good i love the way he shoots
he is this is one of those guys that's
the shooter like he will take the risk
to come inside to kill a screen and i
love that about him because he does not
miss when he makes those decisions i
love the way that he's able to carry
underneath when he's in cloud coverage i
think that's beautiful helps your safety
out a little bit yeah because he knows
he's gonna rally to tackle and then he
also does something that i really find
interesting which is finding the ball
through the receiver when he's faced up
faced up and he's hit the hip with
somebody he's able to turn and look for
the ball it's not the same as when
you're weighing your backs to him
he looks and finds it through them so
he's still face to face with those guys
able to go make a play how many calls do
you think tip up bay has been getting
overnight oh this pick is insane but
let's not forget that they already moved
out of the first round so they probably
would really like to at some point you
want to make a pick
well that's what's interesting is all
three of these teams to start the second
round pretty much moved out tampa
minnesota and tennessee all traded down
to get this spot tampa i mean
minnesota
they had their pick last pick lewiston
tennessee they went traelin burks but
they still need some other do you think
there's any chance tennessee goes
another wide receiver
possibly i mean i know they brought in
robert woods obviously
but but they needed a wide receiver when
they had aj brown and so now it's
treylen burks robert woods is coming off
an acl yeah yeah and yeah and i looked
it up today brian tannehill's making 39
million dollars
and that you can't do anything with that
contract right no
but then again the sixers got rid of ben
simmons so you can get rid of bumps i
didn't mean to call ryan townhall bum
that was what does that mean that means
sky or christian anderson you have scott
moore there you saw george pickens in
play
speed but if you want to win right now
is george pickens the guy that you're
picking same same question with
christian watson right oh there yeah
points program yeah
it just is one of those things where
they they are in window mode am i wrong
about that oh yeah i mean number one
seen in the afc
how many more years of
of derek henry prime derek henry are you
gonna have left and so they've built
your entire team around they're in win
now mode so you i don't i don't know
that they can get who's probably the
best receiver on the board george
pickens
they can't get him he they can't take
the chance so we'll see what happens all
right so i'm looking right now the pick
is in so we will wait to see who our
hero is on twitter that will eventually
get us ahead of the broadcast we're
going to do our best to stay ahead of it
gabe running up and it is going to be
logan hall defensive tackle so we talked
about the fact that there is going to be
some possibility of changes up front but
that's where the buccaneers are going to
go logan hall
first pick of the second round logan
hall out of houston 6-6 283 a pretty
good athlete and the first pick for the
tampa bay bucks what do we think connor
i really like this one a great athlete
that at that size something felder and i
talk about a lot a tweener but in a good
way somebody that can play three tech
and be too quick for guards somebody
that can kick outside the five tech and
if you watch the film they had him
inside a lot at houston but he's gonna
get a chance to rush from the outside as
well use some of that power against
tackle so when you look at logan hall
really good tester really productive
player sideline to sideline chase speed
which is rare for an interior defensive
lineman and some a theme i heard about
the bucks or the last couple months is
we're used to seeing them get defensive
tackles that can contain that can
control their gaps they wanted a shooter
they wanted somebody that could fly
disrupt the quarterback so logan hall uh
a really really nice player for this
defense this is a b-plus pick right here
well for me i'll be quick i'm gonna go
with a-plus this guy wow he's a
first-round player he's a first-round
player that got picked at the top of the
second round what do you love about this
guy so i love you mentioned connor
mentioned he's a shooter i love the way
that he's able to not just see the gap
but get create penetration on his own
make himself skinny and that causes a
problem for offensive linemen i want to
hear i want to hear jason kelsey talk
about it when a guy can make himself
skinny kelsey what does that do when
you're trying to close down that gap or
move a guy
my own yeah absolutely i mean this kid
is
all over the place he uh he's got great
versatility he can play outside he can
play inside uh you just talked about
shooting the gap michael he uh he's got
a great arm over and he gets he's really
good at dipping that shoulder and get
into the gap and once he pierces the gap
it's over
i can see this guy playing first down
outside over the tight ends at like a
defensive end position and sliding down
second
down third down
or even you know just trying to create
disruption inside you see him in the
backfield a lot he plays through people
he hits the gaps well
um a really really solid player that
finishes
um you know i kind of reminds me a
little bit of eric armstead
out of san francisco you know he's he's
got a
lot length um you know plays big
all right thank you jason kelsey let's
go to somebody that knows the bucks very
well and dominican sue is a free agent
so let's bring in our guy richard
sherman your thought of them going logan
hall here at the first pick of the
second round
i think it's a great pick i think the
way todd bowles uses his defensive line
and and the versatility you know i mean
sometimes he has five downs sometimes he
has three down sometimes you know you
saw it with joe tryon last year you know
sometimes you'd see him lined up over
the center sometimes you'd see him 10
yards deep sometimes you see him
outside over the slot receiver i think
those kind of looks and that kind of
versatility that kind of it keeps the
offense on their heels constantly and i
think this is another piece for him to
put any place you know he may be on the
edge by himself he might be over the
center he may be in a three and a four
eye and a nine
and i think that's what todd is looking
for in all of his defensive linemen from
shaq barrett to joe trion to sue to even
be the veya you can see on the outside
so i think this is a great pick and it's
gonna be a great it's gonna be a lot of
fun for the kid love it richard sherman
you are the man we have a trade for the
second pick of this round packers giving
up two second round picks 53 and 59 to
go up to the vikings 34th pick
and who are they taking
christian watson the wide receiver they
heard all of the memes how are we going
to do this to aaron rodgers we need to
get him a wide receiver a small school
guy with a lot of potential christian
watson is now a member of the pack kick
return experience four touchdowns of at
least 65 yards last year
north dakota state what do we think of
the newest weapon for aaron rodgers
player comparison marquez valdos
scantling so they just lost to the chief
obviously they have a type uh this is
size and speed right an elite tester
there's going to be a growth period here
play strength i thought he had a really
nice week in mobile against higher tier
corners of course but once again with
christian watson play strength is going
to be an adjustment period for him so
this isn't a sure-fire answer right away
i like this as a long-term pick i think
in year two he'll be up to speed but a
great athlete that can get vertical for
that offense so i'll go in a minus i
like the aggression to solve wide
receiver and for me my 39th overall
player so the value checks out yeah for
me i'm going to go ahead i'm going to
give it a b plus i think that the key
for me with is his ability to grow in
the game and listen we know that aaron
rodgers is hard on his wide receivers
yeah so him taking that next step is
going to be a really really big ask
because again as we mentioned he's going
up two levels not just fb not just fcs
to fbs he's going fcs to the nfl and we
have seen this trey lance trying to do
that carson wentz did that well tried to
do it let's bring in a monroe st brown
amanra this is a guy from a smaller
school and he's going to a big situation
what did you see from him on tape
on tape i mean he's he's a big deep
threat guy they lost quez marcos vales
gatling to the chief so basically
replacing him in my eyes a deep threat
guy ran sub 4-4 at the combine 6-4 can
definitely run watch his tape ball in
his hand no one's catching him um the
only question i have is you know he
played what competition he was going
against in college right uh
some db's that he might have gone
against might and i've been the best
he's going to get to the nfl he's going
to see guys like pat pete and the
vikings
who we have on the line jeff okuda amani
i mean these guys are elite corners so i
think it's going to take some time to
adjust but you know hopefully you can
make that transition and be a weapon for
aaron i'm on ross st brown chiming in
and that will be the big player for
green bay christian watson the wide
receiver out of north dakota state
joining the green bay packers we're
keeping it moving titans staying with
their pick the third pick of the second
round going roger mccreery with the 35th
pick roger mccreery and our guy jordan
schultz breaking that one roger mccreary
first team all-american first team all
sec six interceptions in his career
described as the alpha of the secondary
by former defensive coordinator derek
mason who the titans just get yeah they
got a guy that's gonna have an
interesting transition period i thought
he played really well on the outside
while at auburn then he gets down to
mobile and they like working him out in
the slot because of lack of arm length
he just doesn't have length now to be
fair to roger mccreary when you turn on
the tape very sticky corner very sticky
in coverage where he puts himself in
position despite limited length to still
make a play on the football when it
comes his way so for the titans here a
guy that you might be kicking inside or
maybe you're comfortable you don't care
about the lack of length and say we
trust the tape instead we're going to
play him on the outside so they needed
help at this spot the value item is my
54th overall player and this is day two
we talked about that plateau where a lot
of these guys are very similar so this
is a b because i think he is a long term
number two maybe number three but more
likely number two corner at a key spot
for a team need yeah this is a team
that's got caleb farley elijah mullen
and christian fulton already so you
don't have to he doesn't have to do
anything immediately he's going to get
to learn he's going to get to play and i
remember early on the draft crash course
somebody on twitter was like then we
would never draft a corner we don't need
a corner and then they go and they get a
corner but he's a really good corner i
love i love mccreary i'm going to give
this a b-plus because when i watch him
play i see a guy with that you mentioned
it that's stick-to-itiveness and when
you come through with that
stick-to-itiveness that means that
you've got your plaster up against that
wide receiver so it doesn't matter how
long your arms are right and you're into
their body and i love the way that he
plays into the body it is interesting
caleb farley having the back and acl
injury last year so health might be an
issue that they're just worried about
richard sherman when you see mr mccreary
on tape who does he remind you of and
what do you think of his adjustment in
year one
i think he's gonna be fine you know i
think you you mentioned the injury
concerns with caleb farley and that's
that's true you know they play a lot of
man-to-man and your corners have to
stand up corners have to play 100 of the
snaps and this guy has played he's
played in the sec against some of the
best you've seen the receivers that have
come out of the sec out of alabama and
lsu and georgia and this guy has
competed against all of them and really
really held his own and i i really i
really don't have a true comparison to
him right now you know i mean he's so
he's kind of bulky you know he's well
built corner he's aggressive like you
said people make a lot of
comments about arm length and you can
have the longest arms in the world and
not be able to play you can have great
arm length and all the measurables and
not be sticky and covered so i really
dismiss a lot of those concerns can the
guy play turn on the tape put him out
there against good competition and let
him play and and the concerns about
moving into the slot it's just different
it takes time to adjust to that a guy
who's been playing on the edge his whole
career isn't just gonna just bump into
inside and just be like hey this is the
same thing it's not the same thing you
don't have the sidelines the route
combinations are different so it takes
an adjustment but with good coaching and
repetitions i think he'll be fine but i
still think he's an outside corner
richard sherman i remember after you
took over the nfl people were just
drafting long cornerbacks and go and
he's just like richard sherman and i was
like no richard's a one-of-one stop
looking at arm length richard you're the
man we'll be back to you in a second
because we have a trade that we have to
get to the jets have traded up with the
giants keeping it in new york
interesting 38 and 146 so i believe
that's like a fifth round pick trading
bro because i wanted to see more michael
carter but here's your second round pick
for the jets they trade up to take them
workhorse back and i heard a lot of this
chatter today that they like michael
carter right they got michael carter in
the fourth round last year but maybe
you're one b or you're you're 2a kind of
guy well bruce hall 1a 1b every down
pass catcher great athlete throwback
comp here for you guys deuce mcallister
very similar measurables test the same
feel as a runner that's the most
important thing to know with bree salt
you can look at him and go 6-1 tackle
breaker excellent outside burst
excellent moves in the open field
the natural feel as a runner in my
lafleur's outside zone scheme is the
most important thing to take away here
and they needed a guy that can be on
there on third downs and be able to
catch the ball as well you see the
breakaway speed this has been a problem
for the jets offense they just haven't
had big playability you draft garrett
wilson 10th you think elijah moore is
going to really turn the corner and have
a big second year and now you got
somebody in the backfield run heavy team
they spent a lot of resource on the
offensive line michael carter he got
injured last year as well you needed
another running back this was the guy
and this is one of my best players
available when you look at the big board
for breeze hall right here let's see
where he's sitting he's sitting at
number 30. so i don't like taking
running backs in the first round after
that i don't care if they're a good
enough player this is what the 35th pick
yes 30th overall player yeah this is a
b-plus for me because this was low-key
you need if michael carter got hurt
again they don't have anybody
yeah i watched them last year and it
would be a little tevin coleman it'd be
a little ty johnson i was like there's
no identity this is your identity do you
is he a felder guy yeah
i love this dude i think the only reason
he didn't go in the first round is
because iowa state wasn't that good this
year if we're being quite frank i think
that his stock dropped because his team
stock dropped people stopped watching
them stop watching what they were able
to do he is an every down all-around
running back he will step up and stick
his nose in it and pass pro but watching
him run the football you mentioned that
outside zone scheme this is a guy he's
going to come to the line of scrimmage
and then he's going to press hard and
then once he probes pros finds his spot
he'll stick his foot in the ground and
go he runs out of arsenal mike lafleur
offense which comes from kyle shanahan
that's perfect exactly and he can do it
he's done it in college he's going to we
talked about seeing it on film yes we've
seen it on film we've seen him break
tackles we've seen him use that build up
speed as you call it yeah he's not going
to out 40. right he's not going to
outburst you but if you block it up
right and he breaks a tackle the next
thing you know he's running past and let
me tell you once he gets chugging along
safety's not going to want to tackle
this sucker because he's got some he's
got some size to him 439. love the way
that he weaves what's your grade oh for
me grade i'm listen i'm gonna go with an
a he's the best running back in the
draft you get him a couple picks into
the second round and he's someone that
can come in and help you immediately oh
by the way now i mentioned pass bro he
can catch the ball out of the backfield
as well he will be a safety valve zach
wilson is going to fall in love with
this yep
all right the draft is moving right
along they have not announced on tv yet
the jets pick but we're going to take
our time to announce the texans pick
because why wait texans are
taking baler safety jalen is that petri
petri petri jalen petri is the pick
consensus first team all-american big 12
defensive player of the year i love this
the only fbs player with at least three
fumble recoveries three force fumbles
and two interceptions
and he studies tape a safety for the
texans here connor how does the value
stack up man it's pine he's 46 overall
player once again second round great we
got a ton of guys with second round
grade when you look at peter reminds me
of jordan whitehead who just got a lot
of money from the team to pick for this
the new york jets he plays the slot he
can play in the box he's physical he's
got good range he's got good speed and
then everybody was like kenny cover can
he do this can he do that once again he
gets down to the senior bowl he was the
best safety and coverage there running
with running backs he's really good
making a play on the football he hits
like a ton of bricks i like jalen petry
a lot there's a lot of different ways
you can use him and this is a football
team that obviously lost you know jordan
justin justin reid
when you lose justin reed this is your
surefire replacement he can handle the
same kind of role so beautiful i'm i'm a
big petrie fan here uh this is an a
minus for me i think he's gonna have a
really really productive career i love
this dude yeah you fist pumped yeah i
fist pump he's on my list as one of my
faves why uh he the idea that he if
there's a question if he can cover means
you didn't watch him because he played
in the big 12 pass happy he covered a
ton and i love the way that he's able to
stick to guys and i also love the way
that he shoots this is a guy that's
going to come in and he's going to shoot
that gap to go make a play when it comes
to the screen game when it comes to
playing in zone and checking crossers he
will come down and destroy the hit he
had on mims from oklahoma was an
absolute nightmare kill shot this guy's
super physical i got to give it an a
he's he's i mean i just i love the way i
love the way he plays lovey smith right
now building out the secondary derek
stingley early on now jalen petry let's
ask our second secondary specialist
richard sherman what do you think of
this safety petri
i think he's just what you said i think
he's a carbon copy of jordan whiteheads
he plays fast he's really decisive i
like what they're doing you know they
had one of the worst pass defenses in
football last year so they're addressing
that early and often and i don't i don't
think they're expecting these picks to
you know they get to learn they get to
go out there and learn you know if they
win a few games this year i don't think
they're expecting themselves to win a
super bowl this year i think they're
building for the future and i think
these are cornerstone pieces and i think
he he'll do a great job of placing what
justin reed was able to do but you
really have a hard time replacing that
leadership but i think them drafting a
corner with the number three pick and
stingley and safety and allowing them to
grow together is the best way thing to
do in a secondary in 2021 thank you
richard sherman jalen petrie played
431 coverage snaps
how many penalties he had
zero not a single one which is pretty
darn impressive jalen petry joining the
houston texans and lovey smith the
giants trade down again so they picked
up some picks the falcons move up from
43. maybe 238
and what's interesting is that means the
falcons felt the need to jump the
seahawks because the seahawks are
sitting there with two we talked about
maybe this is a quarterback we talked
about maybe the falcons want to do this
but both of those teams have offenses
which they like mobility at the
quarterback position arthur smith what
pete carroll's been doing
but
it's a defensive end
so
i just hyped it up i hooked it up but it
is
arnold abacati
dynamite dynamite i love this selection
so the falcons trade up to get these to
a second team all-american arnold
abacati uh recipient of the 2021 iron
lion award for strength and conditioning
had a tackle of loss in all but one
games this year what what are they
getting from him uh the kid out of penn
state connor a new version of unique way
to me that's a little bit more of a
compact rusher stand up speed rusher
often use a wide rusher he can cross
your face he can win inside he can
flatten into the pocket man he is strong
he is stout he's explosive i mean the
testing metrics really got him over the
hump to be a top 40 player after
exploding at penn state he was a temple
player transfers to penn state we know
what everybody does in that weight room
and that strength and conditioning
program he looked great on film this
year he has strength to drive tackles
back into the pocket but he's got enough
quickness and once again you see the
testing numbers here six nine five three
cone that's an important metric for pass
rushers 38 inch vertical your
explosiveness that's an excellent
excellent number that is freakish long
arms it helps him win i love abba katie
uh he's a top 30 player for me this
falcons team has no idea what it's like
to get after the quarterback he is going
to change that this is an a for me it's
pretty interesting that the two teams
that john abraham did so well on was the
jets and the atlanta foul and then no
one ever did anything again exactly what
do you think of this kid i love him i
think he's fantastic the big it's
interesting you mentioned yannick and
gokai because when i look at him
excuse me i kind of see
oh my god just don't die i see a i say
no i see a um kind of a uh
i see a little bit of a poor man's car
leftist right and but the problem for me
i think his hands are heavy and that's
the scary part he's got these heavy like
hands of stone you know what i mean he's
just club people yeah he's just as a
beast heavyweight fighter yes exactly
and he that's what he brings to the
table for me he is someone who is so
strong physically he's going to make you
tired over the course of the game you're
going to not want to block him you're
not going to want to have to put him to
put his paws on you whether he's
tackling you and you see him there like
that's the guy you don't want him laying
on you all the time man after he tackles
you you don't want him to get that full
extension on you when you're an
offensive lineman he's got the ability
to do all those things it's to me this
is an apic i think that he is someone
that's going to be really special at the
next level if you're the falcons you
have now you have an opportunity to find
ways to get to the quarterback i love
the fact that he did stand up at penn
state because i think that shows a
little bit of versatility but if it's me
let me put his let me put his hand on
the ground on third down and go get that
quarterback i mean at 62 250 you got to
be able to stand dean p's always good at
putting those guys and hiding them in
coverage but this is a team that was
last in sacs in the nfl uh they had 18
they were 11 fewer than the team that
was in 31st that's terrifying there were
19 teams in the nfl that had two times
as many sacks as the falcons last year
they go out there they get the biggest
wide receiver and now they get a speed
a good rusher on the outside with heavy
hands in arnold evocati so the giants
have now moved down twice they've
scooped up more picks
we're kind of seeing what's going on
connor hughes again no relation to
connor rogers getting a text best
running back in the draft talking about
the guy that you guys took um breese
hall we are now at 39 which is the
chicago bears the chicago bears have yet
to draft this will be their first pick
in the draft for them uh of course they
gave up their first round pick to the
giants last year in order to get justin
fields first time seeing him first time
with a new gm ryan pohl's new head coach
matt eberflus
have you heard anything about this team
trenches trenches ryan paul's offensive
line background obviously a great job uh
you know not learning behind the scenes
but growing behind the scenes in kansas
city and now he's got his shot with ibra
floose you're going to obviously build
in the front seven as well he'll value
cover players let's see where they're
going here kyler gordon yeah
i think the offensive line is terrifying
right now it's my first reaction to this
pick and i like tyler gordon
so you thought they'd go bigger but
they'd look at bernard raymond
but they're going with a cornerback the
chicago bears with their first pick in
the draft go with the first team all
pac-12 corner out of washington kyler
gordon you see there with the 4-5-2
zero penalties the last two seasons but
a lot of snaps and he has a childhood
background in dancing and kung fu just
wanted to get that in there connor but
where did you expect him to go in this
dress right around here 43rd overall
player i really like kyler gordon and
he's going to be a nice player for the
chicago bear scene i'm a little worried
about their offensive needs i'm a little
worried about the development of justin
fields right now it does not look good
on paper there but let's make this kyler
gordon's moment right somebody that is a
little different than trent mcduffie the
the washington corner that went in the
first round he's got a little bit more
length he's got excellent ball skills uh
he he flashed a lot in man and obviously
played a lot of zone as well i think he
can get hands on you he can turn and run
down the field he has very good twitch
very good agility he's somebody that it
all looks there the part now the
instincts are catching up he's not on
the same level with mcduffie in terms of
instincts that's why stylistically he
reminds me of somebody that could be
like casey hayward a top flight zone
corner that plant and drive that get
downhill and find the football kind of
player uh athletically he is very very
impressive he's a one-year starter so
you have to understand that it's going
to take a little while to get going but
for me i like the player i'll go with an
a minus i think two years from now he's
going to be in a really good place this
is an eberflus led defense where he was
able to really develop some young
players in indianapolis and make it
happen and other than jaylen johnson not
a lot of depth is he a felder guy though
i like him i think he's really he's not
a felder guy
yeah okay that's what i just learned
that's right i like him i think he is a
good player i like him in zone better
than i like him in man i like the fact
that he's able to
come off i like the the way that i the
best the thing i like the most about him
is that he can see through the receiver
see through the zone he matches but then
he can come off and go make a tackle we
saw that on the clips that we watched
i'm gonna go with the b plus here i
think he's a good player i think that as
you fit him into this scheme that's
where he can grow the idea for him is
gonna be where do you play him and how
does he get up to speed as a guy that
hasn't played as much football as some
of the other corners that we've seen
that's the biggest thing right that's
what you've got to wonder it's going to
take a little while i can't precise that
enough a one-year starter it's going to
take a little bit sherman what do you
think when you hear a guy with not a ton
of experience but then also
what he'll be asked to do with the
chicago bears defense
well i'm really excited because i've
known the kid since he was uh since he
was a high schooler and uh he's worked
out with tracy ford this four sports
performance facility that bobby wagner
and a lot of the seahawks work out at
and so he's been training with nfl guys
for a really really really long time
he's going to develop really well he's a
heck of a player he's competitive he's
competitive as all get out you know when
there was covet 19 season we were out
there holding seven on sevens and he was
holding his own with nfl players josh
gordon was out there dk metcalf was out
there and he's covering guys like that
and this is this is when he was younger
in college when he was a freshman so i i
expect him to have a lot of success he's
a guy that works hard he's really smart
i think he'll fit well in this system
and he'll be a a really good player in
the future really good insight let's go
to more insight amon ross st brown
apparently you faced this guy so what it
what was it like facing kyler gordon
yeah i remember playing him my sophomore
year when i was in college and he was a
young player
like you said last year was his first
year starting so when we played him he
was rotating in and out but what stood
out to me most about his game was he
wasn't afraid to tackle you watch the
tape he's in there making plays and i
remember actually one play why i caught
the ball he attacked me pretty well so
that's one thing that stood out to me
he's not afraid to put his head in there
and as a db that's something i think
every defensive coordinator wants is a
db that sticks in here and make a tackle
so i'm excited for him especially in the
nfc north i mean that's great insight we
learned about his offseason practicing
from richard sherman and the fact that
he hit a monroe st brown well enough
that he remembered it we don't remember
all the times we get tackled but we
remember when people tackle us well it
sounds like there's a good identity
match between him and the chicago bears
and you have to think this is the first
pick for matt eberflus and he said i
under i know we want to turn around this
offense but i need to have my identity
and my stamp and i'm a defensive guy and
i need my weapons we're going to let
luke gets gutsy figure out the offense
now we are at back-to-back seahawks
picks there is a chance that we are
going to see the quarterback come off
the board of malik willis they could
maybe make us wait for the second one
they could do it right away for the
first one they have not announced the
bears pick on tv yet so we are still
ahead but there's a few guys that are
still out there nicobe dean has not been
taken andrew booth has not been taken uh
and then of course as i mentioned malik
willis connor what are we thinking here
if we're going to do an early guess man
i would think this is where you throw
that dart for malik willis what do you
have to lose here you're picking
back-to-back right so you're playing
with house money let's just make that
very clear right here you're playing
with house money where you could still
get something that's a little bit more
sure fire right out of the second round
um now if they really want to go crazy
and invest in the offensive line again
you still have bernard raymond on the
board i don't think they'll do that in
this class after taking charles cross
but that is an offensive line that has
needed a lot of long-term work and then
when you look at defense they need a
corner andrew booth should absolutely be
in play in this spot i think for me and
they still need a pass rusher as well so
i would not sleep on athletically boye
mafe is absolutely the type of player
seattle traditionally they like they
like to take felder i want you to chime
in but first let's just take a quick
peek at the seattle seahawks room let's
see what they're talking about right now
uh say daddy if we should take malik
i'll say daddy i want to see it huh
uh i'm seeing and i'm seeing a lot of
people writing daddy uh so people want a
leak i just think people aren't that
comfortable going into the season with
drew locke but let's say malik is one
then the other one you could go corner
uh trey brown had a season ending knee
injury sydney jones is a free agent at
the end of the year offensive line
anyone that's trying to get out to you i
like the boy mafia i think the corner
andrew booth makes a lot of sense i'm
very curious um
about i was going to ask about matt
corral because oh as we get deeper into
the draft
now we start to see what what does value
mean to you if you're if you're taking
that guy and if a hell would you rather
have a healthy macaron or healthy
malware malik willis i would prefer
malik willis okay personally i just
think the he has the body type to
actually be an effective runner at the
next level with the rocket arm they both
have great arms yes that's not in the
discussion here at all matt corral likes
to run yes the problem is i don't swim i
don't know if that frame is going to
hold up in the nfl as a runner all the
time i would prefer malik yeah i just
wanted to get that in there because it's
a great conversation as we start to get
as it as it gets as he goes it gets
lower and lower now all of a sudden we
start to see teams that
were eyeballing corral and it was corral
versus hal for them now they're yes
willis versus corral i'm i'm also
wondering because you talked about
offensive lineman are there any
offensive linemen left that are still at
a certain tier that might evaporate well
they need a center cam jergens is
somebody that you gotta get because cole
strange was the surprise of yesterday's
draft linder bomb not shocking so cram
jergens is the center that okay get him
or you're looking at a way different
here i'm gonna say jamari sawyer there
you go if they need a guard if you need
a guard yep jamari sawyer was the guy
that played left jamar sorry helped
georgia
offensively jamar sawyer is the reason
they won the national championship game
wow he started at left tackle and then
they said we cannot do anything with
this alabama defensive front they moved
him into guard and then all of a sudden
that long james cook run that's because
of jamari sawyer so yeah he's my he's my
favorite in terms of those interior
linemen we talked about him a ton on the
draft class draft crash course i think
that he's another guy that should be
high on folks board because he's got a
great opportunity to be to be an instant
impact guy so pick 41 is their pick that
they've already had pick 40 is the one
that they got for russell wilson this is
a new identity for the seattle seahawks
team finished seven and ten i cannot
remember the last time that they
finished fourth in the nfc west now the
nfc west is kind of open but i will say
this i feel like kyler's happy now
because now he has hollywood brown so
that storyline might be fading off a
little bit the niners we're still trying
to figure out is it jimmy g are they
going to give it fully to trey lance
what's going on with debo there seems to
be unrest there
but you look at the seahawks and the
rams are the super bowl champions right
but we haven't seen them pick yet
they're still a good team but they have
a lot of holes when you look at that
roster right a lot of guys left so i
think the the west was the class of the
nfl last year and i think it has fallen
off in a huge way there's opportunity
now i agree with your regression theory
with the west here's my number one
question with seattle that i i can't
answer i truly can't figure it out are
they with the oldest coach in the nfl
and pete carroll are they do they
believe they're a win-now team and
people might laugh at that with drew
locke is the quarterback well i'm asking
do they think they're a win-now team
they haven't traded dk metcalf they took
charles cross i loved that pick right
are they building a foundation now is
this going to be another offensive line
pick because it's still not complete yet
are they building a foundation for the
next quarterback or is this going to be
take the best player on the board is it
going to be boye mafe or can they draft
and stash for david jabo right if they
don't think they're a win now team
this pick should teach us about seattle
yes what they think what they think they
are where they or where they think they
are because
if you go get someone that can play
right now that does feel like they're in
win now well to me to be honest trading
russell wilson means you're not
because if you're trying to win now you
don't trade russell wilson if you're
trying to rebuild you
trade russell wilson
is richard available can richard sherman
comment on this uh i mean
yeah what do you think man like where do
you think the seahawks are or in terms
of as a franchise
i don't think they're in win now mode i
think they're a year away i think
they're looking forward to the
quarterbacks that are coming out next
year i think that's where they're
putting their focus i don't think
you trace your franchise quarterback
away and think hey
we have drew locke and we're about to
really go go after him you know you
don't have no line you let dwayne brown
walk you drafted a rookie but ricky
needs development at the left tackle
spot like it's a hard learning curve and
the past rushers that you have in this
division are going to going to make it a
hard learning curve you still got to
deal with bolsa you still got to deal
with aaron donald you still got to deal
with leonard floyd so it's i don't think
it's a win now i think the people pieces
they're gonna draft will show you that
even if they draft a quarterback i don't
think you're expecting to play now if
they don't draft the quarterback i
expect the quarterback run to be next
year for them
all in to get a quarterback next year
all right pick us in richard those guys
are gonna let's do it my guess is travis
oh boy mafia there we go so there is a
guy this is what they do a lot of front
offices have philosophies so makes sense
what do you think of bowie mafia i love
boya mafe is one of the best players on
the board this is a john schneider kind
of guy athletically now when you look up
the production it's kind of funny
because he's kind of the same story as
trayvon walker but he didn't go number
one overall he's a different kind of
player but he didn't go and have a
breakout monster double-digit sack here
but you turn on the tape the ability to
change direction the explosive first
step all of those things are there at
boye mafee why he was the 31st overall
player for me reminds me of marcus
davenport who came into the league in a
very similar situation high expectations
and you look at it and go okay he's
going to need a little time but
athletically we think it's all there and
we've seen that light to start to turn
on with davenport boy mate needs a
little seasoning but i like this one a
lot good value here for seattle as well
a they've had two great picks so far to
be 260 at 6'4 and run a 4-5-3 with a
1-5-6 10-yard split explosion that is
explosive and he can change direction
short area well that's what i loved
about even just a clip we just showed
was watching the way that he was patient
with his feet but then instant explosion
side to side to go get to the
quarterback after the play busted so he
has the ability to do all those things
mafe is a guy obviously playing in
minnesota where you see him come off the
edge let's go make a play explosive off
the edge that's where you see that 10
yard split come in lefko you see him
here lined up wide you see him get
hemmed up don't worry i can disengage
i'll get back downhill to go make a play
i love to see that too guy's showing me
effort first move doesn't work i'm gonna
keep going jump down inside on a little
bit of a slant he can do that as well so
i love what he brings to the table he is
someone that is going to give you his
effort all the time played for a school
where a lot of folks weren't checking
for their defense a lot of folks weren't
checking for what they were able to do
but he continued to be consistent
continue to be productive and i think
the big key with him and i'm gonna go
ahead and give this a b plus because of
the value that they're getting for the
pick yes and the only reason the only
reason they didn't go all the way to an
a is as as as richard said if they're
not in win now mode why not go get the
little more explosive guy in a jabbo and
sit on them if next year is the plan
yeah right and you know what they have
another pick so it might maybe they go
back to back oh wow because i'm i'm
looking at them right now they need it
left though other than ucheno uwosu they
really don't i'm not like he's a big
sack guy they only had 34 sacks last
year which is bottom 10 in the nfl but
this is a team that they just lost
so many identity pieces not just richard
sherman on i mean richard sherman
russell wilson on offense kenneth walker
is the second pick pete carroll's
another running back ultimate pete pick
here
if you want to talk about identity then
it's a running back going to
the seattle seahawks the doke walker
award winner led
fbs with 89 forced missed tackles and
yards after catch only two career
fumbles
in his entire career at michigan state
but only 19 catches this running back
here what do you think for the seahawks
yeah i don't think there's much in the
pass game that has proven i don't think
it's in pass protection or as a pass
catcher and they didn't use him that way
as a pure runner he's right up there at
the top of this class a tackle breaker
shifty i'd like to seem to be even more
physical thick lower frame player
comparison for me was deangelo williams
little surprised seattle felt the need
to go running back here i had other
needs prioritized for them in the top 50
picks obviously they had three top 50
picks 56th overall player so i'll go
with the b minus here because kenneth
walker has a super high floor he's a
great runner but i just don't like what
seattle's draft strategy is in this pick
after a great pick in boye maffe listen
i i like him i think he's a good player
i love what he was able to do at wake
forest then he got into an offense that
was more conducive to what he was able
to do and he really exploded but he's a
touchdown machine at either school i'm
going to be quick my wife went to
michigan state so i'm going to go ahead
and give it an a
i love the curve the the thing that
might be interesting just for reference
as we bring in richard sherman is rashad
penny and chris carson will be free
agents after this year but i heard
richard sherman that you were very
excited to talk about this why
i am because this is pete this is pete
carroll you know it's always been a run
first play defense kind of philosophy
and that's where he's going to lean on
this year you know they're going to run
the football you you saw last year
everybody killed them on the um rashad
penny pick years ago and this year he
finally blossomed he was running the
heck out of the ball he had a four or
five 150 yard plus games this is they're
going to build on that they're going to
expect this guy their stable of backs to
really push them um this entire season
you know they're going to keep the ball
out of drew lock or whoever the
quarterback is going to be this year
geno hands and really allowed the
defense in the run game to shorten the
game and try to sneak out some wins i
expect that to be his philosophy that
was his philosophy when we won super
bowl and when we went back to the super
bowl we run the ball with marshawn lynch
we play great defense and the
quarterback don't turn the ball over
that's how that's how they win and i
think that's what he's trying to build
again i think you you might be on to
something because they did miss a lot of
games from their running backs but they
have that stable so now it's chris
carson rashad penny travis homers like
their change of pace back dj dallas is
there and now kenneth walker where do
you think conor kenneth walker is going
to rank in that room right away when
they go out there to the field and just
look at them right i mean he's going to
be the best pure runner i can't have and
that's a good room it's a really good
room but he in my opinion is the best
pure runner obviously young legs uh once
again thick lower body
really really good short area now he's
there he needs time he needs seasoning
on third downs he's not seeing the field
as a pass protector as a pass catcher
but as a pure runner he would be the
dude in my opinion that room by the
second half of the year yeah it's hard
to i mean here we are talking about
jordan davis being a two two down uh
defensive lineman you got a two down
running back you're almost signaling to
the defense what we're doing here that's
what i was going to say is how hard is
going to be to get him in the game if
you know that when he's in the game he's
getting the fight i just think people
really need to look at the seahawks
defensive depth chart right now to
realize how many other positions they
probably had to address yeah uh and then
also looking at this offense and
i guess richard's right they don't want
to do the quarterback here and since
they don't want to do the quarterback
they're just going to completely punt
and it's going to be a geno smith drew
lock offseason battle but we are getting
to one of the best gm's in the nfl chris
ballard picking here at 42 it is the
colts first pick of their draft and it
is an interesting one because they have
an off season in which they got matt
ryan psych the vikings have traded up uh
remember they traded back i believe from
34 with green bay and they took 53 and
59 and now they are going to move up to
42 with indy what were you saying
they've moved i think three or four
times yes so dapha mensah it's his first
year as a gm he's having he's having his
fun right here yeah so we are not sure
which picks they gave up and of course
we will be waiting to see uh which way
they go minnesota ending our first round
by going with louisiana the safety out
of georgia and now they're sitting here
maybe needing some interior defensive
linemen possibly needing a cornerback in
addition to that safety
where are you thinking they could go
here i think quietly what a lot of
people miss with minnesota is they do
need a receiver justin jefferson is a
stud adam thielen is getting up there
he's dealt with injuries and i'm sure
they'd like to move off the money maybe
after this season so quietly they need a
receiver i like skye moore for them a
lot this is where you have george
pickens come into play at his earliest
uh sky moor would be the ideal one there
and once again i can't emphasize it
enough i just would not entirely rule
out a quarterback selection even with
kirk cousins money on the books right
now
what do you think here i mean i think
the pickets thing is the most intriguing
one for me uh he's a guy that i've
talked about plenty of times you know
that i like him
if he comes off the board here he does
provide the idea of having pickens and
jefferson on opposite sides of the field
as stealing ages out that that to me
that's terrifying both of those guys can
scoop both of those guys can go up and
get the ball
[Music]
and we have a pick and it is going to be
andrew booth the cornerback out of
clemson that we thought maybe could go
in the first round but he goes here to
the minnesota vikings at 42. first team
all acc
35 games 15 starts was the number two
cornerback in that 2019 recruiting class
behind derek stingley was only penalized
one time in three years to get him here
at 42 connor yeah i like it 50th overall
player corner class started to fall off
a cliff we saw mccreery and kyler gordon
already go off the board he just hasn't
been able to work out during the draft
process and that hurt his stock where
you're right lefko he could have went in
the first round so why can't he work out
he's been dealing with the hammy
yeah so he's had a little bit of injury
issues second round grade value makes
sense a little over aggressive at times
he's got to reel that back there's
sometimes where he's so jacked up that
he comes in and misses some tackles uh
carlton davis light is how i describe
him david is obviously a scheme diverse
player so i like this pick rock solid i
need good value it's a b yeah i love him
i i think he's amazing i love the way
again this is a guy we saw him down that
play shoot down james cook in that
clemson versus uh georgia game just chop
his legs up get the ball out do all the
things you want him to do you see him
playing coverage in the back end this is
a guy that is scheme versatile venables
when he's at clemson he asks those guys
to play cover zero cover one cover two
cover three cover four right he did all
those things and i love that about him
he's this he does not fit into that mole
that we've talked about with the other
guys where he's a man corner he's his
own corner yes he's a guy that did
everything i'm going to give it an a
because i think he's a first round
talent that you're able to get a little
bit later it felt like there was a four
or five year span where minnesota kept
drafting cornerbacks and i look at their
roster and none of them are there
anymore they have had constant turnover
they go secondary now with both picks
but andrew booth richard sherman what do
you think in this ed donatell defense
but first what do you think of him as a
player who are they getting here
they're getting the playmaker you know
they're getting a guy who who's very
intelligent who can make plays on the
football who can take the football away
and anytime you're facing aaron rodgers
twice a year you need that detroit is
going to be up and coming soon chicago
is going to going to find a way to be
competitive so i think you need corners
and dbs and that's why they went dbs
with the first two picks they've had i
think that he's a heck of a player i
mean they haven't had a really
consistent pro bowl all-pro style corner
since zay rhodes left years ago and he
was freaking the most consistent you're
competing with megatron and zay adams i
mean tay adams all the time i think that
he can be similar you know he can be as
consistent he can be that kind of player
for them if they continue to build
around him like i said before them
allowing drafting a safety at the same
time and then having harrison smith
they're going to allow them to grow
together and that's the best way to
build a secondary allow them to grow
together to thrive together to make
mistakes together and really realize
what they can what they're capable of
harrison smith undoubtedly will help
bring along lewis scene and you have to
imagine that pat pete is going to help
bring along andrew booth richard sherman
thank you so much and we want to give
thank you to our sponsor our draft
coverage brought to you by rocket
mortgage if you're looking for an edge
in the home buying market you've got to
go with rocket mortgage verified
approval can help you compete in a
crowded market and boy is it crowded
today give you the edge you need that is
rocket mortgage we want to thank them
for sponsoring our draft coverage
finally going to see the new york giants
but do you have something for me yeah
the picks live okay and who is it going
to be conor uh wandel robinson the
kentucky
not fully gadget player he's a wide
receiver but really the true gadget
player of this draft there was a lot of
talk about them trying to move kendarius
tony their first round pick out of
florida that had a lot of questions and
this is the kind of guy that you would
think fits into that do everything roll
it is wendell robinson what do you what
do you think about this value here i
don't love it 90th overall player this
is the giant's about a killer draft but
this one to me here tells me that one
they do not like darius tony because
this guy plays the same exact role uh so
that's not a good sign less athletic
rondelle moore is who i compared him to
when i look at wandel robinson
he's a guy that can play in the slot
when you get the ball in his hands and
manufacture touches he can make things
happen there's no doubt about that i
just look at the giants right now and i
would have went for a more true wide
receiver i like skye more better i
obviously like george pickens better i
even think jalen tolbert and john metchi
were better players in this spot so he
this is a gadget player he's really
effective at forcing missed tackles but
the value just seems a round off for the
giants here so i'll go with the c they
have a very interesting wide receiver
room right now very short arms very
thick it would be zero percentile in the
nfl today his arms are 27 and 5 8. his
wingspan is 67 and 5 8. i can't remember
the last time i saw there is no other
wide receiver in this draft with arms
shorter than 70 and he's at 67 which is
very interesting did you watch a lot of
kentucky this year yeah and i watched a
lot of nebraska too so there's the thing
100 catches a hundred catches at
kentucky but that's not the bulk of his
career the bulk of his career is at
nebraska where he had 51 catches and 46
of rushes in
in his sophomore year then we go to that
we go to the freshman as a true freshman
this guy called 88 balls and then 40
touches as a as a running back he does
he's the true gadget player of the strap
i really like him you do i like him a
lot i think he's a really good football
player i think that he's got the ability
to be really skilled i don't care about
the measurables in terms of length i
think that the reality of it is you find
a way to get the ball in his hands and
then he's gonna find a way to make
people miss the numbers that he's put up
he's been productive from day one this
is a kid that was supposed to be one of
the saviors for scott frost and then
scott frost fumbled the bag yes he did
and wandel was like don't worry i'm
taking it to kentucky they used them
more as a true wide receiver than
nebraska did i think this is an a it
doesn't matter i don't know i don't care
where he fits like in terms of the value
board and this is the problem that's no
disrespect to you at all i love this guy
as a player he is a football player he
will go out and get the job done he will
play in the slot he will play truly in
the run in the backfield as a running
back if you ask him to to me he's a
little bit of percy harvin light that's
what i see out of this player he's tough
he's physical he wants he will run into
the interior if you ask him to which is
what he did for nebraska a lot of times
sterling shepard is a free agent after
this year the issues with candarius tony
it makes sense galaday's your big guy
you can do slating down the down the
side and you got him everywhere amon
ross saint brown wendell robinson
thoughts
you know what he reminds me about lester
tavon austin in college not as fast
but when i watched this tape i actually
watched this tip earlier this morning
and with the bonus hands he's making
dudes miss his one cut his sticks i mean
he's just special with the ball in his
hands i don't know how of an elite rock
running he's going to be at the next
level i think his size might hurt him a
little but if he can get that ball in
his hands whether that's on kick return
punt return
a pitch out the backfield a reverse i
think he's dangerous with the ball in
his hand so we'll see
he is apparently electric giants going
back to that well after their pick last
year apparently is not sitting well in
the organization wendell robinson the
pick for the giants at 43. you know what
he is
from a staff that came over from buffalo
right obviously with brian dabel isaiah
mckenzie
that's what this is this is their isaiah
mckenzie now once again i agree with
felder and and i'm on rod like this you
know what he is and you like what he
does yeah do you take that player in the
second round i i just don't that's my
biggest thing i do yeah your thing is
looking at my board maybe we can get him
later because the giants have traded
down a few times and they have
accumulated more picks but they
apparently thought
we need that guy that can run reverses
like we had with isaiah mckenzie out
there in buffalo and he was a he would
touch the ball like five six times a
game and when he made manufactured ways
yes oh it was fun
it's free yards for your quarterback
right pitch passes things like that
they're making life easy for daniel
jones cleveland browns are now up and
this is the cleveland browns first pick
of the draft they traded three
first-round picks for deshaun watson we
are still wondering what is going to
happen with baker mayfield they have
seven picks total right here i look at
their team they do need a defensive end
opposite miles garrett janavian county
right now still a free agent they
definitely need help at defensive
tackles three of their four starters on
their d-line no longer on the team malik
mcdowell malik jackson gone and you saw
what larry ogunjobi did when he went to
cincinnati either of those the biggest
need or is there another guy that jumps
out they also did a lot of work on this
receiver class now i know that was
before they traded their first rounder
for desean watson i heard they were all
over jamison williams so when you look
at that does your mind go to maybe skye
moore that 10 yard split is very
explosive acceleration that's what i
think of they want more size speed we
keep saying it george pickens jalen
tolbert so i don't think they're out on
the wide receivers here they got them
mary cooper we know that but they're
they want more they want an explosive
offense in the afc
yeah i did the thing for me when i look
at them they're they have they've got
needs right yes they've got them and so
i wonder if i don't know if travis jones
is a great scheme
i was going to say that would be my
guess but
he's the best val that would be an a
plus for me uh first round player
there's only
three left yeah once again none of them
are gone i compared him to marcel darius
we have another trade so the browns are
trading back with houston so houston
went jalen petrie uh and they stayed at
their pick and it looks like houston is
going to be moving up i do not see any
other picks in this round so they must
be packaging either future picks or
picks in the third and fourth round to
move up i have to trade for you here
let's hear it yep so texans traded 68
108 and 124 to come up to 44. which is a
big jump in this draft so and they are
taking uh poor jordan schultz uh john
metchi
the wide receiver out of alabama
houston getting some speed after they
went two secondary guys and an offensive
lineman john metchi this is called
knowing your old friends getting in
front of new england in my opinion
interesting the houston texans trade up
and it is going to be
john metchi the third second team all
sec averaged over 13 yards per catch
nick saban said this guy is the epitome
of what you look for in a wide receiver
he's tough he plays hurt he plays
physical he gets open and he never
complains what do you think of this
weapon that they get for davis mills
well that description's funny to me
because i compared him to emmanuel
sanders who you hear a lot of those
things about emmanuel sanders i love
metchy good route runner a very
explosive player before the injury just
understands spacing on the field that's
so vital for him he knows how to beat
zone he can beat man coverage i liked
him as a value pick in this draft in the
third round because i thought the injury
would take him there i have no problem
if your medicals check out that you
believe he's going to be back to the
player he was when he was playing with
mac jones that he's an effective second
round wide receiver he can be a high end
possession number two
this is a b plus for me metchi's mechy's
gonna be a really nice player he just
has to get healthy it's really brandon
cooks and and that's it i know i mean
nico collins has shown some flashes but
he could play very soon he did have more
drops
than i believe touchdown catches uh does
that worry you at all no he wasn't a
touchdown guy for them gotcha that's why
they had james and williams yes yes and
that's why they had they smith yeah
and then also that's why they had
nazi harrison ryan robinson brian
robertson he wasn't their touchdown guy
yeah
guy he said he's a setup guy and what he
was able to do is find space because
those other guys take the top off those
other guys he's the wiggle room guy so
for me i think this is an a minus i
think the minus comes with the injury
and you got to see if he's healthy but
otherwise i think he's a guy and we
talked about him pre-show yes with our
mother ron st brown i'm on ross st brown
what do we think mechie going to the
texans
man i think it's a great pick um you
know like i said earlier i think john
michie is one of the most underrated
receivers in this class obviously
bearing that injury that he had if he
fully recovers i think he does a great
job finding space
um in this slot i think he'll be the
most productive in the nfl
he catches it but obviously he had a few
drops but he'll catch it he's tough and
he can start and stop on a dime which is
huge especially in the stock being able
to find open space so i think he'll be
great at the next level in terms of
finding open space does his intelligence
of reading a defense pop off on film
when you're watching them
uh you know it definitely does you know
different zones uh cover two cover three
whether he has to throttle in a hole
while he has to run through it you know
you watch him on certain shallow routes
he slows down then speeds up and bursts
past the defender so he really it pops
out on film that he knows the game he's
smart and the biggest thing is he just
knows how to find open holes i'm on ross
st brown thank you so much john metchi
the houston texans trading up to get him
ahead of you believe the patriots
i just thought that was such a seamless
fit yeah and i mean obviously the
belichick sabrina relationship the mac
jones metchy relationships the need for
a wide receiver they don't draft wide
receivers in the first round besides
nikhil harry i thought about that pick
for months and i sat there and said they
could take him in the second round
nicerio where did he come from new
england yes once again
the value says differently for me having
him 72nd but i really like this player
if he didn't get hurt he would have been
way way higher baltimore ravens are on
the clock they get kyle hamilton at pick
14 and they traded up to get tyler
lindenbaum insane draft the center for
them but the story also is the fact that
they traded hollywood brown and that is
something that their quarterback
especially the fact that hollywood brown
came out and said i've been asking for a
trade and i told lamar about it which is
very interesting it is so it makes you
wonder are they looking wide receiver
here is this sky more i look at travis
jones how many times did we talk about
jordan davis ravens it's so funny to me
jordan davis obviously the biggest human
on planet earth the fastest human at
that size travis jones is 325 pounds and
ran a sub 540. he if jordan davis wasn't
in this draft everybody would talk about
how freakish that travis jones combined
to get him at this value i mean i saw
travis jones first
we thought the raiders were going to get
him last night yeah when they took
linderbaum at 25 like this could be
travis jones yeah and they didn't even
have to trade up or do anything at 45 is
that where you'd put your money right
now it just makes so much sense
but nicoby dean would be an all-pro
there yeah i mean you're getting what is
that cj mosley right patrick queen has
really struggled there early on so if
they if they are a little uncomfortable
he's still developing i want to be fair
to him but if they're not comfortable
with where he's at but this is a defense
derek wolf missed all of last season and
then he got hip surgery this is a team
that zadaria smith was going to sign
with and then backed out of a verbal
agreement and went to the vikings
they're thin they're very thin up front
for a team that prides themselves
on being really good oda odafa owen and
tyus bauer coming off off-season
surgeries and the guys behind them
ferguson and hayes have zero sacks in
the nfl
calais campbell is back and that's great
but i don't know how much time coleas
campbell has left and this is a team
that you're right
if they don't have
a ma a big dude up front it just doesn't
feel like the baltimore ravens it does i
mean when does baltimore get bullied
around like that right and if you want
to bully teams you take a bully travis
jones i mean watching him down to the
senior bowl i used heavyweight before
yeah that's what he was to me that club
move
he's somebody that you do not want to
find yourself across from all right
we have the pick and it is going to be
david ojaba awesome so they go for the
pass rusher instead of the big guy and
they're gonna have to be patient but
that's okay david ajabo the pick for the
baltimore ravens here at 45 who are they
getting oh just a first team all big ten
a michigan record five forced fumbles he
only played two seasons of high school
football for only 26 defensive snaps in
his first two years in michigan and then
exploded connor what are the thoughts of
the value here at 45. the value's
phenomenal a first round player the best
player left on my board my 18th overall
player i'm not worried about the injury
he's going to come back and be fine a
great athlete great speed rush he's got
a spin move he's fun to watch moved here
from scotland to new jersey so he's had
a long road to american football and
that green light came on real fast
watching him and aiden hutchinson work
it's when he gets those isolated
matchups on a tackle on an island he's
too fast to the outside shoulder and i
think he's going to learn how to counter
rush inside as well so ojabo ins
everyone raves about the character i
want to when you rupture your achilles
obviously it's a long road back he's
built for that he's built for
development hard worker in the weight
room baltimore is going to love this guy
this is this is my favorite pick of the
day this is an a plus he's awesome him
in a dafe way on each side that's the
most athletic edge duo we're going to
see in the nfl eventually wow yeah
there's i mean this is great this guy is
remarkable obviously he's playing
opposite aiden hutchinson so you wonder
what's that look like but you mentioned
hey he's going to be playing opposite oh
way so he's going to have that help he's
going to be fine he's going to get to
the quarterback i love the fact that
he's learning to develop past moves so
yeah i'm going to go with a plus as well
he's someone that you know is going to
step in once he's healthy and it's going
to take time after the achilles but once
he's healthy you're going to see him be
able to get up field go make plays and
then that be able to get underneath once
he gets that guy to overset all right
baltimore ravens just 34 sacks last year
they were also 32nd against the pass so
they need to get after the quarterbacks
especially in division that now has joey
burrow blossoming that now has to sean
watson ready to go and the ever elusive
kenny pickett ready
now like you said the ravens had the
speed on the outside the question will
be do they move up to try and get
another big interior defensive lineman
how do they address that the detroit
lions are on the clock our guy a monroe
st brown we will have him ready to go
but the lions aiden hutchinson with
their first pick at number two then
traded up with the vikings to get
jameson williams at 12. this is one of
the picks they got back in that trade as
they gave up other picks other needs for
them
could this be malik willis
i hope so it is not it is josh paschall
josh pascal the pick here your initial
thoughts go for it this is the most dan
campbell player on on day two of the
giraffe just tough strong good hands a
little bit of a tweener on the defensive
line where you see him you see him on
the outside shoulder of the tackle right
there but he can kick in a little bit
because he's so strong he can contain uh
reminds me of adrian claiborne a little
bit just kind of this run monster he's
got some juice against the pass but
that's not gonna be his game he's going
to set a hard edge a hard worker if he
wasn't hurt and got to be down at the
senior bowl he would have gave those
tackles a really really tough time so
pascal my 69th player on the board
obviously we're getting to that point of
the draft he fits what they want we know
that trey flowers hasn't worked out
there right pascal not that different of
a player i really like him and i think
this is a high floor pick so this is a
b-plus for me the lions are having a
really nice two days here so far team
captain mark stoops says he empties the
tank every day one of the most special
players i've ever coached had everything
in 2018 battled back what do you think
of the player here i love him he he's a
fighter i still don't know where he fits
defensively i think you play him as a
true defensive end i think the question
becomes are you going to put him in that
in a 4-3 and play him is that true
defensive end i don't think he's he's
your five-tech all the time and that
becomes the real question mark i'm gonna
go with the b here because i don't know
where he fits along the defensive front
i don't think he's a guy that i want to
kick way down inside on pass rush downs
or excuse me outside of pass rush downs
but on play downs one two and
in short yardage i i don't know what
he's going to be at the next level uh of
course romeo acquires recovering from an
achilles injury depth in general along
that d line 28th in rushing last year
24th in passing so that's two picks mr
oman ross st brown for that d line that
linebacking core you know your head
coach is this his bread and butter is
this just another toy for him to play
with
a hundred percent i think you know dan
came on brad holmes they did their
research i'm sure this guy has grit
that's what that's what he talks about
all the time so sure he's a tough player
you can never have enough you know depth
at d-line so big guy in the trenches i
mean i think it's a great pick for us
we're gonna need him so i'm excited
awesome monroe st brown another teammate
that you'll have to welcome josh pascal
the pick for the detroit lions at 46. i
have next up washington do you have the
pick already connor i don't have to pick
no this is the pick that they got back
along with carson wentz uh so this is 47
right now
washington they
right
so this is the carson wentz era
officially they needed help alongside
terry mclaren they went out and got
johann dodson from penn state they have
released landon collins but they are
going with fadarian mathis the pick
there for the washington commanders
almost
they're not going to pay durant payne
that's what i think of when this
what are they getting from fadarian
mathis connor yeah when you look at
federian mathis he reminds me of
harrison phillips a little bit a really
stout run defender not an overly
athletic player but just does his job in
the trenches knows how to contain uh
gives you a little bit of effort juice
against the past but not a bursty
explosive constantly winning pass rusher
kind of player i don't really think that
was always his job at alabama i think
his job at alabama was more so react
read and react kind of player against
the run which is the harrison phillips
comparison right there my 79th overall
player in this draft though i just look
at it once again i think this is the
type of guy you can get on get in the
third round get in the fourth round it
feels like a little bit of a reach i
like him high floor he'll be a starter
but it's a c-plus for me because there's
a lot of other needs they had that fit
this round better second team
all-american felder a team captain uh
saban said he set a good example for the
younger guy what kind of impact do you
think he'll have i think he's going to
be a guy that you can plug and play and
listen he's coming out of the closest to
the pros that you're gonna get with the
exception of georgia right and so the
big the big key for me is watching him
play from a two all the way out to a
five depending on what sets they were in
alabama and i think he brings a
toughness to the game he brings an
intelligence to his game i want to try
to reiterate that with a lot of these
guys he's a really smart football player
along that defensive interior
understands what teams are trying to do
to him and then how to counteract it i'm
going to be quick here i'm going to go
ahead and give it a b plus because i
know we want to get to jason kelsey
kelsey what do you think about federian
mathis
i like his game you know he's a solid
overall player i think it's a really
good pick for washington they just lost
tim
settle and uh
matt ionitis this offseason so they
needed that depth they needed another
guy that could play there especially
when they like to play bass get 3d lyman
on the field um i think he he can play
anywhere along the front he's a very
solid plays bigger than he is type guy
and
you know just a really solid player
another alabama defensive lineman for
washington which is pretty crazy when
you think about daron payne and jonathan
allen and all those guys there but you
did mention daron payne is a free agent
after this season they just paid
jonathan allen and remember they did get
into that one big fight on the dallas
sideline last year and it looks like in
the long run jonathan allen will be the
guy that stays but fadarian mathis the
pick for washington all three of those
guys alabama d-line well here's here's
the here's the thing though
federer mathis he's the guy that's the
opposite of josh pascal right i know
where mathis plays pascal's guy i don't
know where he plays he's somewhere in
between yeah three last picks all along
the defensive front seven uh 2d
alignment and then the edge in ojabo
before that we had two wide receivers we
had our first running back come off the
board in this draft we still have yet to
see a tight end we still have yet to see
any of the other cornerback a
quarterbacks excuse me but here's the
last 10 picks as we get ready for
chicago which will take us halfway
through the second round looking at your
big board who is surprising you that is
still available felder's guy and a kobe
dean i mean
somebody's gonna get a steal and i'll go
down with that one travis jones once
again they're my two first round grades
that are left and then you get into it
malik willis should not be waiting much
longer my favorite player i think just
favorite player is jaquan brisker that's
left he's a starting safety that is
versatile he's interchangeable he can
handle coverage roles he can handle run
support
i just look at that and think man if you
need a safety go get him because this
thing is going to get looking ugly soon
after him and brian cook go yeah so i
think that's yeah and then the wide
receivers are going to start falling off
a cliff we've seen a couple of good ones
already come off the board so this is
again matt aberfloss's team this is also
a team that traded khalil mack this pick
that they have right now is from the
chargers for trading curlio mac they
also got rid of allen robinson so two of
the figureheads of both sides of the
ball they went cornerback in the first
pick with kyler gordon they do need some
size up front i don't know where they
stand with roquan smith he's up for a
contract as well i don't know if they
need to go linebacker but if ebflus
wants to go defense again if you had to
guess connor where do you think they go
here i look at bernard raymond and say
why not at this point right even if you
have some concerns about him you know
obviously developing he moved from tight
end during the pandemic to tackle uh
he's somebody that came over from
austria so a little bit of an older
player because when you're you know he
had to do his necessary military time i
think it's about six to eight months in
austria wow so started college a little
late that's why he's an older rookie
let's put some context in it and just
saying this guy's old all the time yep
so i look at bernard raymond and think
man that's somebody that you have some
versatility with what you could do with
tevin jenkins maybe you get raymond and
say we're going to play on the left
we're going to play on the right we
might like you a guard right away i know
i looked at him and said when everybody
had him in the first round of mocks i
said that's not a good idea same way i
felt about trevor penning right now at
this point a developmental tackle that
can give you some guard flexibility i'd
love it right here yeah they have two of
those second year tackles like you
mentioned kevin jenkins and larry borum
they both took them last year should be
a depth piece or a guard and that's sort
of what i'm reading when i was there too
i mean they were last in the nfl and
sacks allowed last year with 58. and if
you're going to play justin fields
you got to block for him a little bit
yeah you can't just ask him to run
around here's my other question guys
besides darnell mooney who is he
throwing to
i just they did sign equinamia st brown
they did sign byron pringle yeah they
got some depth guys but they they just
don't have a dude no right so
i'm a little concerned for the future of
justin fields this year just looking at
and i know it it takes it's not ryan
paul's fault he got in there roster's
not great it's going to take some time
but i would really like to see this be
an offensive pick maddie eberlus you're
a defensive guy really bright guy guy
with a ton of success you're going to
figure it out this year
dedicate a piece here to the office
that's sky more than i would i think
that makes a lot of sense you can get a
little more vertical too him and mooney
now you're worried about the vertical
attack and we know justin fields can
push the ball down the field and it is
jaquan brisker you said you wanted him
and they got him love the player but
once again you know obviously they're
looking they're looking defense again
love the player
chicago bears pick number 48 they got
this in the khalil mack trade and they
are going safety jaquan brisker out of
penn state good size good speed you know
what in the last five years the chicago
bears have not drafted a safety in any
round and they do it here with jaquan
brisker i love him my 37th overall
player reminds me a little bit of eric
weddle just so versatile he can come
down and tackle
praise he heard it it's big time praise
he heard his shoulder in the season
opener played through it the entire year
and had some missed tackles because he's
playing with that hurt shoulder a tough
guy really good instincts and coverage
you can use him however you want i love
jaquan brisker he was one of my favorite
players coming into the day i can't
believe he's still on the board so this
is an a minus for the bears they have
some offensive needs i'm a little
worried about but i love brisker team
captain first team all big ten called
the unquestioned leader of the team by
his teammates whenever i watch penn
state this year he was magnetic i felt
like his teammates wanted to touch him
all the time whenever the ball was in
the air he was there a playmaker yeah
he's killed games for them the wisconsin
game yes that's the one the iowa like
the like he's killed the the michigan
like he's killed these games like he's
went out and made plays the auburn game
excuses the one i'm thinking about right
he's done all those things i think it's
an a play a pick i had him in the first
round so i know we've got to get to
richard sherman richard sherman you see
jaquan brisker play what do you think he
brings to the table for the bears
i think he's i think this is what the
nfl is going to it's kind of like that
star position where where it's like
positionless football you know he'll be
he'll be in the slot he'll be blitzing
he'll be uh in the box he'll be deep
safety i think he's a great fit for them
i mean chicago bears you always think
defense with the chicago bears i know
we're concerned because they're not um
getting any offensive weapons obviously
fields need some offensive weapons but
the best offense is to get people
stopped and to keep points off the board
and if they're they're getting some
really quality defenders and some great
spots to keep points off the board you
know i think he will appreciate the
games not being 40 to 48 right uh and
this is a quality guy he's instinctive
he plays hard he plays fast he trusts
himself i think early on in his career
he didn't really trust himself he didn't
really trust what he sees i think he's
changed he he shoots his gun he trusts
what he sees and it makes him an impact
player and they're looking for defensive
stars right through the middle of the
defense if you think about the
indianapolis colts when hebrew flues had
success there it was d tackle it was
darius leonard at middle linebacker and
they were always searching for that
safety eberflus trying to get that guy
with jaquan brisker we're now halfway
through the second round and the new
orleans saints are on the clock and
is this a chance that we see malik
willis could this be and all i heard
from the saints all these last few weeks
is we think we're really close and we
don't want to go with a quarterback
right now they really like jamis i mean
you see the guaranteed dollars they
really do believe in jameis so
if you really are at that point
get an impact player there's impact
players on the board they went chris
o'lave the wide receiver out of ohio
state to complement michael thomas they
went trevor penning the offensive tackle
to replace terron armstead quarterback
was the let they knocked off two needs
right away how you feel about trevor
penning is how you feel about trevor
penning
they did lose marcus williams uh
marketing they signed marcus may but
they lost malcolm jenkins so there could
still be a need uh for safety there and
i'm also looking at him i i for me
i don't know if you can go too much with
another wide receiver but
what do you think why not why not trey
mcbride
do you
do we think that taysom hill is do you
think trey mcbride's an upgrade over
overtakes a million times oh my god i
mean it's it's not even comparable right
so why not what it doesn't have to be a
wide receiver it can just be a pass
catcher that's trey mcbride that's an
additional weapon for james to throw to
the saints room on the bleacher report
app it is all quarterback right now
everybody is talking about is it going
to be the quarterback you see could it
be a ritter could it be uh willis what
is it going to be again
if you're watching on the bleach report
app click on your name and then you can
find your team's room project picks
react to picks only your guys so that
when you end up taking a guy that the
other teams don't like and you get clown
for it you don't have to listen to that
abuse it's very important so the saints
are on the clock right now uh two picks
they have they have made some trades so
i think they have four picks left it's
still mickey loomis but this is dennis
allen's team now but with mickey
drafting
it's the same philosophy we've seen for
the last they're a program right is what
you call it where you know what they
they are they stick to that they're very
aggressive in the draft we saw them go
up and get a lava last night uh they
obviously prefer some impact there i it
would be
it'd be fascinating if they do take a
quarterback because at this point you
can sell it you're not going to upset
jameis winston there's a second round
pick isn't coming in to unseat his job
right now you can really not even have
to have them sniff the field this year
but once again
i think they view themselves as we're
ready we're returning lost are on
upstairs we drafted trevor penning right
we've had you know obviously a hole at
number two wide receiver we got chris
salabe they did they did bring some guys
back or were able to replace certain
guys like you said marcus williams left
marcus may
they like their defense a lot the head
coach is the guy that's been running
really interesting team just because i
look at their defense and it really is
deep and i think
maybe you take a linebacker maybe you
take nicoby dean and put him next to
demario davis that'd be electric and and
add another piece to the middle and the
division stinks
they gave the bucks a hard time last
year let's not forget this i think that
they've beaten the bucks the last four
times they've played
so they had just they just they had
their number they they looked like that
was like were the were the top dogs in
this division i tried or wrong i have to
say that
because i don't i don't host a football
podcast anymore
but if i did i would say do you all
realize how important sean payton is do
y'all realize how good of a coach sean
payton is you might think you're close
and they're going
alontay taylor to which
uh
it looked like felder said what is the
strange pick of the day and it is the
first strange pick of the day apparently
it is alante taylor uh the cornerback
out of tennessee connor where did you
expect him to go on day three when me
and felder are trying to bring ourselves
back to life here tomorrow early uh when
you look at it player 161 i compared him
to isaiah dunn who um you know somebody
that didn't get drafted last year an
interesting player just in terms of what
is he going to do at the next level is
he going to play zone do you trust him
in man do you trust the physicality
i just think this is really early there
were better players on the board if you
needed a corner that badly i'm just a
little surprised here so for the saints
definitely my least favorite of the day
i would have taken kobe bryant that's my
biggest question here wait excuse me
yes
there's a kid named kobe toby bryant was
a sauce gardener's running mate at
cincinnati four-year starter ball skills
this is just early it's just really
really early for allante taylor so this
is a d-plus i have on my safety sheet
does he play both positions yeah a lot
of people think he's going to convert
and and be a safety and that could make
sense if we do trying to replace that
malcolm jenkins role great do it on day
three there's 800 of them no they're not
in a fight with anybody for this pick no
no one they're not in a fight with
anyone to pick this guy nobody else was
going to pick him right now nobody else
is going to pick him today so the way
that i look at it is i like i like
alante taylor i think he's a was a
really good piece of that tennessee
defense that was trying to get better i
think he he the reason we talked about
him transitioning to safety was because
he was very good in a lot of their zone
schemes and seeing through receivers to
the quarterback and he's not afraid to
come up and make a tackle as you can see
right like i love the his like those are
the things that he does well now the
reality of it is and i'm going to give
it a c minus i'm not going to be as
harsh i'm going to give it a c minus
because you didn't have to get him right
now but i do think that he is an nfl
player i do think that he is going to
grow into
essentially as sherman mentioned that
star position right the big nickel type
player i think he's going to grow into
that which is going to provide real
value for him just don't think you
needed to get him right now he had
started starting uh reps in all four
years four interceptions there's no ball
production there
i saw him get lost in man a lot way too
much where i look at him as maybe that's
why he's gonna be a safety once again
but manchester united stunk for a while
yeah
brown right faced allante in high school
and what did we glean from that
experience what do we think of this guy
i'm on ross st brown
yeah so i played with him when i was in
high school at the nike opening where
they have you know the top 150 high
school players come out um he actually
was a receiver in high school so we were
both playing receiver um and the fact
once he got to college he switched to db
and i remember just thinking like geez
that's that's a big transition from
receiver to db but for him to get picked
this early i'm excited for him um he
made a transition pretty well apparently
and yeah he's awesome dude awesome dude
would you like so you vouch for his
character you think he's a good guy
yeah 100
i was really hoping you're going to be
like nah he's kind of a herb all right
hey i'm just kidding
amanda st brown thanks for checking in
alontay taylor the pick for the saints
as connor said the first kind of shocker
yeah of this stuff you know it's a shame
because there is he's obviously an nfl
caliber player there's no doubt about
that once again starting experience all
four years
it's just when you're we're in the
second round guys second round
and competing against yourself well
a team that i think has really done a
good job of figuring out their needs the
kansas city chiefs are now up getting
trent mcduffie to maybe play in that
honey badger role getting george
karloftis to solidify that d-line on the
other side of frank clark move chris
jones inside i was texting with their
quarterback today very excited with
their defense so far he's like we got
some dogs on defense and all we got to
do is get some more weapons on offense
are there weapons out there right now
they're not going to replace tyreek hill
but who do we think it's going to be if
there's a team that is going to you know
play roulette on the george pickens
experience right here it's them
the patriots are now on the clock
they've traded with the chiefs though
that means i believe the chiefs have
traded with the patriots twice in this
draft i think they traded with the
patriots first for trent mcduffie at 21.
right okay and now they're trading again
so brett veach and bill belichick just
hobbing it up hey what's up bill hey
what's up brad how you doing good let's
trade so the patriots are now on the
clock
um i kind of wanted to know what you
meant by the george pickens experience
to be honest he's just a fascinating
player obviously he got hurt he wasn't
overly productive but that size speed is
so intriguing it's a little bit of a
backyard brawler yeah he's a tough guy
yeah if if you haven't seen the georgia
tech fight
it's there's like a george viral george
pickens mashup online of none not none
of him catching justification
being a bully yeah yeah like blocking
coming off the ball blocking guys
straight to the ground i'll be honest
that sounds great for the people he's
he's fun like he's really really fun
it's just a matter of will he be super
productive all right let's talk now
patriots they did trade for devonta
parker um they could still use in my
mind a cornerback they lost jc jackson
huge contract for the chargers they did
add malcolm butler they did add terence
mitchell but they could still use some
corners there uh
is that how it's going to be no i'm just
saying they need to the kobe dean on the
patriots they like big linebackers yeah
here's the thing though do they see
allante taylor go off the board and they
go oh we can go get the guy we want
travis jones would be a very and it is
going to be
taekwon thornton
i'm just reading your faces to see
and i'm not sure
fun yeah
player 189 and the second round is is
definitely so they did go wide receiver
and a burner four two eight connor he's
got gas straight gas
uh poor man's dj shark is what i called
him wow so what do you think of the
value here terrible terrible i mean it's
it's awful i mean sure he ran a he
remember yesterday when i said it's rare
to get a guy that runs sub four three
and has polish about jameson jamison
this is the guy that runs up 4-3 and has
no polish 14110 yard he's 180 pounds he
can fly he can absolutely fly the size
speed profile like dj shark long yes
fast
not a natural pass catcher at all at all
really not a natural pass catcher at all
not much going on besides
get vertical or are we going to scheme
you a touch so you can run
i just i didn't value him that way in
this class when you look at what number
did you have him 189 on the big board i
had him in the 189. i had him in the
sixth round i had him as the 25th wide
receiver
this is just saying we wanted the
fastest guy and that's fine but i i
don't see any politics i cannot remember
the last time i've seen the patriots do
this what's your grade yeah this is this
is a d i just wow i don't understand
there's a lot of really good receivers
on the board and i don't think he is one
right now well if we're going to be
honest belichick has never been a good
drafter of wide receivers
all of his best wide receivers have been
guys he's stolen from other teams when
he's watched wes welker work and he's
watched randy moss what do we think here
about taekwon thornton
he's a burner he's super fast he can do
that he the biggest thing i was gonna
say he you stole my thunder a little bit
i was gonna say i don't know if he can
catch the football uh he's one of those
guys that sometimes jumps up when the
ball's right at his face
he he'll jump up and catch it in his
stomach instead of catching it with his
hands out in front so for me i'm going
to go d-plus because maybe he turns into
somebody that is straight line down the
field you throw it over the top because
you can run faster than anybody else but
man this is a rough one for me because
they could have got him does he have
special teams experience at all
because he did lose
gunner olszewski and that's why i'm
wondering yeah maybe they like him as as
a gunner as a coverage kind of guy but
you know once again i can't emphasize
enough he's he's really light 180 pounds
at six foot two is yes
i'm telling you he reminds me of the
poor man's dj i liked dj charcoal right
but once again this guy's focused in
catching the ball maybe we don't know
what we're talking about maybe monroe st
brown's gonna come in here right now and
said idiots close your mouths this kid's
amazing are we dumb or what do you think
amon ross ain't brown
you know i'm actually shocked too that
he went this early
i remember watching his 40 at the
combine just dusted everyone
but i don't know how his game is going
to translate to the nfl
obviously you're fast you can take the
top off but what can you do in between
you know 20 to zero to 20 yards can you
run a comeback can you run a curl those
are things you want to see in a receiver
because you know you just put a safety
over the top and you eliminate that deep
bar really fast um but i think you know
the patriots could have gone there's a
lot in my eyes there's a lot of better
receivers that they could have chosen uh
from taekwon but yeah you know he's fast
that's maybe what they want um so we'll
see i'm on ross st brown we appreciate
your honesty i just think about the
speedsters that have come out of baylor
i think of corey coleman i think of
denzel mims i think of taekwon thornton
haven't had a lot of success
but most importantly the philadelphia
eagles are on the clock right now
number 51. and last night jason kelsey
and i shared the split screen and we
lost our freaking minds and we had an
amazing time the pick's been made
already i love the pick um in terms of
the player kelsey are you doing this
right
right i want to make sure that this
person hasn't broken it's on the screen
it is cam jergens
oh that's it
it's a center
yeah
no i don't know
he's going to be i knew we were taking
them you did
so uh
so this is my favorite player in the
draft i'm not just saying that because
we picked them
uh the eagles have been uh using me
uh to like evaluate some of the centers
coming out and of all the guys
that i've looked at
like for the past two three years out of
all the guys that compare the most to
myself
uh
this guy is him i mean he is so athletic
so fast you see him out in space he runs
he's a natural athlete you see the
fluidity he played tight end a position
convert he's only been playing offensive
line for two years
um you know four nine two forty one
seven ten
uh seven one nine three cone this guy is
a freak athletically he has the best
chance to be a difference maker at the
center position
i i like this kid a lot i really do i
think um
you know i i can't wait to work with him
i can't wait to teach him everything i
know um i think he's uh everybody loves
him i've uh his college offensive line
coach was our assistant offensive line
coach for a while with the eagles wow i
was able to talk to him
and get the lowdown on this kid
we have been high on this kid for a long
time so i'm excited that we were able to
get him here
um and to make it even scarier how much
we're similar we are his family has a
cattle farm i just bought 11 cows so
maybe i can go in on this uh family beef
jerky thing i'm all in i'm sure
now and he owes me a try he told me he'd
give me something to try when he was
visited so i need me some beef jerky
you're telling me right now that for the
last two three years as you've been like
a perennial pro bowler and just running
down the field not running running backs
you have been like
deciding you've been hand picking your
eventual replacement and you have
bestowed that honor on cam jergens i'm
not saying that okay okay uh you know i
think
i'm saying that the eagles have asked my
opinion on different centers and um
you know i think that this guy right
here is the guy that assimilates most to
me out of all the guys that have come
out the past few years
for sure and i think you i mean he could
be much better than me i think this the
the ceiling is so high on this guy
i'm all in
wow you know what the fact that like
you're so all in took all the
awkwardness away that really made me
happy what grade are we given here it's
going to be an a plus for me wow and
he's really lucky to have uh somebody
like jason to mentor him because they
are very similar players jason i
compared him to a ryan khalil-esque kind
of guy and you know the athletic puts
together a consensus board they take all
the media members like me that make
these ridiculous big boards and make a
consensus and i the feedback i was given
was you ranked him the second highest of
anyone he's 96 on the consensus board
item 42nd wow he's a freaking stud he's
athletic he's nasty he's tough outside
zone bully a plus a plus a plus and even
better that he gets learned under that
guy awesome
yeah i mean listen you gotta i'm gonna
give a nice listen when you listen to
kelsey you gotta give him an a we you
gotta give him an a so the thing that i
love the khalil comp i love that as
someone that
is from charlotte watching the carolina
panthers if you can get that stability
whether it's a jason kelsey whether it's
whether it's orion khalil that's that
stability in the second round that means
a lot i just want to say this i want
jason kelsey to play forever and i want
fletcher cox to play forever but both of
them are on one year contracts and the
fact that jordan davis and cam jurgens
are coming in and the fact that i just
heard jason kelsey talk about like cam
jergens as a little brother and sharing
a cattle farm like
as an eagles fan i think it's beautiful
it's like it's like this
man i jason thank you for being such a
humble dude man that was like a
beautiful thing that you just said
i mean i'm excited i mean this is uh i'm
at this point in my career i get to
really try and help uh you know you want
to leave things in a good spot you want
to leave things better than the way you
have it and we we're in a great spot as
an offensive line in philadelphia we
have a lot of good young talent we have
a lot of guys that have played over the
last few years there are some great
players in our room
and to add this guy to that group i feel
really good about where offensive line
is for the future man very good road
grading up everybody hungry dogs run
faster this is awesome shout out to jeff
stalin you got another dog baby uh all
right pittsburgh steelers are on the
clock the pick is in all right they're
the ones riding the george pickens
experience they go kenny pickett in the
first round and now they go george
pickens to join a wide receiver room
that includes chase claypool and deontay
johnson after they lost juju and james
washington talk about the fighter that
is george pickens oh man he's he's nasty
man he is he he's big he's long he's got
down field speed he's obviously a size
speed prosthetic prospect you see the
sub 4-5 speed at six foot three almost
200 pounds coming off the serious injury
we never really got to see him have that
true junior breakout year right and an
offense that could not get him the ball
the things you want to watch on tape
with him is the targets that didn't make
it to him when he wins down the field
the ball never gets there or the ball
never had a shot to get there so george
pickens we know the steelers like to
throw the ball down the field this will
help kenny pick it i'm excited to watch
them grow together and i like this spot
for him this is an a minus for me man
him and chase claypool i wouldn't want
to see those guys size speed size speed
really
seven over seventy percent of his
catches were either a first down or a
touchdown he moves the sticks and he
scores touchdowns is he a felder guy
yeah
i love him instant this dude's a bully
he's an absolute bully this is someone
who you want on your side watching him
in the georgia tech game slinging
georgia take the directly into the wall
like it's very rare we call a wide
receiver a tone setter it's an a plus
for me the issue for him is you said you
read off that 70 number the problem is
he didn't get enough targets for him for
his touchdowns or his production to
match that percentage so that's the big
issue for me what i want to see coming
out next i know we've got our modern st
brown on the line uh i'm on iran when
you look at george pickens if he's
healthy what do you think he is at the
next level
i love this pick this is you know one of
my favorite receivers in this
in this draft going in the second or
third round um day two
what i love about it most is the bully
in him you know i me myself i have that
doll mentality and when i watch him on
tape i see that i just see that in his
game you know there's certain plays he's
blocking dbs putting them on their butt
just after two steps they're pressing
him he puts them on their butt you watch
that fight like you said against georgia
tech although you don't want that as a
coach as a team might get penalized
might get kicked out that just shows you
what kind of guy he is and that's a guy
i would want to play for
i would want to have as a teammate so
i'm excited for him i think this is a
great pick like you said him with chase
claypool deep threat can do catch
underneath strong hands big body fast i
love this pick and i i think also there
are certain teams when they draft
certain positions that you go oh they're
going to be good and that's the
pittsburgh steelers every time the
pittsburgh steelers take a guy i don't
know who's evaluating wide receivers for
kevin colbert in his 22nd year but they
rarely miss it is a new identity and i
am not taking a shot i promise but if
you guys are all talking about how he's
tough and he's gnarly and he'll fight
you that is a far cry
from tick tock juju smith schuster and
i'm i'm not i don't mean to be coming at
anybody because i ain't trying to fight
nobody i'm just saying
we got a dog and it sounds pretty good
because we know chase can fight in the
meantime if you guys want some help with
some home buying here's a message from
rocket mortgage
this crazy suit can give me an edge oh
yeah
huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in the housing game
rocket cam
[Music]
yeah that's what i thought all right so
we it is going to be the colts here
because i guess they traded back uh with
the packers and they are taking
alec pierce wide receiver out of
cincinnati and connor said i could see
this immediately why oh he's a jump ball
player
for me a volleyball background obviously
a premium tester
i still worry a little bit about him
separating at the next level and i know
you read the measurables in the athletic
testing and go how can he not he's an
absolute freak in terms of the track
workout but overall for me just watching
him work out down in mobile there were
times where he struggled to get off the
line of scrimmage in his releases i
think there's also to be fair to him a
lot of times desmond ritter missed him
so i want to be fair to his lack of
lack of superstar production with alec
pierce but he's a jump ball target on
the field stylistically reminded me of
martavius bryant where that's how he's
going to win he's going to try to get
down the field
yeah he was really good so i just worry
about him getting away from defenders at
the next level where this is a plus but
on the good note is they have a
quarterback there that knows how to get
this guy the ball on the back shoulder
throws and that will help him yeah the
the inaccuracy of desmond ritter maybe
opens it up this is a guy that deadlift
675 it was a high school track star
dynamic athlete what do you think of him
as a football player volleyball guy too
which is kind of mentioned
i think i think this is a i think this
is a b plus pick i look at him and i see
a guy that i don't know that he needs to
get separation all the time good point
because he's going to go up and take the
ball away from people and i think that's
that value to his game i'm on raw uh you
watch you've watched him alec pierce
when you watch him play what do you
think he brings to the table as a guy
that you know can jump up and high point
that football
yeah you know i haven't watched too much
of his tape i do remember you know i
watched the alabama vs cincinnati game
in the college football playoffs and
he was a big dude uh watched the combine
he ran really fast like you guys said
it's a freak athlete basically i mean
for him i just don't know how polish she
is as a receiver um i agree whether
that's getting out of his brace getting
off press release um i just don't know
how polished he is but if he can make
that jump ball and make the 50 50 ball i
mean he can make some money in this
league so running past defenders and
catching balls is what you got to do as
a receiver so if he can do that i think
he'll be fine they're trying to find
help outside your other former usc guy
pittman pascal went to the eagles t.y
hilton is a free agent let's bring in
jason kelsey also formerly of the
cincinnati bearcats what do you think of
alec pierce what are the colts getting
your guy frank i love this kid man he is
a uh he's he's always seems to be an
option
um watching him in his college career
he's just always there he's one of those
guys that's even when he's covered he's
open uh you can just throw it up to him
uh the times kind of i thought settled a
little bit of the speed concerns
uh he's a big body large target to throw
to
natural catcher um
i just have loved watching him play he
had a tremendous career at cincinnati
and i'm fired up to watch them at the
next level let's go baby i love it uh
and i love the next pick okay kansas
city we knew they needed to get a weapon
and we have a run going on right now for
wide receivers for the last five picks
have been wide receivers and kansas city
just got another weapon
for pat mahomes skye moore skyy
moore one of only four fbs players with
95 catches 1200 yards 10 touchdowns the
largest hands among the receivers at the
combine 10 and a quarter he played
quarterback in high school he played
quarterback in high school a four for
one what do we think here at 54. i love
it for me he's well worth that selection
when you look at skye moore my 40th
overall player he fits what they need
the 146 10 yard split is an elite metric
that burst off the line of scrimmage is
very very special when i look at skye
moore reminds me of pierre garcon right
he can do a lot of the tough stuff
underneath but he's got enough juice to
win down the field mahomes is going to
love this dude this is a great fit it's
a good compliment to what they have too
i know they signed valdez scantling
who's more size speed kind of guy they
have juju was more possession kind of
guy skymore can give you everything but
where he's going to shine in that kansas
city offense is vertically uh this is an
a plus the value
great 40th overall player the scheme fit
dynamite this is great for the chiefs
i don't know why why is he still here
with all the other receivers that went
you literally was about to say that okay
good no go ahead tell me no i was gonna
say you were talking about this guy is
one of your favorite wide receivers for
round one that could get picked right i
thought he was gonna be i thought he was
gonna add to the mix of the guys we
thought could come on the board after we
got past that original five i thought
scott moore was in the mix to be one of
those other guys with johan dotson so to
get him now in the back end of the
second this is an a-plus i love the fact
that they're able to get him he is
someone i love that you mentioned that
he could do the dirty work underneath if
you want him to run those shallow
crosses he'll run the shallow cross and
he's going to run away from a nickel
corner he's going to run away from a
safety but if you let him get vertical
and ask someone to cover him down the
field that's going to be a problem as
well can he play right away yes oh yeah
because that's my question is this is a
team that's trying to win now so i just
wanted to confirm that with you guys he
dominated when you look at guys that you
go oh level competition did they
dominate 1300 yards 10 touchdowns 95
catches he dominated he's gonna be fine
and then the other part is they're not
asking them to be a number one receiver
no right they've got they've got
valerie's gun they've got michael
hartman they've got smith's [ __ ] they've
got these guys they don't need he's
gonna be a fourth guy fourth guy means
he's gonna be covered by their fourth
guy right if he's covered by their
fourth guy he can beat that fourth guy
to be the fourth option for mahomes and
he'll be that smaller tyrique receiver
now he's not gonna have that tyrique
speed but that's what they're using for
a monroe st brown what did you think
when you watch skye moore
i like this guy a lot obviously he
produced a lot in his college career um
can get off press has big hands can make
the contested catch but what stood out
to me most was his route running runs
great routes and then his
ability to catch contested balls over
the middle you know some dudes get
scared running across the middle
linebackers and their safeties are in
there he makes all those contested
catches over the middle so i think
that's gonna be huge for him in his
career making those catches early on and
then once he makes those just taking
deep shots like you guys talked about
earlier
my man amman ross st brown coming
through with the analysis it will be a
lot of pressure on skye moore but from
the look of him he is a gamer and he'll
be ready for it arizona they went out
and traded for a weapon in hollywood
brown for kyler and they're saying kyler
we got your back we're now giving you
the first tight end off the board trey
mcbride at a colorado state trey mcbride
put up numbers and
it was all on him became the first tight
end in school history to pass a thousand
yard receivings only six career drops
averaged about six catches a game the
unanimous all-american and john mackey
award winner is he a premier tight end
that could be a top tight end in this
league that's my question he can be i
would say he's leaning more towards top
12 than top five kind of guy and that's
okay at this point 45th overall player a
second round grade a smaller mark
andrews in my opinion i think he has the
best hands in the draft
mark andrews and now hollywood brown
coming towards you so they're gonna be
buddies uh listen he i think he has the
best hands in the draft and that's
counting the wide receivers wow he's got
enough speed he's really really tough as
an inline blocker he didn't always run
away from people and still caught the
ball he catches the ball in traffic he
catches the ball when things are
congested around him he shows some juice
after the catch whether it's leaping
whether it's running through people and
he's used to being the guy now they have
zach earth's there for the short term he
could be the number two very effective
number two and it's gonna help them run
the ball as well so for me this is an a
i really like this pick for arizona and
this is helping kyler murray i love him
he's so good you said smaller mark
andrews you're thinking the baltimore
connection right right right mark
andrews went to oklahoma another
oklahoma
yeah but no trey mcbride's a good
football player this is a guy that's
willing to get down and dirty oh he
makes every catch 90 catches for a tight
end in college that's insane especially
when you know he's going to be the
target you know he's going to be the
target the next guy had less than half
as many catches as him so he knows what
he's supposed to do he's a very good
route runner this is a guy that does
have good speed he's able to run away
from some safety he's able to run away
from most linebackers that's a positive
for him great ball tracker you mentioned
the hands which he does have great hands
but he tracks the ball exceptionally
well and that's what i really love about
him i think this is an a plus play a
plus pick be able to get him here to get
him now to get kyler more help which
you're bringing in with hollywood brown
obviously i think to get him a tight end
that's going to be a problem i think
that's a big issue you see his ability
to ball track is so nice i love that
about him and again good hands when you
pair good hands with the ability to
track the football and set yourself to
put yourself in position to use your
body to make catches and glad you
mentioned ertz early on 12 personnel 12
personnel mirrored sets eight sets now
we've got opportunity to run two way go
left or right we can go make plays or
line them up both on the same side
overload that side and you can run the
football they also resign max williams
so they could almost go three tight ends
max got hurt last year which is part of
the reason they traded for zachary's but
that double tight end set is very
important for this team uh and uh like
you mentioned zachary's getting up there
in age you want to add something no i
was just gonna say you got three you can
go empty set empty backfield with three
tight ends remember that's what cliff
tried to do in the beginning but it was
empty set with like four and five wide
receivers and get tougher at the goal
line yeah right exactly that's up for
the go on my only question for arizona
is they do need to replace chandler
jones so we'll see when they do that
cowboys 56 they are going sam williams
here sam williams pass rusher out of ole
miss wearing seven so you know he's good
four four six
six four two sixty one what are we
thinking here for the cowboys trying to
get an edge rusher as they lost uh the
pass rusher that went to denver um
the one and only randy gregory they need
to replace that production car yeah so
when you look at it my 63rd overall
player so this is right exactly where
you expect sam williams to go he's an
interesting player because when you look
at it he's kind of just i'm gonna run in
a straight line and overpower you he
hasn't really figured out his plan at
all but man it worked for him he's big
he's strong he's productive he ran a
4-4-6-40 which is insane he's a really
real and he had production with 12 and a
half sacks he's a really good athlete he
can bend he does understand how to keep
hands off of him so when you're that
strong and you're running in a straight
line and you keep hands off of you he
wins leverage games and the way he hits
quarterbacks is with some of the most
brutal authority i saw out of pass
rushers in this class he gets home he's
not just trying to bring you to the
ground he is bringing the pain so uh he
had a great nfl pa week of practice
that's one of the lower all-star games
obviously behind the shrine bowl and he
got the call up to the senior bowl so
that's big time for sam williams uh this
is the right value and i think he's a
little limited right now but his effort
is really really good as a pass rusher
so this is a b and this was a need for
dallas so it was he's ready to go too i
know i said pass rush plan is a problem
but if you say pin your ears back and go
he's effective because of his motor and
he'll go on the other side of demarcus
lawrence so it'll be single coverage
yeah i love the way he's able to get a
little bit of a chop in there right yeah
he's still got to work on perfecting
dipping the dip in his shoulder to get
underneath guys but he has a little chop
to keep hands off him so when he gets
his chop going he does get the hands off
he does he's an apex predator on the
football field this is a guy that
understands how to hunt and he wants to
eat and so i love that about him he is
when you watch him play he was
all that ole miss had is that fair to
say connor
yeah it was the he was the guy for them
i think he's a b-plus because i think
he's someone in sub packages early play
him now put him in the game right now
and play him great call felder he is
not very good against the run right now
but he is very effective as a pass
rusher so a sub-package player and we're
at the point of the draft this is where
you draft some package passwords
and they need to get that production
because i mentioned randy gregory went
to denver for 70 million dollars tampa
bay has traded with buffalo they are now
at this pick they came out the first
pick of the second round and went with
logan hall the defensive lineman
out of houston they still have some
questions at wide receiver even though
they signed russell gage they still have
questions at quarterback remember we
were talking about whether or not they
would do andrew booth the other question
is levante david 32 years old free agent
next year nicoby dean is sitting there
and he is your comparison and we know
what todd bowles can do with a good read
and react uh i also wonder they did lose
both guards they traded for shaq mason i
don't know if there's a guard up there
that could fit and then also tight end
gronk did he retire now that trey
mcbride's gone he really might see a run
in tight ends but what do you think here
they really really like trey mcbride so
i wonder now are they worried that was a
tight end
we really like do we like
jeremy rucker a lot right another guy
that could play line block catch the
ball wasn't given the same targets as
trey mcbride because when you look at it
yeah we wait do we wait though do we
wait and get isaiah likely
likely hold on
travis jones is still on the board and
he would have been a consideration for
them i would think at the end of round
one and and this is a team that again
sue is a free agent
i don't know if you want to do it
and it is going to be godeki yeah to the
bucks there's your guard lefko you were
on it okay yeah they lost both guards uh
kappa uh moved on um
and
marpette moved on but it is going to be
the guard luke godeki 28 starts 24 at
right tackle actually played four games
at tight end he came in as a tight end
and then put on a hundred pounds but
what do we think of the value here at 57
yeah the value's fine i like him a lot i
think they needed a guard we know how
the board has gone he's my 86th overall
player so you got to take it before
everyone's gone like you said former
tight end turned tackle started all 2019
at right tackle he missed 2020 due to
injury uh the arm length was always
going to move him inside at the next
level shorter arms kind of built like a
fire hydrant the thing i ruined the sky
report is he takes names as a run
blocker he's an absolute ass kicker as a
run blocker and apps i love that about
him reminds me of roger saffold and
saffold was he he put him into the earth
and that's what godeki does so i really
like the buck's line is really really
good and you're going to keep this thing
simple for this guy great landing spot i
know the value cause he's a guard is a
little off but it's still a b-plus he's
good to go he was fine as a pass
protector a tackle in college but
kicking inside was always his road
what do you think here he's a good
player i mean this guy again he's a
bully we you asked about uh when we
talked about sky more you talked about
guys coming up guys that didn't play g5
they didn't play power five uh what does
it mean to well this is a guy that
dominated it does it doesn't look the
same when a guard dominates as it does
with a receiver because the stats aren't
the same but when you watch him play you
do see total domination you do see teams
teams either opted to not line up over
top of him really or they decided to try
to slant or move run plays the defenses
tried to do things against him slant
make it hard for him because they knew
that if we lined up head up over him
we're gonna have a problem and you see
him here at the tackle spot look
great ability to do that you know what
you're protected from even more when you
play the guard spot you're protected
from that and so i love the fact that
when you see him and we've got a lot of
tackle clips but when he's playing guard
is where i really love to see him and i
love to watch the way that he's able to
just go out there and body people up and
i also think it's going to be an easy
transition in terms of this they clearly
traded with new england for shaq mason
because tom brady felt comfortable with
shaq mason you got ryan jensen there at
center you got donovan smith at left
tackle you put this guy in between them
nobody's messing with him with ryan
jensen there but now you have worfs at
right tackle mason at right guard jensen
at center this kid godeki at left guard
and donovan smith if you're going to
make a run with tom brady you cannot
have a hole at left guard but again
you're tucked between two good players
the development should be easier well
here's the thing and i'm going to get my
grade i'm going to give this a b plus
because the key here we looked at a lot
of tackle footage but the reality is
when you kick down the guard this guy is
an absolute monster and i'm glad you
mentioned the protection right yes he's
got guys on either side of him just
focus right in front of you what you've
got to do is worry about this and people
teams are going to learn really early oh
we should maybe we shouldn't have put
that guy over there because he just
washed down that entire side and i think
that's going to be the the beauty of
goddecki
all right godeki the pick there for the
tampa bay buccaneers
uh they're trying to make a run and
they're fortifying their line it's
incredible the amount of times i hear
people go he'd be an okay tackle but
he'd be a great guard and the first
thing that comes to my mind is zack
martin the guy that became an all-pro
when he could have been a pretty good
tackle atlanta takes troy anderson which
causes a fist pump from michael felder a
defensive player rocking the 15 right
there getting right after the
quarterback troy anderson the pick i'm
seeing a lot of footage from down low
which means probably not a big school
and it wasn't montana state with a 4-4-2
smaller school but a big player a
big-time player yeah here's his road
left going atlanta's had an awesome
draft i've loved what they've done
you're talking about somebody that was
an excellent college running back then
was an all-conference quarterback and
then moved to linebacker this is in
college
music this is in college not in high
school a track athlete in high school uh
you know one of the best athletes to
ever come out of the state of montana
ever so when you look at troy anderson
for him he is the classic run and chase
linebacker and guys felt his presence on
the field there's plenty of times where
you look at the coaches tape and you see
a running back go to catch an outlet he
drops the ball because he felt him
running downhill 100 miles an hour
coming down to crack him he can blitz
he's still learning to play linebacker
his run fits his obviously instincts
overall coming downhill he's still
learning those things but if you need a
run and chase backer and a cover 3
scheme right and you want him to go
sideline to sideline you want to use him
as a blitzer i said this to somebody i
think he could have been an nfl running
back that's the kind of athlete he is he
is insanely fast insanely explosive the
vertical the 40. he's he's got to figure
it out downhill right a-gap coming
downhill i think it's going to get there
and i like that atlanta is taking a
dynamic athlete so for me this is a
b-plus he was my 51st overall player
this is good value and i think by year
or two that green light will come on i
mean it sounded like you were describing
a defensive cordaro patterson what do we
think of here troy anderson he's
remarkable the way that he plays is is
so fun to watch he's he he's a wolf man
this guy's a hunter another guy that
just he will track you down he's going
to find you we saw the clips already
right left go where you're seeing him
bang on people look at his eyes look at
the way he moves side to side okay i'm
looking i'm looking i'm finding okay now
i got you and i'm gonna go get you and
that's what i'm looking he's learning
about the way that defense is supposed
to fit hand in hand he's looking at he's
learning about that part of the football
game but the way he runs side to side
100 meter state champ in high school it
was in montana but still
great point great point but no but
that's still that's still in the
comments so we haven't addressed that is
there a fear
small school fear
no i don't think so i i think especially
with where they're picking him i'm going
to go ahead and give this an a minus i i
think the big key for me is he's a
player that i like now do i wish he had
been in kobe dean absolutely but yeah
that's the other thing the reality of it
is for me he's a different type of a
linebacker i don't need troy anderson to
be the quarterback of my defense what i
need him to do is play off the ball play
on the backside and run everything down
as we funnel it back into him basically
his job is going to be scrape backside a
and we'll get the ball back to you and
you make 120 tackles
it should be very interesting i mean
atlanta didn't need a quarterback they
just took one that plays linebacker but
this is he sounds like the perfect human
valedictorian in high school played
quarterback can play defense does
everything a versatile player anderson
the pick for the falcons there at 58. 59
now is minnesota we've been seeing move
and move and move uh connor in terms of
people left on the board that might fit
them what are we thinking i mean can we
just talk about for a second how atlanta
passed on the quarterbacks there
completely they are cool with marcus
mariota this year
rather than at this late in the second
round
and i like troy anderson i have no
problem with that i'm not talking about
atlanta i think this is a good thing for
atlanta let me kick that can down the
road i just it's pretty shocking ed
ingram minnesota had gone secondary with
their first two picks lewis seen the
safety and then andrew booth the
cornerback and now they're going with an
offensive lineman
what do we think here connor for the
value a guard the value not great with
ingram 124 here i thought he was going
to be
a late third round kind of player hot
and cold film there's some games where i
love what he can do as a run blocker i
think in 2020 the consistency as a pass
protector is really really good but once
again the film's just hot and cold can
you find that mean streak in a offense
that is absolutely run heavy is he
athletic enough i i don't this isn't
where i would take this kind of player
uh personally when i look at ed ingram
he's a decent athlete right a decent
athlete i don't think he's really good
getting to the second level but i think
north to south he has enough strength so
for me this pick doesn't really excite
me honestly once again i think a third
or fourth round player uh at a position
that you can find starters there all the
time so a c plus for me with that ingram
this is a team felder they drafted
christian darasol in the first round
last year he's going to be your left
tackle brian o'neill is going to be your
right tackle garrett bradbury has
struggled a little bit but he will be
there in center you have to imagine
he'll be competing with jesse davis
maybe for right guard can you hide him
on this d and i don't even say hi
because we're not talking about that
let's talk about the ceiling how about i
shut the hell up and let you talk
i think that this is a guy that's going
to be good enough and i think that's the
interesting because when i watch him
play even just in the mini clip package
that we showed the big thing for me is
he overextends himself and he plays a
little high so when you overextend and
play high you run the risk of teams
being able to take advantage of you and
yes he is strong i do think he's a
strong player but you see him there he's
able to pass off the twist but he gets
help if he doesn't get that help that
quarterback's on the ground here chip
nice good job stick to him let's stick
to him don't push him in the back also
discipline but the big thing for me is i
i like when he has help he can do it i
think that's the big key we saw the help
from the chip we see the help there
where nobody's uncovered so he's helping
down inside he's got a little bit of
athleticism but you want him to make
that a little more violent so for me i'm
going to give this a c i think that he
was a part of a
quality lsu football team quality lsu
offensive line i wonder what it looks
like without the help yeah he was there
for a long time exactly and so the help
is the part that for me i don't think
he's doing it all by himself he's got a
lot of help which again if you're
playing guard you're going to have help
a lot of times anyway
what was your grade i gave it something
you have to see
is there any chance that darion canard
jamari salyer could have been a better
pick there take it away
what yes yes who's yours who's your man
crush jamari sawyer
jamari sawyer i love that dude out of
georgia every guard i see that comes off
the board at before him i'm getting i
get frustrated why do you think that
could be happening
i have i don't know have you heard
anything connor no i'll tell you exactly
why it's just the lack of
measurables which i think is stupid with
him right when you look at sawyer he's
just and i know it's cliche but he's
just a player it doesn't matter that
he's not the biggest guy doesn't matter
that he's not the fastest guy he's a
bully he's a fire hydrant he reminds me
of a rock 6'3 320 but he didn't run the
40. so it's not like we know he's not a
super athlete and it doesn't matter if
you're in a dry block if you're going to
dry block if you're going to be a gap
scheme yeah sawyer is absolutely your
guy and once again it goes back to being
feel like a fire hydrant you know he's
probably a hair under 6'3
he thick build he reminds me of he when
i when i met him when he was in high
school he reminded me of raphael from
the ninja turtles that's right
buffalo is now on the clock uh what
we've seen from buffalo is just one pick
cair elam and a lot of trading back this
is a team that they're attacking
cornerback because the injury is there
they tried to sign jd mckissick didn't
work out maybe they go running back
because the buffalo bills they're kind
of stacked everywhere this is ready to
make a super bowl run poyer is a free
agent next year but it doesn't matter
the bengals are on the clock cincinnati
was picking down at 63 the second to
last pick of this round they are moving
up the question is who why would they
need to jump kansas city and san
francisco in order to get this
but and again
you're looking at the big board there
they may have traded that 63rd pick so i
don't know exactly what they've given up
yet but it is going to be cincinnati
here at 61. any guesses here connor
well we saw them get dax hill yesterday
right so
when you look at it from them right now
i think it would be early for them they
could go tight end they could still use
the tight end i know they got hayden
hurst in there they lost cj uzama who
was a huge part of their huge part of
their offense of course so it wouldn't
shock me if you see a jeremy ruckert
kind of player if they want a more
athletic player you could look at greg
dulcetch
i'm kind of on tight end here
could they also maybe go with a guard
that you guys were just talking about
they they signed three obviously
offensive linemen yeah but ted harris
and alex kappa are older and if we
learned anything you need depth and it
is
taylor britt cam taylor bridge that's a
nice player can taylor brown they need a
coin they needed a corner for the long
term we talked about this a little bit
yesterday yes we did that maybe need to
replace eli apple he's on a one-year
deal and we saw what happened to him uh
in the super bowl but they did need
depth here cam taylor britt out of
nebraska connor yeah he reminds me of a
poor man's devin mccourty because he's a
corner that plays like a safety felder
and i have talked about this he loves to
come downhill and hit you see him
blitzing here he's got really good
straight line speed him and dax hill
yeah him and dax hill they like their
athletes now on the back end here so
when i look at taylor britt he's a fun
player man he really is he could do a
lot of different things for you i think
he's a zone corner personally i like
when everything's kept in front of him
because he can come down get downhill
quickly and tackle and find the football
he's got the size to do that but once
again do i think he's going to be this
outside man-to-man corner long-term no i
like him as this interchangeable piece
kind of like dax hill right in a
different way but super versatile yeah
he's a solid player so this is a bean i
like that the bengals are thinking about
their secondary for 2023 when some of
those guys are freezing you're also
thinking about for the buffalo bills and
kansas city chiefs this year you like
this guy love him watching him in high
school i'm go ahead and give it an a i
know we gotta get to richard sherman i
love this guy he is so versatile he's
playing some wide receiver kicked it out
the corner plays like a safety as you
mentioned connor he is
so violent so willing to be violent i
love that out of him
and again jesse bates von bell and eli
apple all their contracts are up after
this year richard sherman do you like
cam taylor britt
yeah i really do i really do i mean you
know we we talked about eli apple and
chidobe um
last year last year that they yeah that
they put out there and they had uh it
was probably uh a woozier's best year um
but eli apple struggled later on you
know he had a pretty solid year then you
know he started to get into the
headlines for having too many
conversations i think this guy can be
consistent this guy can be another guy
who's plug and play who gives him that
depth who makes the cornerback
competition a true competition i think
he'll have an opportunity to start if he
goes up and shows up ready to play and
can absorb the scheme and be ready he's
tackling he's aggressive and i think he
has a chance to play i don't i don't see
them penciling starters in right now
with drafting him in the second round
uh my favorite thing that i read about
cam taylor britt is the coaches say the
temperature of the room rises when he
enters it it's intense which is great i
hear that our richard sherman
likes certain things that counter rogers
is saying richard what are some of your
favorite things that connor has been
saying during the draft
you know i mean you know
we could talk about drake london being a
calvin johnson light you know or we can
talk about his high floor you know we
can talk about the floor on these guys
being high you know i just feel like he
is high floor on at least 37 guys in
this draft so far but you know what i i
like it
connor a lot of starters on day two in
this draft high floor it's a nice way of
saying
uh not a star
that's how i would put it richard
sherman
yes
and uh
i will never call someone a calvin
johnson light i will promise you that
well you didn't say that we'll stick
with the cortland sutton cop for drake
london yes he did he
he didn't say that one but i just you
know i just like his his light versions
of everything yeah everywhere some of
the light ones that you picked oh man we
can call it diet coke we can call it
light no no but you who else you said
you well i just said poor man's devin
mccourty about cam taylor bridge yes
yeah there's a couple of ways to vary it
up
i never want to be the player comp guy
that's like hey there's a julio jones
there's a richard sherman in this trap a
lot of people call them sauce gardener
richard sherman sherman i was going to
be honest with you i i call it sauce
gardener richard sherman okay i okay i
wasn't gonna go there i felt like it was
a little rich for me but i like sauce so
i'm glad you agree with it
it's more of a cop yeah yeah i think he
has the length i think he has the
disruptive i think he's at the line of
scrimmage i think he's more developed
than i was early on you know i developed
late and then i got real consistent
niners are going drake jackson here and
then i'm gonna pick a fight with richard
sherman after this because if you come
for conor you come for all of us
drake jackson edge rusher at a usc 6-3
254
his agent drew rosenhaus got adam
schefter to tweet about him
that's how you get him drafted but drake
jackson edge rusher here for a san
francisco team looking for somebody on
the opposite side of nick bosa yeah and
it's funny because i compared him to
arden key who they just lost right they
had a breakout year from morgan key and
he left in free agency with drake
jackson that 966 relative athletic
scorer he is a great athlete at that
size got to usc and just never became
the guy we were hoping for him to be a
dominant pass rusher and that's because
his game lacks power right now he's a
finesse rusher he's got the twitch he
could stutter step he can beat you
inside or outside with that stutter step
but you don't really see a bull rush you
don't really see the power and the
reality of the situation is offensive
lineman in the nfl if they know you
don't have the power you become a little
predictable so he's got a lot of work to
do rounding out his game uh when you
look at the big board for him let's see
where i had him yeah 71st so the value
is not really crazy yeah but if san
francisco needs instant impact out of
him i think we're about two years away
to be honest with you so i'll give this
one a b-minus right here yeah i like him
i think he's a good player loved him
coming out and recruiting he did not
materialize the way they thought he
would they thought he was going to end
up being you know
some version of whether it was miles
garrett
exactly like they thought he was going
to be that and he wasn't he's a
different type of football player so
you're gonna have to get him to be more
violent his hands have to be more
violent he's got to transition to that
speed to power you want him to do that
listen i love the way the fact that he
could get stoned and then fall back and
make an interception but i also would
like for my linemen to win on that right
not get pushed backwards into an int i
love the fact that he can chase things
down from the opposite side i want that
too but i want i also want to see him
set the hard edge i want to see him use
a counter move look clean straight line
it's a great that listen it's a great
highlight because he gets a sack but
nobody touched him i want to see him get
get off a block and go make a play
that's one of those things yeah right
but we had to wait three plays to get to
see that yes and so that's the part
where i'm looking at what i want out of
him i'm gonna go ahead and i'm gonna
give it a b minus i think that he's
someone that i wanted i wanted more out
of in in college
and i think we're gonna he's gonna leave
us wanting more in the nfl until some
good defensive line coach gets their
hands on him and doesn't let him get
away with using speed that's something
not a lot of folks think about yes with
respect to coaching defensive lineman i
i picked this up from friends that play
for butch davis
butch davis didn't let you do it the
easy way which davis didn't let you get
away with using speed only so he
throttled down guys to make them do
things the right way and then you were
able to use your speed once you had pass
rush moves let's talk to drake jackson's
forward teammate at usc monroe st brown
a lot of concern up here do you share
that
i do know i love this pick so
when drake first got to usc
his freshman year he balled out and then
we got a new defensive coordinator
sophomore year yeah and they wanted to
lose weight he was i think he was about
240. his freshman year they wanted to
lose weight so he lost weight sophomore
year and he just wasn't wasn't as strong
in my opinion he didn't didn't use his
strength to his advantage
um and so what he did is over the draft
over the comments he gained his weight
back and i'm super excited for him he's
one of the most freakish athletes i've
ever seen i mean yeah right now at his
weight he can do a round off and a
backflip
without even thinking so he's a freak
athlete he can jump he can run so i'm
excited for him he's staying back home
it's gonna be i think it's gonna be
awesome for him yeah his body
transformations have an interesting i'm
reading here that he lost 35 pounds
during quarantine so that was what he
was talking about and you wonder if he's
that good of an athlete he could
probably sustain the weight as well so
we'll see that he could be a completely
different player when he gets there but
san francisco going to find a different
way to use them kansas city now is on
the clock we got a little tempted
earlier but
love the draft that brett veach is
putting together trent mcduffie at the
corner carloftus there on the d line and
they get skye moore the wide receiver
now one impact guys all three all three
and very defined roles in a way
uh
what are we thinking here could they go
offensive line
could they go
another wide receiver i'm a little
shocked bernard raymond's still on the
board okay so take him take him and let
him sit which is great for him let me
just throw some other guys yeah let's do
it what if they threw a travis jones on
that d line and really bulked up a d
line that really doesn't have a lot of
size that was 21st against the run and
had a lot of injuries last year yeah i
mean i'd be all about it i know they
wanted to what about an akobi dean at
linebacker sure i don't think that
scares a guy like brett veach either
there's certain gm's that
whether it's the medical whether it's
the size of each has kind of operated
and i really respect this in a way of
are you good at football and if you are
we like you because we want to get back
to the super bowl who's the player right
here that if they got drafted does it
matter brian cook they go safety
we've been excited wow let's start with
felder start with my man you know what
we're gonna mix it up safety is the pick
here after they went corner trent
mcduffie they did sign justin reed but
they may have lost honey badger but this
kid out of cincinnati felder you like
him a lot i love him he's one of my
favorite players in the entire draft uh
the way that he plays he plays
aggressive man coverage and then you see
him there peeling peeling off the man to
go get help provide help and make a play
he's an amazing tackler when you play
man coverage what happens is huge gaps
open up and he's an eraser again you see
it on tape he can get the job done i
think that he is for me i had him as
probably my number
two and a half safety right behind
daxton hill wow him and brisker kind of
occupied in that same space he's a
violent tackler but a sure tackler as
well and the fact that he played so much
man coverage lets me know that he's
going to be comfortable in the slot that
he has to play it this is an a plus pick
for me i mean i i love what he brings to
the table this guy uh brian cook is
someone that is going to have a home in
the nfl very quickly and folks are going
to get to know six really well yeah
remind me a little bit of tony jefferson
such a good tackler such a smart back
end player really good safety bill
transferred for howard uh and got to
cincinnati and never looked out of place
at all and here i mean the last thing
i'll give you know while i throw up the
a because i like this player 350 plus
snaps in the box 186 in the slot about
300 at free safety anything they needed
him to do he did it and he did it
successfully he never looked out of
place and spagnolo's all about confusing
you pre-snap and now he's got some
adjustments guys to throw you all over
the place richard sherman are you as
high on brian cook as they are
what do you got over there share the
food what are you eating what are you
eating right now it was it was lunch
nope nope eat what is it what are you
eating i'm not giving it to you i'm not
getting paid for
he gets to eat they are classic they're
classic okay what do you think of this
kid
see we're talking about food brian cook
i think he's an enforcer
enforcer oh i see what you did there uh
i think he's an enforcer i think he's
gonna change you know they lost the
landlord and tyron matthew i think he's
been an enforcer he's been the landlord
in kansas city for a number of years on
on most of their super bowl runs he's
been a pivotal part of it and i think
they felt like they needed to replace
that kind of aggression that kind of
tenacity and i think they've done it you
know obviously tyra matthew is a big
time play maker involved in a pass game
and run game and every part of the game
you know but this guy is going to make
an impact as well he's going to be a big
time hitter he's going to take the ball
away he's going to help them combat
darren waller and tight ends in the afc
west and i think that's huge that's what
they're looking for somebody needs to
stop darren waller because the raiders
are going to become an issue this year
for him especially with devonta adams
hearing a little excitement in richard
sherman's voice on that one yes i did
too and i can't wait to the excitement
on jason kelsey's voice because we know
how he gets with cincinnati bearcat
draft picks he's now joining your
brother another uc guy
yeah what do you think yeah
dude this is just another pick of a
great bearcats team best team in college
history
i am so excited for this kid
he is going to a great situation in kc
andy reed loves them bearcats drafted me
my brother drafted trent cole drafter
brent selleck his track record with
cincinnati bearcats is phenomenal
i cannot wait for this kid to get there
with big red in the kansas city chief's
uniform he's a play maker he's all over
the field kansas city you're going to
love him
man i'm excited let's go baby
i there's nothing better than a jason
kelsey yale man trent cole and brent
selig all right bills select james cook
with the second to last pick of the
second round james cook if my mind
serves me right tight end georgia
[Laughter]
listen i love it you came off the top
rope i was like
james cook led georgia in all purpose
yards the younger brother of dalvin cook
going to buffalo where really
again they didn't have a lot of holes
and they tried to sign jd mckissick he
ended up going back to washington do you
like james cook in this rojo play there
yeah i do you reminded me of geo bernard
they tried to sign mckissick he reminds
me of bernard you see where they're
going here with james cook a pass
catching running back he's got some
juice he's got some burst i do think
he's a little pigeon holed as a you know
maybe third down pass catcher i don't
really see him as this early down player
we heard they were connected to guys
like bruce hall kenneth walker he's
different than that he's a true role
player so for james cook my 95th overall
player um it's a little early for him
here i do think he'll make a difference
on that offense as an outlet so i'll go
with the b minus here for the bills
511 199 442. what do you think about
this guy i love him you do oh it's one
of his guys really then i want you to
wax poetic yo listen saw this guy first
time i ever saw him was in atlanta 2016.
our 2017 excuse me i saw him again in
2017 out in oregon
watch this guy and listen the mouth the
chirp
non-stop really him talking and just
talking to guys talking to guys talking
to guys talking to guys he lined up
against the running backs in a little
cat and mouse against the linebackers
and cat and mouse drill
ate their lunch he said hey coach look
can i go get some reps at wide receiver
went over to the wide receiver up
against the best corners in the country
i'm on ross st brown reference to
opening remember best 150 players in the
country lined up against the best
corners of the country ate their lunch
as a wide receiver this guy was
underused at georgia
he is incredibly explosive i am not
surprised that he came off the board
before zamir white he is a guy i agree
you view him people view him as a gadget
piece i think that he fits into you
mentioned gio bernard he fits into that
group that group of guys that are going
to be listen do you want to hand them
the ball off 25 times no but do you want
to make sure he touches the ball 20
times in a game yes what are you going
to do when i was going into the college
football playoff i i said i called my i
told my work i said can you just draw me
up a blank field with
the linemen some wide receivers and then
i'm just going to put james cook in the
back we're going to motion james cook
over here then we're going to motion him
over here then we're going to line him
up over here and then we're going to
motion him into the backfield he can do
all those things he can just line up out
here he can do everything you want a guy
to do i think this is an apic he's going
to have an impact immediately he's
confident dalvin cook's younger brother
he believes that he belongs in the nfl
and nobody's going to be able to tell
him otherwise man sounds like it's going
to be josh allen and stefan diggs new
best friend pairing him up with isaiah
mckenzie and it is new offensive
coordinator ken dorsey who was the
quarterback's coach under brian day ball
now this is his chess piece that he gets
to use and don't forget motor singletary
coming up in free agency absolutely uh
the final pick of the second round the
broncos or as mike cleese calls them the
brucos take nick bonito the linebacker
out of oklahoma
nick bonita goes to the denver broncos
what do we think here connor we we
really like it me and felder are high on
the sky we talked about him a lot on
crash course obviously we just saw
hassan reddick get a lot of money in
free agency that's who i think this guy
is he's an outside speed rusher you can
get a little creative with him because
of his athleticism out wide whether it's
running backs he can run and peel out uh
he could do a lot of different things
for you plays bigger than that size and
when you hear the hassan reddick comp
you worry about that size all right can
you handle the run i think he's a tough
guy for that size but i like the
situational pass rush role for him a
defined role going to denver they got
randy gregory now they get nick benito
and all you do is say hey money downs
third downs four downs get us off the
field get one on one with the tackle use
your speed even some use a long arm move
so don't underestimate the power uh this
is an a minus for me i really like
denver thinking pass rush here in a
division where you got to get off the
field against justin herbert derek carr
and oh yeah patrick mahomes yeah uh last
two years felder 36 of his tackles were
behind the line of scripture he lives
yes he a guy though no i love him okay
you get me this dude's good he's really
good i think that he he listen no
surprise to me that he's the first
oklahoma defender off the board if i'm
not mistaken i know a lot of folks are
high on perry higher than winfrey yeah
and asamoah exactly so i love the way
that he comes off the board as the first
one because he's the guy i believed him
the most and watching him play i'm gonna
go ahead and give this an a i think
getting him a guy that i thought was
probably the top half of the f of the
second round guy getting him at the back
end and the last official pick of the
fir of the second round that's good
value you put him with randy gregory you
also have jonathan cooper there already
he's a guy that can pin his ears back
and go get the quarterback and he's
going to be exceptionally violent when
he gets there i think that's the big
plus for him i think he's nick benito's
a good player and i love the way that he
brings a little fire to the table
all right denver broncos wrap up our
second round here getting the linebacker
oddly enough that was from the trade for
von miller trying to get some depth
there
for the new head coach nate hackett on
that defensive side do you love this
draft day coverage in the palm of your
hand cause it's your cell phone well
guess what our show is sponsored by
rocket mortgage they've made it possible
for you to get a home loan right here on
the same phone i'm just telling you
right now that if you shut us off and
then go to rocket mortgage not that
happy just wait like i don't know until
the third round is over and then get
your butt to rocket mortgage with a
process built around your needs when you
need a home loan that fits you
rocket can
let's get back to the show third round
and i just want to say
nicoby dean still hasn't been drafted
malik willis still hasn't been drafted
yeah travis jones still hasn't been
drafted all of the quarterbacks haven't
gone but no quarterbacks
there was zero quarterbacks in that
round we were bamboozled all the way
away all we heard was that the other
run-on quarterbacks yeah i literally
wrote that we're gonna see the
quarterbacks all go
yeah this is i will tell you what this
is surprising to see teams hold their
water like that yes they are telling you
they do not like this quarterback the
jaguars are now up with the first pick
of the third round and they are going
luke fortner
luke forte the center for
center for kentucky going here and
finally the jacksonville jaguars get
some protection for trevor lawrence
connor
yeah and they've been spending a lot of
money to do that when i look at fortner
you know obviously we saw strange
already go off the board we saw jurgens
go off the board we saw linda bomb so
this was my fourth center in the class
so this feels right at this spot unless
you're going to play dylan parham at
center who i like better team captain
obviously team first mental makeup he's
got heavy feet he's going to be a 24 or
24 year old rookie going into training
camp i just wonder he really struggled
to get out in front on screens anything
wide in the run game he's okay in pass
protection he's got a strong anchor but
the lack of athleticism really really
concerned me the three cone the vertical
and it's on tape that's what it is on
tape he couldn't get to his spots in
time an older guy i don't really see
that growing this is a c for me i i
don't think he's the long-term answer at
future of center in jacksonville and
that's what they're drafting him to be
here he has to be because brandon linder
retired so this will be the guy that
slides in should have prioritized it
earlier centers first team all sec
double digit starts at guard at center
they went defense with their first two
picks travon walker lloyd we've seen
some other ones jurgens come off the
board linderbaum come off the board
maybe just didn't fit right with the
with their board but what do you think
of this guy as the future center with
trevor lawrence he's the second best
offensive lineman on his own on his team
right now it's still on the board
canard's still on the board so i think
that listen if you believe in him
he's going to give you an opportunity to
win
he's a little grabby to me but the
reality of it is he doesn't move
exceptionally well but if you're going
to ask him to anchor he can do that you
just don't want him to be grabbing like
that's a great play i love to see him
there get his hips turned get underneath
to get use his leverage and do that he
can do that if this is a team that
that's all you're gonna ask him to do
yes play in a phone booth great way to
put it connor if that's what you're
gonna ask him to do he can do it but i
don't think he's the best offensive
lineman from his own offensive line in
college so why not go get that guy and
see what you can do with him they're not
even that good at right tackles canard
would have made sense bingo so for me
i'm going to give this i'm going to give
this a c minus and it's largely rooted
in the fact that canard's still on the
board you could have had him
like you're not this isn't to me it
doesn't feel like a huge upgrade at the
center position when you could have had
an actual upgrade interesting all right
jacksonville jaguars go defense defense
and then center and now
minnesota is on the clock minnesota
we've seen them go
safety corner offensive lineman you said
that they needed maybe go a wide
receiver they are going brian osmoa to
the vikings
athletic linebacker moneybacker is what
you would call it
we are two picks ahead of television
right now they did get jordan hicks they
do have eric kendricks but you were
saying he is the money down linebacker
brian asamoah linebacker oklahoma
michael silver learn how to spell
people's names it matters to them uh
connor rogers what do you think of this
guy he's very athletic he's a running
chase guy he's gonna play under 230
pounds he's about six feet tall as you
see right there the name of the game for
him is just playing in space right and
keeping him clean keeping him upright
not getting offensive lineman climbing
to him he's not going to survive that
way so he can make plays sideline to
sideline he can run in cover which is
something i really really like i think
he's a sub package linebacker i don't
think you're going to see him on the
fields all three downs i like him as
that nickel or dimebacker shout out to
richard sherman shaq thompson light is
what i'm thinking here right he's not
shaq can survive on the field all three
times but what he does best is run and
chase that's what asamoah does player
105 so a little early i think this is a
c-plus for me a sub-package player a
little early here but he absolutely has
a defined role yeah shaq also got
dropped in the first round yes so
because he could play all three down
because he's gonna play all three this
is the third round pick yep so for me i
i think great for me is b plus i think
he is someone that is going to run and
chase guys down you add speed to your
team which means when you get into your
nickel package you can play big nickel
depending on what teams are doing now
you look at them you look at what the
makeup is right we're talking about the
vikings so when you look at that
division or you look at those teams that
they're going to be playing in the nfc
those are going to be teams that are
going to sometimes they're going to go
12 personnel tall personnel you still
might need your nickel package depending
on those tight ends that are in the game
now you don't have to put in a smaller
safety you can put in a smaller or a
bigger safety and a smaller linebacker
and i like the benefit of that that
versatility and this guy's going to be
on all your four cores hicks kendricks
and asamoah that's a lot of speed at
linebacker and i'm hearing that our
richard sherman liked your shaq barrett
light oh nice that yeah see he's got
he's checked
thompson here's my last thought on this
too and i because
it's not the value's not that far off
player 105 right this isn't a bad pick
right chad moon is still on the board
jenny tindall's still on the board yeah
they're a really good linebacker leo
chanel is still on the board different
player so i don't want to criticize that
i think that's the thing is they're
different players they're different
players and the thing i truly am
thinking about
is if you have to go big nickel he's a
guy that can still come in and make
plays at the line of scrimmage as an
actual alignment he really looks like in
three years he missed zero games which
is the durability that you're looking
for the giants are now on the clock the
new york football giants went thibodeau
neal and then wendell robinson and now
they follow all of that up with josh as
zudu
josh azudu the pick for the new york
giants connor what's your take on this
offensive lineman out of north carolina
i really like what he can do in the run
game especially what that run game has
been able to do the last two years he
can really really move people now he
played a lot of tackle in college when
you look at his film uh i think he's
going to kick into guard 6'4 308
extremely extremely athletic kind of he
started at left guard early on and
started at left tackle good athlete uh
he's suited for a long-term guard role
in my opinion especially if you get him
on the move and once again he has been a
part of some units that they knew how to
run the football i do have some
questions in pass protection item as
player 153 somebody i kind of had rising
throughout the process i feel like i
found him late where this is almost a
little even too low for me but playing
guard or transitioning into guard at the
next level kind of hurts that so the
giants need help they need value on the
interior yes i really like them
attacking this need i know it's crazy to
say because he's lower down the board
but i think this is a pretty decent pick
by the giants because i do think he's a
long-term starter at guard or at least a
debt piece behind clowinski that they
just signed there so i'll go with a
b-minus here for a zoo-do bringing in
glewinsky and feliciano some vets now
you have the young guy beneath him what
do you think of azudu mr north carolina
here's the thing with the zoo right they
had a really good run game a year ago
and then last year they had a good
running game when it came to sam howell
two different very two very different
types of run games but he was able to be
a guy that was able to make plays in the
in that in that run game so you see him
here lined up at the guard spot pull
make plays i love that that's where he's
gonna play at the next level this is
what he's gonna do he's gonna make those
plays that you're gonna tight pulls are
good for him right there you see it
again being able to push yeah the little
shift and so i don't he's not a tackle
he's a guard play him at the guard spot
you see him here at tackle and he's
patient calm he's got a good anchor you
move that inside he's going to be he's
going to be very comfortable with what
they asked him to do i agree with connor
i think he can be a starter at the guard
spot for a while in the nfl don't ask
like if you need him to finish out a
game of tackle maybe he can do that i'm
gonna say that this is i'm gonna go with
i'm gonna go with a b because you're
getting someone that you know can be a
quality player two and a half years to
start at unc uh in an offense one i know
you like javonte williams yep we like
michael carter those guys needed guys to
open the holes up and he's one of those
guys that did that all right josh azudu
the pick for the giants they had their
tackles figured out neil with thomas and
evan neal now they're getting some
future guys that they can build around
cleveland browns are now on the clock
they have yet to make a pick in this
draft and their first pick is martin
emerson martin emerson the pick the
first pick in this draft for the
cleveland browns again give up most of
their picks in their pursuit of deshaun
watson they had holes all over the place
connor your read on martin emerson here
with the fourth pick in the third round
i think for me i just like the other
corners better that's where i'm a little
hung up when you look at emerson you
reminded me of isaiah oliver i think he
can play press bale i think he can get
hands on you at the line of scrimmage i
think you worry a little bit about the
long speed and the lack of the 453
jumped out to me yeah and it's not a
deal breaker but i didn't think he
really found the football in college and
that's what concerned me so you're not
getting a you know a lot of upside here
once again reminds me of isaiah oliver i
think the problem once again is i liked
a lot of corners better in this draft
especially kobe bryant that i think does
all the things i just said but at a much
higher level so this is a c-plus for me
for martin emerson
i like him a lot ooh
listen
we heard why you wouldn't like him why
should we like him he's physical he's
tough like he's a fighter this guy's
he's a boxer right like he's someone
that you want on your side in in a fist
fight in an alley he's i like that i
like the fact he mentioned when he puts
paul's on guys they don't forget about
it he's patient you see him come down
here close it down in the run game he'll
do that but i like i love the way that
he plays zone coverage i love the way
that he's able to track guys come out of
the look he he does what you need to get
guys down on the ground effort you're
going to get that that's not a great
tackle it's not going to say not going
to pretend
but he does what he has to do to get
guys down on the ground but there's
there's a few times when you watch him
play that he comes through and he
destroys people and i like that part of
his game we just didn't get any of those
clips that i needed just to reinforce
what i was saying i think this is lying
kidding i'm just kidding this is a beat
pick for me uh yes there are corners
that i like more than him marcus jones
from houston uh
small guy though yeah they wanted to
small guys he wanted a big guy this is a
big guy i think he's the best at that
press bill as you mentioned because i
don't want him playing man all the way
across the field but he is someone that
i like because he can be physical and
the key for him is not to make tackles
the key for a guy like mike emerson
martin emerson the key for him is he
plays a lot of denial football or when
he gets pause on you the route is
disrupted the timing is disrupted so
that you're not an option for the
quarterback and that's something that i
like to see out of a corner they just
resigned denzel award they've had
success with success with greg newsom
can this guy play alongside those guys
yeah absolutely he's a true outside
corner i want to make that change so now
you can maybe move newsome to the inside
when you go nickel where he's pretty
darn good as well yep yeah newsome was a
player you can move all around we have
10 corners that have come off the board
let's take a look at the 10 corners and
see where they went stingley and sauce
both went in the top five mcduffie and
kiera elam were the two that went at the
end of the first round then we saw
35-39-42
mccreary gordon and booth alante taylor
was the surprise out of tennessee that
you guys were a little bit shocked cam
taylor britt got a lot of love from you
two going to cincinnati a very versatile
secondary and now we finish up with
martin emerson but
it really seems like that run happened
between 35 and then towards the end
there did they go in an order that made
sense to you no i'm really surprised
kobe bryant's still on the board you're
talking about a four-year starter and he
got a lot of exposure because he played
across from sauce gardeners so guys were
like yeah we're never throwing near
sauce gardner let's throw kobe and he
was good and he was good at it he did a
really really good job he was a senior
bowl standout so i'm a little surprised
that he's there i really like joshua
williams from fayetteville state i had
him in the third round i know a small
school player but he looks the part and
plays the part team that took roger
mccreary with their second pick
tennessee titans made their third pick
again they went traylon burks trading
a.g brown was the story but petit freyr
i haven't written down how to actually
say that because i don't want to mess it
up
but the big tackle there out of ohio
state
it was indeed petite frere nicolas
patifrere 6'5 316 going to a tennessee
titans team that they're losing roger
saffold at left guard their right tackle
starter right now is dylan raiden's and
you're also wondering how much longer is
taylor lawan going to be playing what do
you think the plan is for petite prayer
yeah you could stash them this year i
don't think you're going to play them
inside i think you're going to let them
grow as a tackle which is why they use
them at ohio state i got to see him play
in person this year
kind of a dancing bear at that size and
i i that was really impressive to me the
way he can carry his weight and still
move i like that he plays through the
whistle that was something that stood
out to me as well in terms of the kind
of player he is i think andre dillard
who you're familiar with uh
unfortunately i don't want to talk no no
i get jason kelsey as prospects as
prospects yes so i think when you look
at it that's who he reminded me of play
style and prospects but with petite
freyr uh he's somebody that i don't
think will be starting this year i know
they do have some holes down the line
like you said on the offensive line so
this is the kind of guy you want to
draft and stash in the third round
because he does have long-term starter
potential that'll be a b minus for me
from tennessee i thought they'd go
offensive line even earlier no i like it
i think this is for me as a b um when i
watch him play this guy always got the
job done has really good technique never
see him with his hands out wide yes he's
always coached well yes very well coach
always has those hands inside he can
drive people but he's also able to make
he's also able to set in this get get
past set get past set ready so yeah i b
for me i think the guy's a really good
ball player jason kelsey you watched a
little of petite freyr uh how do you
think he translates to the nfl as a
tackle
yeah i'm always partial to my ohio state
colleges so i mean um i think he
transitions really well he's a good
athlete overall
um like the guy said he uses his hands
well he's a good technician i do think
he winds up a little bit and like
telegraphs things from time to time but
that is going to come as he gets older
um i really uh he's just a solid
all-around player
and surprised that he wasn't higher it
looked like he started to creep up a
little bit towards the end of the draft
and some of the projections as people
watch more of his tape because he's just
one of those guys when he watches tape
just gets the job done really solid
player all right really solid player
according to our jason kelsey nicholas
petite freyr will be an investment and
possibly a now player for the tennessee
titans we are going back to the
jacksonville jaguars for the second time
in six picks a few picks ago they went
luke
fortner out of kentucky the center
they still have some needs on offense
they did go on a wild free agent
spending spree this off-season
bringing in a number of guys christian
kirk zay jones evan ingram brandon
scherff to help solid up that offensive
line so you put sherf now next to
fortner
he can maybe help bring him along in
terms of needs what are we thinking here
for jacksonville yeah they obviously
spent a lot of money and they've made a
decent amount of picks already so they
might be thinking best player available
here instead and it's your guy chad and
that is one of the best players
available talk about them and get right
into it well let's not forget this is a
team that also took devin lloyd yeah so
they are just loaded in the middle of
the field i love chad mumma uh he's
somebody to me that there's not really
any weakness in his game i've seen him
come downhill and find the ball carrier
as you'll see right here i've seen him
run sideline the sideline i think he can
run and cover and so now they have two
of like your top three linebackers in
this dress
yeah and they're guys that never ever
have to come off the field and this
tells me that they're gonna use devin
lloyd to rush the passer and they're
going to take chad mumma and say you're
a traditional linebacker whether you're
playing sam whether you're playing mike
in the middle of the field whatever it
meant we trust you and they got a little
more athletic in the middle of the field
they got guys that can run but they
don't sacrifice in traffic coming
downhill i love muma my 38th overall
player this is an a for jacksonville and
that middle of the defense is is looking
stellar right now and super versatile
yeah he's good this guy's really good
you watch him play and he's someone that
works in pass coverage can scrape over
the top doesn't get lost in the trash
and i love the way that he's able to we
we talked about with troy anderson right
a guy still figuring out how football
football's supposed to you got four guys
up front the three guys fit behind him
like that that's the way football works
defensive football and
chad muma's a guy that understands that
relationship exceptionally well already
he understands that if this guy has a
gap and this guy's got c gap i'm here in
b gap that's where my run fit is
he flows exceptionally well and he flows
downhill always takes that read step off
the top and then goes sees it and goes
and gets it look at this no bad steps
there right there in the hole meets the
guy in the hole to collision to go make
a play he could play mugged up that's
how he's doing that right there play
mugged up then pursue and to make a
tackle i like that the fact the idea the
scariest part for me thinking about it
directly pertaining to jacksonville is
the fact if they could have devin lloyd
lined up to rush the quarterback you mug
up mumma on a third and long you mug
mumma up you got trayvon walker there
you got josh allen there you go that's
kayla von chason they paid over let's
pull let's put our ears back and go and
then mumma bails out of there on what
you could blitz from anywhere he bails
out on his own dog bails out on a man
dog and he's able to be a rat in the
hole to go take the ball away from me
this is an a pick this is a guy we
thought had a chance to go at the end of
the first round yes at the start of the
second round and you're getting in the
third round this is an apec
interesting
jacksonville jaguars loading up on the
front seven and their only other pick
was the guy that they hope is snapping
to trevor lawrence for years to come
jacksonville jaguars
24th against the run they're hoping that
changes let's get to a quick message
from our friends over at rocket mortgage
this crazy suit gonna give me an edge oh
yeah huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in the housing game
rocket cam
all right let's go to conor's big board
and we're going to take a look at
chicago's on the clock right now and the
kobe dean somehow is still there
travis what do you mean it's just
there's a lot going on right now on
twitter and it was before the draft and
we knew this because he got hurt in
college he's just beat up nicoby dean
which once again i think he's a hell of
a player i know he's felder's favorite
is it mostly shoulder i think it's
shoulder i saw i believe albert breer
just said there's a thought that he
might need pec surgery after his rookie
year and i did talk to somebody inside
the georgia facility a couple weeks ago
that said he's had a sleeve and a brace
on his knee for a long time and that's
been banged up and that's been limiting
it from working out so you're just
looking at a guy that he played a lot of
good football yeah but man he played a
lot of car crash tough guy football yeah
they ate him up and they ate him up and
it's you know what i hope he can get
right at this point let me say this
about a kobe dean if you have medical
concerns that are short term right now
he's worth every bit of this investment
right here every bit of it so i'm
curious to see where he goes bears have
gone safety with or excuse me secondary
with their first two picks kyler gordon
and jaquan brisker the question is when
are they going to start helping out
justin fields and this offense whether
that's on the offensive line whether
that is a possible weapon i know that
there's jamari sawyer out there who you
guys like a lot they could use some
depth on the interior uh but we'll wait
and see for the first draft for ryan
pohls and matt eberflus they've gone
secondary twice and there's the value
the wide receiver
velus jones with the 71st pick
for the chicago bears getting a weapon
for justin fields what do you think of
this kid out of tennessee there's
nothing more conflicting than having a
favorite day three player and then he
goes into day two with felis jones i
really really like him uh reminds me of
antonio callaway who was a dynamic
athlete at florida i think there was
more meat on the bone for him they just
didn't get him the ball enough in
college an excellent special teams
player you see the quick throws to allow
him to catch and run yes he was player
150 for me in a very deep wide receiver
class but once again i really really
like him wide receiver kick returner
punt returner transfer from usc
uh high level athlete almost a nine as a
relative athletic scorer that four three
one forty four three one he can fly
you're talking about the co-sec special
teams player of the year with jameson
williams uh he he brought back a kick
for a touchdown averaged over 15 yards
on punt returns i think he plays inside
at the next level if you can get him
they're short underneath throws that
gives him space space to run with the
ball in his hands he makes things happen
so last one i really like guys only
three drops on 68 catchable targets so
just because he was down on the big
board i've been screaming for the bears
to help out justin fields this helps out
justin fields i think this guy's going
to be a better nfl player as a wide
receiver now it's just a special teamer
than he was at tennessee so this is an a
minus for me i love villas jones yeah i
think he's a really good football player
watching him play at tennessee uh
especially with the constant switching
quarterback situation oh my god to go
between milton and hooker and how they
were trying to figure that out i think
this is a b-plus i think he's a guy that
we do see blossom at the next level it's
about getting him the football and
getting in the football in space amman
rob played with him at usc before he
transferred to tennessee monroe what do
you think of villas jones coming to your
nfc north division pal
yeah i think he's one of the toughest
receivers in his class you know i
haven't i played with him my freshman
year at usc
he was always a burner we all knew that
um for him to run the 431 was nothing
new to me and all of us at usc he's
always been that burner but for him i
mean special teams is going to be huge
for him at the next level i think kick
return punt return mostly kick return
though he did that since i mean i can
remember when i was a freshman at usc he
was a beast on kick return he did it at
tennessee i don't think he got a lot of
looks at tennessee
like you guys said earlier um i think he
can run he can run routes he can go deep
he can catch the ball so i think he's
going to be better pro than he is in
college but i'm excited for him and i
can't wait to see what he does thank you
very much
brown what's interesting right now their
kick returner is khalil herbert so they
could definitely use some speed and let
khalil harbor be the uh the the the back
that comes in to reprieve david
montgomery and just because there's the
value has diminished at kick returner
and that's a really interesting pick the
value is diminished kick returner he's
an excellent punt returner which is
super valuable abe lucas offensive
lineman seattle seahawks avoided this
position seemingly forever they go
charles cross with pick number nine and
then at 72 out of washington state abe
lucas cup
yeah a little early player 147 for me
now they did a great job taking charles
cross and i told you earlier i didn't
think they were done on the offensive
line i would have taken bernard raymond
here honestly i'm a little surprised uh
and you know we're talking about similar
offensive tackles maybe a little bit
more finesse style he reminds me of jake
fisher obviously a player that didn't
have you know the best nfl career i just
kid's an athlete he's a really good
athlete i don't see the physicality that
is demanded at the tackle position at
the nfl level and maybe that's something
seattle with their coaching staff can
get that green light to turn on but you
know felder said it to me best once and
i burst out laughing but it was really
said he just kind of gets in the way and
i think you can do that in the pac-12 i
don't think you can do that in the nfc
so for me this is a c i like that
they're investing in the offensive line
i love charles cross they got a lot of
work to do to get this guy it's all
there athletically i just want to see a
mean streak charles cross is undoubtedly
going to have to play jake kurhan is
their right tackle he's going to be
undrafted excuse me he was an undrafted
free agent but he finished the season
with five strong starts so i don't think
lucas is gonna have to play right away
but it could be a battle do you like
this guy yeah i like him i think that
there's just he needs that mean streak
he needs to be taught so i'm gonna go
ahead i'm gonna give this a c plus on
the strength of the fact that i think
that the seahawks have the ability to
pull that out of him and i think that's
going to be the key i also it also
doesn't help the offense that he played
in college a lot of it was all he had to
do was get the bottom get in the way
because so much of what they did were
quick hitters great points in the run
game and in the pass game a lot of it
was three step through shotgun one throw
throw throw or it was the the draws
where all you have to do is you get in
the way draw the guy up field and then
they run underneath you so that's that
is that's part of what he brought to the
table was the ability to play he's a
function of the offense that he played
in
he's not gonna be able to do that in
seattle we're not gonna let him do that
in seattle he's gonna have to do a
little bit more than that in seattle so
we'll see what happens two of the next
five picks are the indianapolis colts
and they start off with jelani woods
this is the pick they got back for
carson wentz they get jelani woods at
pick number 73 tight end out of virginia
this is the guy that i was thinking
about earlier this is a uh team that
jack doyle retired and they love
multiple tight end cents with frank
wright they signed mo ali cox uh but
they needed another tight end to fill
out there and it is going to be jilani
woods who felder loves do you want to
take this one felder yeah let me i'll
take it i'll go ahead i'll go first man
listen jelani woods is a transformer six
foot seven two hundred and sixty pounds
and he still can figure out so him and
mo alley cox next to each other is wild
yeah it's buckwild like the idea like
this he he's a power forward he's he's
the same size as lebron james yeah
basically yes yes lebron and pads yes
like this is crazy and so he i think was
underutilized a little bit at uva but
they did he he did again we talked about
what your coach asked you to do they
made him block and he found a way to get
that butt down and go make plays so i'm
gonna give this thing an a because he is
someone that i expect has i know one of
those guys that has a better uh nfl
career than they have a college career
the 44 receptions when you watch him you
go through and you pull out the catches
a lot of those are big plays a lot of
those are him being the being a giraffe
essentially running down the sea
down the scene 70 of his catches were
first downs or touchdowns bingo yes
scored a touchdown in eight of 11 games
and had zero blocking penalties for a
guy they may block a lot he's a mammoth
tight end my player comparison for him
was cj uzama there's just not a lot of
guys that are this big and this fast and
they have one in mo alley cox which is
really funny that they thought jelani
would he was a former basketball player
too yeah this is their kind of tight end
a monster tight and explosive
athleticism he has the highest relative
athletic score for a tight end ever out
of almost a thousand tested basically
your athleticism compared to your body
composition so you're talking about at
that size he is an insane athlete now i
look at him the blocking has potential
like felder said leverage is going to be
tough at the next level there's going to
be bullies that get underneath him and
are able to move him he's a little high
cut for me uh the hands are not natural
but it's good enough because he's that
big when they're strong when you see
lebron running the scene do you want to
come down and tackle him absolutely not
so i look at jelani woods and just think
man that athleticism and that size is
worth betting on it's worked for the
colts in the past i like this pick this
is a b for me i think he has more as a
pass catcher if he could just dial it in
a little bit with a little more natural
hands and the blocking is going to be
fine
wow i think what's interesting too is
with matt ryan going there you get alec
pierce who is an athletic speedster and
a jump ball guy then you get jelani
woods the tight end here that's a
problem they're doing the falcons where
matt ryan came from yes the jump ball
off and you still have mike pittman who
can do the other guy's a high pointer
and so the indianapolis colts right now
but i'm telling you frank reich is a
multiple tight end guy and mo ally cox
and jelani woods the the look of that
yeah is going to be very nice
speaking of the falcons
they have made their selection and it is
going to be desmond ritter our second
quarterback off the board and shockingly
it is not malik willis but desmond
ritter the quarterback now that will go
there behind marcus mariota desmond
ritter
third round
74th overall connor what do you think
yeah it's my 68th overall player so i'm
glad this is where he came off the board
instead of ridiculous first round
expectations you're talking about a
four-year starter athletic uh good
enough arm not an elite arm my questions
with ritter is he plays a little slow
and the accuracy just randomly wavers it
randomly comes and goes there's times
where he throws the ball high sails the
ball high once again he has a lot of
experience in this offense you see him
doing that right there the running yeah
i want to see him do more of that for
the kind of athlete he is now my biggest
gripe with this pick i like the upside
of malik willis a lot better than
desmond ritter but the value 68th
overall player obviously you know we're
around what 74th pick right now for
ritter it's just this is the kind of guy
you develop behind marcus mariota he
should not play this year unless mario
gets hurt i know he's played a lot of
college football yeah but i want to see
development in terms of game speed and
that's going to be a little tougher at
that next level for him so i give this a
b minus i would have taken malik willis
but rittered the value checks out here
43-6 as a starter felder never lost a
game at home 26-0 and last year a 30-8
touchdown interception ratio he's good
he's good he like he makes layered
throws and that's what i like about his
game is his ability to make those
layered throws now i want to see which
means he's not he can do it because he's
tall but he's not afraid to throw the
ball between the hatches that's
something that's a question mark with
some of these other quarterbacks he's
got the ability to do that his arm i
wondered about the strength and the
accuracy consistency uh for me i'm gonna
give it an a minus because if this is
the guy that you liked and you didn't
have to get him in the first round right
you didn't have to get him in the second
round and you had two picks in the
second and you had and then you still
get him in the third round and they
needed players so now they got players
before him and now you can afford this
luxury right so if this is the one that
they liked
then that's what this is telling me is
this is the guy that they did like him
because only kenny pickett's gone right
this is the guy that they like this is
the guy they like they didn't have to
give up anything to get him yes they got
more stuff it's a great pick that's i'm
gonna give it that a minus uh jason
kelsey another cincinnati bearcat geez
you guys were good this year desmond
ritter what do you think about him in
the nfl
uh i mean
who knows obviously
i think this is a great situation for
him though um he is the prodigal son
of cincinnati local kid best quarterback
in cincinnati history with respect to
tony pike and zach claros my former
teammates
uh 12
419 yards was his college career this is
a kid that is poised
and composed at all times i love his
attitude i love his temperament i love
how he carries himself as the leader of
a team in a unit um he has a little bit
of issues with accuracy from time to
time but i think he's going into a great
place with arthur smith i mean the play
actions cincinnati never really used his
athleticism for some reason as much as
they i mean obviously now after he went
and blew up the combine they should have
uh he's got
a lot of really good intangible traits
that i think a lot of coaches are
excited to work with and to be
there with marcus mariota they'll be
able to run similar systems very similar
type of guys i think it's going to work
out great for him that's a phenomenal
point kelsey you think about the way
that uh arthur smith was using uh ryan
tannehill and his athleticism and the
lack of pressure that will be on desmond
ritter right away is pretty darn good
the texans just moved up uh with the
denver broncos pick and took linebacker
christian harris so the texans now
moving up and getting a little
aggressive they had gone a cornerback of
safety a wide receiver and an offensive
lineman they needed to get a linebacker
especially for that tampa two defense
what do we think about christian harris
fitting into that role yeah this is the
right range right you're talking about a
great athlete i've talked about this
with felder a lot this year it felt like
he was put in a bad spot at times that
was out of his control often where he
got lost in traffic i don't know if he
was trying to make up for
you know somebody else not doing their
job but it just looked like things were
falling apart at times where
expectations for this guy was first
round before the year i want to make
really clear so the fact he's going here
he's probably disappointed you see the
kind of athlete he is he's an excellent
athlete
he's not that far different he's a
little bigger a little thicker than
asamoah who already went off the board
so that's what you're thinking here
you're getting speed on the field on
third and fourth downs and you're
thinking he could bulk a little more and
develop for earlier downs over the time
so 116 on my board the value's pretty
even reminds me of patcher queen when
patrick queen is coming out i love
patrick queen coming out of the draft i
know he struggled a little bit with
baltimore sure there's still a lot of
time uh so for me right here this is a
b-minus for christian harris i i thought
you know this is the kind of backer you
need this is the guy you take leo chanel
a different kind of backer still on the
board i think a better player but
obviously they really valued the speed
and it's not just downhill it's sideline
to sideline yeah i love the sideline the
sideline ability that he brings and i
think if you play him in position where
you're asking him to work in that deep
middle
and ask him to carry guys across the
field that's where you've got a good
player that's why i'm going to go ahead
and give this an a minus because i think
it's a good scheme fit yes and i don't
want him to do what he did at alabama i
agree i don't want him to do what they
asked this could actually completely
flip it yes now he's a bet he becomes a
better player because they're going to
ask him to run the shoot he can run the
shoot don't ask him to come down and
fill the hole right ask him to run the
chute and chase behind and now he can
win and you pair him up with christian
kirk so you let him handle that and you
let this guy carry along the wide
receivers i just like when teams draft
for their scheme and they don't try and
fit a square peg into a round hole the
ravens are now up next so this is the
last pick that we just did the baltimore
ravens are next at 76 as the draft is
starting to really fly baltimore ravens
with kyle hamilton at safety tyler
lindenbaum at center and then david
ojabo at edge and that's what the
baltimore ravens do is they went three
guys that we had first round grades on
now we're sitting here we're going
interior dealer if they get travis jones
in the third round
if they get travis jones if they get we
you just talked about uh the kobe d
those are the only two first round
players i've left right now but they
could i mean
realistically
they could get if they want to go
offensive line they could go canard they
can go raymond they could go raymond
they could go maj sanders
they could go if they really want to
load up the pass rush i wouldn't even
mind seeing them take jalen tolbert here
honestly add a wide receiver to that
room that i think is a number two long
term
that would be especially after trading
hollywood that's what i mean and a
different kind of player
you know reminding me of van jefferson i
think a guy that wins off the line of
scrimmage and can win he can win at all
three levels of the field but i think
he's a little more rounded not a
one-trick pokemon take us in let's see
if we were accurate and the pick is
jones
that's the one right there wow baltimore
just they're lapping everyone in this
draft right now let's make that clear
well the question is when do they not
travis jones team captain for uconn
teammates call him the hardest worker
worked hard to reshape his body lost 30
pounds since he got to uconn and he's a
man that has a lot of pounds 6'4 326
with a sub 5
sub 540 this is a baltimore ravens team
that of course they got kalias campbell
in the middle but they love size for
that scheme yeah it reminds me of marcel
darius a team captain
elite metrics with the 49240 the 7333
cone he is very athletic for a 325 pound
player and when you i've watched him at
the senior bowl and i get there and i'm
on the field and i'm looking at him and
thinking all the tape i watched i kept
thinking gap plugging nose tackle and in
one-on-ones with that heavy club
heavyweight fighter he destroyed people
in the pass rush drills this guy is
well-rounded he's a big time player and
he's a true nose whether it's shade
whether it's zero head-to-head with the
center he is a scary man to have in
front of you he can stack and shed teach
tape against the run that's what i look
at stack get off the block make the
player at the line of scrimmage or in
the backfield i'll say right now this is
an a plus and baltimore they're just
running laps around everyone in this
draft the way you got tyler linderbaum
who's a top 10 player for me you got
kyle hamilton who's a top 10 player for
me you got one of two players in the
third round that's left with a first
round grade for me travis jones nicoby
dean we know dean has medical problems
and they got a jabbo another first round
player for me
this is a
defense franchise altering draft for
baltimore right now wow they signed
marcus williams they're going to be
insane in two they're resetting they're
resetting the defense they're resetting
the defense and it's do we think maybe
lasted this long because he doesn't fit
into all schemes yeah you're sure that's
what we talked about that before with
with jordan davis so i think this is the
same thing this is why he's lasted that
long for me this guy is a player look i
love the way that he butts and presses
oh coming off the line you're gonna see
it right here butt press get extension
shed go make a tackle and what i mean by
button press is
fire off the ball engage
get full extension off where am i going
i'm going this way and i'm going to go
make a tackle i love that he does that
he gives an initial shock
gets the extension he can clear keep
that outside arm free or the inside arm
free depending on where he has the
leverage or where his leverage is coming
from and then he goes and makes a play
so to me this is something that you have
to give a high grade to both because of
who he is as a player and also where
they got him i am echoing conor with the
a plus but again i didn't get to show
but when you fire off the ball you butt
you press and then you either keep one
arm free or you get get rid of the guy
and then go make a tackle he can do
those things the athletic edge guys they
got now yeah they're seeing one-on-ones
travis jones takes up half the field
yeah you talk about ojabo and o-way
insanity yeah wow and that is the
athleticism there is there is a line of
using
other teams don't use because the value
that you can get when other teams aren't
looking for them
i think there's a number of teams that
we came up that we thought could fix
their entire run defense issues with
with this guy he just it's a perfect fit
for baltimore yeah surprised he lasted
this long we're all surprised
everyone should be surprised i mean the
fact that you get a guy that can eat two
blocks is he half if he has to he can
eat two on rundowns eat two
and eat two have your defensive have
your five techniques squeeze and now all
of a sudden what you've done is create
that pinch and that pinch leads to your
outside linebackers funneling it right
to your inside linebackers and those
guys come come out clean and they go
make tackles unbelievable uh
indianapolis colts are now on the clock
they've gone offense offense alec pierce
wide receiver jelani woods tight end
some other needs offensive line maybe
they could do that edge rusher i don't
know if there's anybody left
bernard raymond maj sanders deangelo
malone those are my three favorite
players for the needs you just said and
then also maybe cornerback kobe bryant
they traded rocky sin for yannick and
gawkway they're moving on from xavier
rhodes of all the names that you've said
which one do you think is the highest on
your board that you think you'd like for
them here i think raymond because they
they have a really dire need at tackle
right now and you got to keep matt ryan
clean you talk about left tackle yeah
and raymond's got the feet to play left
tackle i think he's got a little bit of
questions that soft shoulder guys get
him to the outside former tight end it's
gonna take a little time that's okay uh
athletic run blocker i'm really excited
to see
you know obviously where they go here
because there's a lot of good players
that fit exactly what they want and then
you know i said yeah and then i said
kobe bryant corner i don't know they
have an arm length threshold that i
don't think he'd pass so that would be
interesting uh let's check twitter
really quick i need some background on
why malik willis has continued to slide
richard sherman
onion rings and sending out tweets uh
richard sherman you're shocked like us
huh what's going on with malik willis
i'm not sure i mean we thought how
i guess we let i i fell victim to the
draft analyst and all the the
everybody's mocks and thought he would
be gone in the first day and i thought
at worst he'd be going you know early to
mid second round and here we are in the
third round and i you know i i'm not
feeling confident any team is looking
you know where you're like hey he's
about to go to this team or that team i
mean it's kind of
kind of fallen to the back of your minds
and it's like hey this guy was projected
by many as the first quarterback to go
now we've gone
a really long time a second quarterback
didn't go to the third round and we
still haven't seen his name called so i
i want to know you know it has to be
something going on it has to be i don't
know if it's an injury or it's some
background or if there's a pending
suspension or whatever it is but it
seems odd that nobody's talking about
anything like that and this guy has
continued to slide it seems beyond odd
and i appreciate you being honest there
i'm looking at possible teams that could
take him i don't know if at 81 the
giants want to be crazy and say hey
daniel jones here's more pressure i
doubt they do that they don't falcons
took their guy i'm not saying the
steelers take both quarterbacks and let
them battle it out and that'd be good
content could be great content it's not
going to happen patriots aren't going to
do it raiders aren't going to do it
cardinals aren't going to do it cowboys
aren't going to do it buffalo tennessee
that's the one i like
him back there behind 10. i mean is he
going to make it to carolina's next pick
and here is the one that we said was a
possibility bernard raymond offensive
lineman for the colts you know when you
get to go back to back baltimore and
indy you realize that certain teams are
good at being patient and getting the
guys they need bernard raymond the pick
for the indianapolis colts first team
all mack allowed one career sack at
missouri made the transition from tight
end to tackle in the middle of a
pandemic since march 2020 the dude put
on 60 pounds could he be the future left
tackle for the colts absolutely lefko
you've done this with me long enough
these player comps come up very team
specific eric fisher was the comp for
him so this is a player that fits what
they like to do uh he's somebody that's
still getting better despite being an
older prospect as i said earlier on the
show at austria necessary military
service and then got to college tight
end tackle great feat good athleticism
needs to get a little bit better on that
outside shoulder not letting him guys
beat him to the outside and flatten into
the pocket but i love the value here top
50 player huge need for the colts this
is an and bernard raymond could be a
long-term answer there yeah this is a
guy can play a little patient feet
doesn't overextend himself he's still
learning football which is a positive
because he doesn't have a lot of bad
habits i think it's a b-plus i love what
he brings in terms of his ability to
continue to grow in the game yes kelsey
you saw a tight end turn tackle in terms
of lane johnson what do you think of
bernard raymond and his potential with
the colts
yeah in general i'm a huge fan of former
skill guys converted offensive lineman
this kid has all the metrics he's got
the one seven ten thirty and a half inch
vert nine nine broad um his short
shuttle is four three two so all i'm not
a i mean those don't tell you still got
to watch the tape but these are all the
limiting factors he's got all the
athleticism he's still new to the
position still learning it and he's only
going to get better now he needs to put
on some weight he's a little light
but putting on weight will help with
that soft shoulder that connor's talking
about as well as just getting more
familiar with the position but i think
this kit has a ton of upside i think
it's a great pick in the third round
and i think you'll fit in well in indy
with the offensive line that they have
another great pick there for the
indianapolis colts pick number 78 is in
the cleveland browns have selected alex
wright with the 78th pick uh down there
in cleveland uh what do we think i like
this guy a lot top hunter player for me
use both as a stand-up edge and hand in
the dirt five-tech three-tech insane
length for the position i believe he
came in around six five six foot six
wins in a variety of ways which and you
see him here he played against tennessee
and looked really really good against
them but wins in a variety of ways
swipes push pull speed to power swim the
outside speed uh and a really nice
inside move and and guys when you get
paid for sacking the quarterback he's
got these insane strides to close on the
quarterback so alex wright is going to
give them the edge help they needed he's
got insane length he can really get out
to the quarterback and i think he's got
enough against the run to stay on the
field so this is a b plus for me for the
browns this is a need the value makes
sense i'm one of the more underrated or
under discussed players in the draft and
i know felder you've seen a lot of them
yeah i watched a ton of conference usa
and this guy can play the he is so long
that you don't realize that he's
carrying around 271 pounds i was gonna
say he doesn't look at it at all exactly
even he didn't even look at when he was
going up to the podium he didn't look it
so this is a guy that carries crazy
length he's got the ability to make all
those plays i do like the fact that he's
not afraid to play down a little inside
which gives you some versatility to your
scheme when if you want to put somebody
a little smaller outside of him i'm
going to go with an a on this pick
because uab and i love the fact that
this guy gets after the quarterback gets
the job done i think he's a package
player early
and then he can grow into probably a
five technique guy that can stop the run
full time in the nfl i think the big
thing i'm looking for out of him is a
little bit more up top string yeah he's
got lower body strength i want to see a
little more up top string well he's
going with miles garrett so as long as
they work out together he'll be fine
we'll see if he can be the guy on third
down that gets after the quarterbacks
the really good quarterbacks in the afc
north chargers pick is in talk about
teams that are going for a super bowl
run we're flying they are now going with
jt woods
jt woods the pick at 79 to the chargers
connor take it away yeah jt wood super
athletic player obviously from a baylor
defense that uh they had a ton of guys
not only test well but play well darnell
savage kind of player six foot two one
ninety five-ish four three six speed is
insane you got that 6923 cone at the pro
day you see that lateral agility on film
all the time uh i wrote down insane
athlete nine picks over the last two
years there's ball skills fluidity and
coverage he's not going to give you as
much as a run defender right now but if
you're looking for a guy that has range
over the top and can even play some man
coverage that's what he does and he
finds the football he'll sky high for
the football the tackling needs a little
bit of work but athletic with ball
skills the chargers love guys like this
so with jt woods i want to come up with
the player comp too before we before we
give this one a grade yeah darnell
savage so this one for me the value it's
a little bit off but once again they
needed a coverage player there with
durham and james so this is a b-minus
what do you think i love this kid uh
listen i'm gonna go i'm gonna give my my
pick my grade really quick just before
then i do want to say i love that he's a
roamer in the back end i had a couple
other guys rated a little bit higher but
i love the fact that he can roam in the
back and play him in that single i let
him go make plays so for me if you want
to bring it back to me so i can give the
grade i think that this guy is going to
steal the football away from folks he is
incredibly perceptive and i'm going to
go b-plus so we can get to richard
sherman this is a secondary that added
jc jackson they have derwent james they
have michael davis ahsante samuel jr
what a year he had nasir adelie it is
going to be tough but at the same point
it's a luxury what do we think of this
kid and what he's doing with one of the
best secondaries in the nfl richard
i think it's gonna be fun for him
because they brandon staley isn't gonna
have to rush to put him out there you
know brandon steady has done a great job
being versatile with the with the pieces
he has but they still struggled a ton in
run defense because they kept dbs on the
field but i think that's what the that's
what the nfc west i mean the afc west is
going to i mean you got russell wilson
now you got tay adams now you got you
got a lot more to deal with you got a
lot of receivers to deal with so they're
just making sure they have security um
ahsante samuel jr is somebody i think
they're really happy with jc jackson is
a turnover machine and i think they got
another turnover machine who's who's got
the perfect guy to learn from in jc
jackson 17 interceptions in the last two
years i still think he's a he's he's
they got him for a steal
in la but i think it's going to be a
real fun secondary to watch especially
against kansas city against the raiders
against uh
the broncos i mean the whole division is
going to be against denver yes it's
going to be fun uh and like you said
they did have struggle stopping the run
that's why they went out there got
austin johnson they got sebastian uh
joseph day and khalil mack but another
athlete on the back end broncos speaking
of that team in the afc west going with
a tight end greg dolcich important why
they lost noah fant in that trade to the
seahawks so this could be the new tight
end for russell wilson can he play and
have uh success right away going out
there with albert
oh
a very defined role for dulce to me he's
a big slot pass catcher work the scene
get the you see him working vertically
he can catch and run
i just don't really see a lot of
long-term development as a blocker i
don't think that's ever who he'll be so
if you just wanted to draft a big wide
receiver and move tight end uh get him
off the line of scrimmage he can do that
and we know russ has worked with guys
like that before so for dulcetch he's a
decent athlete he is a true move tight
end he's not mike goseki but that's his
role to me sure at the next level so
this one for me is a c plus i don't have
really a problem with the value i just
don't know how overall impactful he'll
be on this one hackett had success using
robert tunyan uh with great that's what
he's thinking here and now with dolcich
but again albert aquaboonham 18 starts
the last two seasons maybe he could be
your blocker but also with the speed and
the talent that you have at wide
receiver cortland sutton tim patrick
jerry judy kj hamler good group they
just they want to spread you out and let
russell go to work what do you think i
love i love dosage he's a really good
football player this is someone that i
when i watched him play a former walk-on
who kind of graduated into this massive
role for for ucla someone that found a
way to catch 40-something balls look at
the yards per catch 17.3 he's a big play
he's a big game hunter and the big thing
for me with him i'm going to go ahead
and give this a b plus because i do
think that he's gonna find ways to get
open i think this is on play callers and
i think that's the key it's on the play
cards
if you can't use him in a similar way to
chip kelly then you messed up by picking
him because if you're not running routes
where he is hiding sneaking
when he he needs to be number three and
what i mean by that is you have your
outside receiver yep you have your slot
yeah and then you have him as your f or
because i don't want him in line i don't
want somebody to get a chance to chuck
them i don't want a five technique i
don't want a a sam linebacker lined up
over top of him i want him off the line
as that number three and then give me a
slant
give me a bend and then sneak him out
and around into the void and let him
catch the football that's why it's a b
plus but you got to call the right place
that's on you he had six catches of 30
or more yards last year three career
touchdowns of 50 or more yards and chip
kelly said you mentioned that his work
ethic is off the charts but they needed
that weapon at the tight end spot we saw
what russell wilson did when he had
jimmy graham a few years ago pick 81 the
giants are selecting cordell
flott
which man that sounds like a sound
cordell flot uh what do we think here
connor a tall skinny corner very similar
to elijah griffin who was in last year's
draft when you look at flot this is a
true developmental corner 175 pounds
you're not playing corner in the nfl at
175 pounds i know he's been a slot for
lsu a pretty decent tester he's been lsu
slot corner for the last two years
extremely slender like i said but he
competes he plays really really hard i
add him more towards the
fifth round range sixth round range just
because i think he needs to gain a
little bit of weight it's going to take
a little bit of time and once again for
the giants they actually have some slot
guys so i think they're thinking that it
just feels a little early for cordell
fly yeah there were other i'll say this
i love marcus jones in this draft if you
want a slot corner and i know they need
special teams help that that's mentioned
kobe bryant yeah outside corner that's
what kind of kills me with this one so
this is a c just a little early for the
giants here yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
echo conor i think this is just a little
bit of a reach i think it is a c-plus
though because he is someone that is
going to stick his nose into that we saw
a couple of those clips he just care
that he's 175. he stuck his nose in
there and did he end up on his back
absolutely helmet off don't matter
doesn't matter he's going to give you
some effort and i'd like to see that the
big thing for me with flot is the
question that i have with a lot of lsu
dbs over that come out in the last the
next over the last three years and
probably for the next year what is he
willing to do that's going to be the key
why do you say that because this is a
team those guys were unwilling to play
zone coverage when bo pelini was there
what do you mean unwilling
they didn't do it so like he would say
we're going to play zone and they would
go nah
watch the tape
literally i played in that defense in in
college the defense that they were
installing it's a it's a zone zone based
defense
flex zone like an ego thing
they didn't go to lsu to play zone oh
wow so what you end up with and this is
not a knock on those players but what
you end up with and ed orjon even said
it we don't got guys on the same page we
got some guys over here playing man we
got our guys over here playing his own
and so that's the big thing
they weren't playing what was called
they were playing their own they were
playing their own defense and so i just
want to see the conversion to playing
more zones the conversion is doing
speaking of a guy that played zone
richard what do you think when you hear
all that what do you think of cordell
flott
i i think you know anytime you get a guy
who's played
scc football you know at lsu he's got
really good coaching but it is concern
his size you know it's because he's
going to be an outside corner he's going
to be he has the speed he has the arm
length he has the instincts to play
outside corner but he's inconsistent
he's inconsistent in zone he's
inconsistent in man
he's a good effort tackler you can see
he puts his nose in there but i'd like
to see more consistent discipline in in
the coverage like you you see a few
busts in there you see at times where he
guesses but i think the giants feel like
they can develop in him and they have
time but i just not to say that the
giants don't have a great staff they
have a young staff but i felt like i if
he would have went to a team that
develops guys like if he would went to
baltimore i'd feel real good about it
he'd went to the bills i'd feel real
good about it if he'd went to certain
teams i'd feel like he'd have time to
develop and develop behind good veterans
because sometimes when you don't have
those veterans you don't develop
properly because you don't know how to
develop property you don't know how to
be a pro you don't know how to prepare
for games and then it's a bunch of young
guys teaching young guys and you just it
makes it really tough
he will have to develop quickly
especially if james bradbury and does
leave deangelo malone the edge rusher is
the next pick for the atlanta falcons
after they went with ritter finished his
career with 42 consecutive starts
averaged six over six tackles per game
the last four seasons d'angelo malone
connor yeah so this is another guy from
the consensus board that i was just
extremely higher on than everybody else
my 41st ranked player
he i think he's the best bender in the
class to me that's what i look at with
malone flexibility the ability to bend
the edge turn into the pocket play fast
now is he going to be this stalwart run
defender that's not really who he is but
they need to rush the passer you got eva
katie i was going to do this
they go two edges they got two edges for
me they were both top 50 players when
that year that vic beasley was dialed in
and had double-digit sacks right that's
what malone looks like on tape just the
guy that's so quick around the outside
shoulder can turn into the pocket i saw
him counter inside enough i love this
player the falcons had nothing at edge
pass rush before today now they got two
of my favorites this is an a plus pick
i love it what let me ask you something
before i get my grade what's the
difference to him in nick benito not i
mean nothing for me they're the same guy
they're that hassan reddick kind of pass
rusher that you need to plan for nascar
package
keep them clean let them get one-on-ones
with the tackles get off the field
that's what and that matters everybody's
going for on fourth down right now it
matters so much he's awesome he's been
productive for three years his 2019 film
is tremendous listen that's why i'm
giving it an a
because i love him too i watch a ton of
csa as you mentioned i love the fact
that he's willing willing to put his
hand in the ground but he's better i
think standing up he's not afraid to
fight down inside he will go get he will
get after the quarterback you see him
there he's gonna go do it he'll bend the
edge i love the way that he's able to
dip we talked about a couple of other
pass rushers not being able to dip their
hip not being able to run the edge he
can do that and he will do that and he's
gonna continue to grow his speed
absolutely is a part of that package so
i love that as long as you get him in a
good package he's going to be someone
that's going to be productive for you
because he finds a way to get to the
quarterback sounds like a great pick for
the fat you want to add yeah when you
take
outliers right smaller rushers they got
to be premium athletes he's an elite
athlete to me that's what matters so
much
all right are you loving this draft
coverage yeah our draft coverage is
brought to you by rocket mortgage if
you're looking for an edge in the home
buying market then you've got to go with
rocket mortgage their verified approval
can help you compete in a crowded market
and give you the edge you need why am i
rushing because the philadelphia eagles
are on the clock is the pick in
because if not let me we're ahead of the
broadcast because they're in a
commercial for progressive jason kelsey
is now joining me on camera uh they've
gone aj brown they've gone jordan davis
they got cam jurgens the pick is in i'm
not looking
uh what position do we want here kelsey
best player available okay
great answer good answer
um
who is the best player available i mean
to kobe dean but we we talked about all
that stuff yeah so the next best player
available is malik willis so not him
could you imagine and the next best
player available is max
sorry what is it we're talking leo
chanelle jamari sawyer maj sanders yep
jeremy rucker oh jeremy rucker too i
missed him that's my fault there's a
bunch of offensive lineman maybe marcus
jones out of houston oh he is it's in
one of the most fun players hold on a
second
i don't know if it's you see that
do you see who the pick is jason
nicoby dean let's go out of georgia
there we go let's go to eagles we just
talked about right
the way available always looking for a
linebacker and they never get it and
they get nakobi dean in the third round
jason kelsey how we feeling
i feel great i mean this guy's obviously
a great player he's
we're just talking about the best player
available to kobe dean
and um you know linebacker is a position
that is highly um you know
important in every defense but in
particular into
jonathan gannon's defense i think that
if you look at his track record where
he's been what he's trying to do you're
running a lot of shell
the linebacker has to be able to fly and
run around if you're gonna mix up
coverages you're asking a lot of these
guys to be able to handle all the ins
and outs of uh you know the middle field
closed middle field open is it is it
four is it two
you know i mean
and this guy offers that ability so i'm
excited i think it's a great pick i mean
we just got
jordan davis and then the kobe dean
which is incredible let me read this and
then felder i want you to go first he is
called the unquestioned leader of the
national title team he graduated high
school with a 4-3 gpa and studied
medical engineering at georgia with a
3-5-5 his coaches describe him as a
culture changer the buckets award winner
first team all sec unanimous
all-american and most importantly a
felder guy this is your favorite player
in the draft and he went the
in the third round going to the
philadelphia eagles take it away wax as
poetic as you'd like you're gonna love
him you will absolutely love this guy he
is amazing so the thing we talk about
this right he's the smartest player in
this draft bar none not close the
smartest player in the draft we watch
the clips from him in the michigan game
the michigan game we watch multiple
times he's calling out their plays he
knows exactly what they're going to do
you see in the clemson game and this is
something that stands out to me because
they talk about his size so much you
watch the clemson game game one of this
year uh this past season he's
wrecking taking down dj uyonga who's six
six two fifty if he doesn't have a
problem with him who's he gonna have a
problem with you know what i'm saying
like he can get the job done and i love
the fact that you mentioned unquestioned
leader and his academic track record
this guy knew what he wanted to do he
understood what it was going to take so
he does two things
he watches film
and he goes to school that's it those
are the two things that he does and now
that football is his job
he's just gonna watch football eat sleep
and breathe football that's what you
want i understand we're worried a little
bit about the medical about him being a
little dinged up that's why he goes a
little bit later but the reality of it
is when you watch nekobi doing play uh
there are two plays that stand out to me
so i talked about the michigan play and
we saw the pick six already in the
highlight package when kelsey was
talking
excuse me the pick six we see this guy
lined up outside and as he's lined up
outside
he gets a pick six he's lined up on a
running back in man coverage outside of
the hash and he's comfortable enough to
break on that ball make a pick six and
go because he knows the play that's
going to come most linebackers get sit
on their heels they wait for it and then
they end up making a nice tackle but
they don't get to pick six the other
play that stands out to me michigan he
gets a sack on cade mcnamara so he we
get we get an orbit motion he calls out
the orbit motion over over over and then
he says blitz still on why because he
knows that they're going to try to
motion him across he said no no we're
going to trade this and i'm going to
keep the blitz on trade this keep blitz
on it's an instant sack because they
didn't account for them because they
thought they were going to fool him in
the national championship game
goal line situation
nice play alabama sets up a nice play a
little play action channing tindall gets
fooled nakobe dean covers for him to
break up a pass that would have been a
touchdown to put them in the game it
breaks up a pass to the tight end can't
relate to he breaks it up and then he
the first thing he does after he breaks
the pass up is get up and get in his
face and say you're supposed to be here
what are you doing do your job don't do
my job do your job and guess what
happens the next play channing tindall
sacks bryce young boom game over so
you're giving this what grade
i'm sweating i'm
wow i feel like the band coming on after
led zeppelin just left the stage right
now so i'm just gonna make this quick
and give this an a plus i mean i put him
in a mock draft to the eagles over and
over again in the first round for months
back to november eagles fans
understandably screamed to me and said
howie will never take a line back ever
that's why i'm so stunned you got him in
the third round he's levante david to me
he's a special player obviously a
special leader awesome awesome pick and
we're all rooting for nacobi dean to
stay healthy and make it happen and i
just want to say that you went on this
whole rant earlier about how the ravens
are drafting circles around people and i
just want to say look at the eagles
because the eagles right now have cam
jurgens uh nicolby dean jordan davis and
aj brown
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay i didn't want to do that on camera
uh the steelers that's a steelers pick
right there de marvin liao de marvin
liao defensive lyman
going to the steelers he was a second
team all-american first team all sec
as a junior he led texas a m and tackles
for losses and sacks and now he's going
to a steelers team that has been needing
depth on this d-line because frankly
they're starting to get a little bit
older um cam hayward he's played a lot
got drafted
seniors richard sherman same year as
jason kelsey and i love them all uh
stefan tuitt has been banged up lately
tyson the louis lou what do we think
about him in that steeler black and gold
yeah this makes sense 76th overall
player right a bit of a tweeter felder
and i have talked about is he a
three-tech is he a five-tech are getting
a four-eye a little bit like what are
you gonna do with him uh and he's
somebody that's a little bit of a
finesse rusher right now he plays he's
we've seen him use an excellent spin
move which is not common for a man
that's 285 pounds reminded me of malik
jackson a little bit still figuring it
out against the run the run defense tape
against alabama is extremely extremely
questionable he needs a lot of work but
the pass rush upside is there for him so
lial this is a b for me this is
something the steelers needed the value
checks out it's just can you unlock this
great pass rush talent we've always
expected from him that we didn't see him
take that next step in college yeah
listen i i love this kid he's really
good he's super talented uh again i do
want to see him play with a little more
power unlock that power and i think
we're better to go to unlock your power
than to go to play in pittsburgh right
so i think that he brings that to the
table i'm gonna go with the b-plus he is
someone that i'm very curious to hear
what jason kelsey thinks about him
because when you watch him play he does
bring a lot of talent a lot of
measurables how do you see it play out
on the field what do you think kelsey
i think he's a really good pass rusher i
think he uh finds a way to get to the
quarterback he uh uses his length well
he is a kind of a tweener where you know
is he uh three technique he's got four
eyes in an end kind of moves all over um
and these three four teams are really
going to value that
i do think he plays high occasionally on
rundowns and he can get driven off the
ball
but if there's a great place for him to
go it's pittsburgh i mean you look at
all the defensive linemen they've had
come out over the past decade they just
seem to have a knack for drafting guys
that fit their system and can excel in
it um so i think you know it's
for a guy that i was kind of unsure
about i think him going to pittsburgh
makes me feel better about this pig
absolutely he's just a pittsburgh guy
and then the new england patriots come
back and they get a patriots guy marcus
jones elite return skills nine career
special teams touchdowns
he is a heck of a corner paul horning
award winner consensus all-american you
get the paul horning award when you do a
little bit of everything corner out of
houston they did lose j.c jackson i want
to add one little thing he has a rap
name elliott j
and he dropped an album called
complications in september
this isn't a complicated pick he's
awesome man i mean when you look at him
five picks 12 past breakups this year a
legendary returner he literally was
dante hall of of college for houston so
he'll be the bethel johnson for the
patriots he he is unbelievable um he's
just an incredible special teams player
he's a legitimate starting slot corner
the value fits which is what jc jackson
played yeah he well yeah he's a little
bit outside too so for marcus you're
strictly a slot is what i want to
emphasize here and that's okay he's got
the athleticism for man coverage but the
most important thing is he's one of the
best returners punt and kicks i've ever
seen in my entire life yes in my entire
life i mean we're talking about every
time the ball is in his hands you could
blink and he's in the end zone
terrifying uh so i love marcus jones i
think this is the first good patriots
pick of this draft so far one that he'll
be there for a long time so this for me
is a b-plus here electric special teams
and i think he can be the answer as slot
corner
yeah i love him i think that he's a
really special i like him as a corner
like that's the thing that i really
enjoy this guy will climb a tree he will
go get it done i'm giving it an a
because of how tenacious he is at the
cornerback spot and then you add in the
return stuff and that's the bonus but i
love the meat that's on the bone of him
playing the cornerback position let's
get back on camera because it is time
to have a moment if you are watching the
television broadcast right now
you're seeing pictures of fountains
you're seeing nothing and we are going
to break this news to you because the
tennessee titans are up and the
tennessee titans have officially
selected malik willis with the 86th pick
ryan tannehill is there in tennessee but
now you have the mobile quarterback of
this draft who many believe was the
number one quarterback in this draft
going to tennessee he could be the
future of this team
bowl game mvp bobby bowden award winner
a career touchdown interception ratio of
48 to 18 led liberty to its first top 25
ranking and a win over an acc opponent
he is coachable he is observant and he
led the nation in russia to get him here
at pick number 86 conor the value must
be wild tremendous 33rd overall player
and i'm glad to say that about a
quarterback in the draft right for how
much you know criticism this quarter
quarterback class has taken malik willis
has just been an awesome riser
throughout the process transferred from
auburn obviously goes to liberty i went
to the senior bowl and looked like the
best guy on that field and it's not just
as a runner although he has excellent
vision as a runner which is really
really special he's got a rocket arm he
was very accurate in practices now is
there going to be a little bit
difference game speed at the next level
of course there is where you're going to
want to let him marinate a little bit
he's going to get to sit behind ryan tan
hill i love this situation for malik
bliss i didn't want him thrown into the
fire like a lot of these quarterbacks
might be uh i think he needs to season a
little bit get used to a pro offense and
and he's run a lot of play action at the
college level and he's good at that and
that's going to work for tennessee he's
going to push the ball vertically down
the field we might not see him until
2023 but i think there's a red zone
package for him because of the type of
athlete he is and how smart of a thrower
he can be in that red zone area so this
is an a-plus for me i'm so intrigued by
the long-term potential malik willis and
he goes to a situation where he's going
to get the long-term coaching to do that
yeah i mean it's it's simple to call
this an a-plus because the reality is
he's a guy that some people thought
might be somebody people thought he
might people might trade up at five to
go get him so it's an a-plus instead he
keeps dropping he keeps dropping i feel
for him it's a rough spot to be in when
you're sitting there and you got your
suit on and you think you're going to be
the guy but at the end of the day he's
in a better situation he's with a team
that doesn't need him to play right now
he's with a team that can let him grow
as a person and grow as a player he's
with a team that can let him
learn how to be a professional in the
nfl without the
weight and the pressure of carrying a
city on your back yes which means he can
grow into this offense this scheme and
turn into a player that not is just a
that's not just a contributor but is a
long time starter in the nfl because he
doesn't have the weight of being a top
10 pick or the weight of being someone's
franchise quarterback immediately let's
sit on this for a second before we move
to the next pick we both give him an
a-plus i think the thing that's really
interesting is one you're drafting him
with traylon berks so you're allowing
those two guys to come in together and
establish a relationship number two this
is a team that they also have robert
woods so he's going to be able to round
be around some professionals too
tannehill him they can both do the same
thing but i think about the excitement
of this kid's legs if he were to fake
the handoff to derrick henry yeah with
the amount of attention he takes and to
be able to roll out that way that's
where it gets really exciting and he had
so much play action in his college
offense almost half the time was play
action so you're telling me you're going
to roll malik willis out and you're
going to create levels of the field a
trail on burke's level
a robert woods
yes all levels of the field where he can
push the ball 60 yards on a spiral
he can also challenge you with his legs
where linebackers put somebody in
conflict conflict exactly the force
player the conflict is he gonna have to
come up and then he can make the
intermediate throw cutting the field in
half is gonna be so key to his early
development this is the right offense
for him this is i know malik willis and
he is has a great personality so i don't
think he's disappointed but i know
internally you have to be you thought
you were going in the first round for
months from the mock drafts this is the
right situation for him i think this
gives him the best chance of anyone in
this quarterback class to be a superstar
down the road wow that worked out pretty
well
cam thomas the pick for arizona here at
87 cam thomas a name that we've been
waiting to hear for a little bit here
cam thomas the edge rusher out of san
diego state 6-4 267. what do we think
here at 87 connor yeah they moved him
all over the place five tech three tech
even shade knows arizona loves those
guys yeah 87th overall player so this is
right on the money uh reminded me of
derek barnett quite a bit honestly uh
shout out to lefko
interior pass rush is the name of his
game i'll say this
i don't want to be a downer here but
massive production a lot of it is
coverage saks stunts twist so i don't
want people it might not be replacing
chandler jones that easily i want to be
very clear you see the massive
production there it's a little
misleading he's not very flexible he's
not very twitchy he it's the cliche he
does play extremely hard i i hate to say
it but he really does there's a lot of
coverage sax there i couldn't
participate in the scene
they already have jj watt yeah he's not
j.j watt but he's somebody that can come
in give you high effort rusher and he
really did have a lot of success off
those stunts and twists so uh this is a
bee for me i think this is right where
he should have gone and boy did they
need the help in the trenches on the
d-line i i like him listen watching
mountain west this guy he was productive
he was product productive on slants on
twist and on mismatches the other thing
mismatches if you get him lined i sewed
on a tight end he's going to whip that
tight ends behind i'm going to go with
an a minus here he has the ability to go
make that play so the big key for me is
going to be how you use him he's better
at rushing i think slanting towards the
inside across the tackle
and he is winning out the winning around
the edge against the tackle
uh the pick is in for the dallas cowboys
at pick number 88 aka michael irvin and
is going to be jalen tolbert the cowboys
the cowboys they traded amari cooper
they lost cedric wilson they signed
james washington
but the pick that they go with here at
pick number 88 jalen tolbert out of
south alabama connor yeah i'm a big fan
of this player in this spot right here
for the cowboys this gives them
the depth they needed at a wide receiver
65th overall player to me i said earlier
reminds me of van jefferson when you
look at tolbert he's a good athlete he's
not the biggest guy but he's got enough
size very physical football player the
quarterback play was not great he was
given a chance on 50 50 opportunities
sometimes those football chances were
even lower than that good double move to
win vertically which we know dallas is
going to like to see great releases off
the line of scrimmage swift feet wastes
no time getting into his route so i
think he's ready to go i'm excited for
this one this is an a for dallas this is
great value at a position they've been
all over going back to round one not
great quarterback play yet he still set
a school record with 178 career catches
22 being touchdowns first player in
school history to get a thousand yards
in a season they did it twice your
finger is on the grade is it high
yeah how high hey put it up there boom
listen
watching this guy adjust to the ball he
it helped him the bad quarterback play
or did make him better to be fair it
starts with bad offensive live play then
to bad quarterback play because
quarterbacks are throwing the ball while
they're falling down and he adjusts to
the ball exceptionally well i think that
adjustment's going to help him help him
increase his catch radius and i think
that's going to be a big asset at the
next level ahmanra saint brown this guy
is going to the cowboys how do you think
he fits in
i think it's an awesome fit you know
playing besides michael gallup and c.d
lamb he's going to be wide receiver 305
receiver 4. won't have too much pressure
on him you watch his tape i mean he puts
together a lot of things he reminds me a
lot of marvin jones
can do you know can do a lot of things
can go deep can run a curl route has
pretty good hands
so it reminds me a lot of him
um like you said quarterback play wasn't
the best but he adjusted to it made made
the deep ball caught caught almost you
know all the deep outs that were thrown
to him so he reminds me a lot of marvin
jones i'm excited for him i think it's a
great fit for him in dallas
man i like that player comp for mom on
raw
yeah good player come jalen tolbert he's
going to get some time too the amount of
wide receivers they play there in dallas
buffalo bills are up and they are
selecting linebacker tyrell bernard
terrell bernard the pick here for
buffalo uh terrell bernard is going to
slip into a situation where you kind of
look at the linebacking core and you go
tremaine edmonds matt milano how does he
fit in what kind of style of linebacker
are the bills getting yeah one of these
money backers right it goes back to a
guy that's about six foot one 225 pounds
kind of built like a strong safety
another one of these guys at baylor
that's a pretty good tester plays fast
and clearly this was the
kind of player they wanted right because
there are much better linebackers on the
board that are more traditional
linebackers when you look at a leo
chanel type of player uh and a lot of
guys it's not just him so they wanted an
athlete i valued him as a day three
player at best a sub package player more
as a special teams contributor so for
the bills for me my 204th player sorry i
can't give everyone a good grade that's
just the name of the game this is a c
minus for me um i think it's a reach
i like him
i like baylor's defense though and so
they got a lot of guys that i like and i
think he's a good running catchy
linebacker he's gonna he'll track you
down from behind he's incredibly
productive i think that this is a b-plus
because if this is what you're looking
for this is the guy for the job he's
gonna do it and i think he's kind of
he's got some bump and run in his game
in terms of when he gets into the
traffic he can he can make himself not
be
basically he doesn't let them put hands
on him and i think that's what he's good
at and so to get him here is good i feel
like that's still good value i know you
had him lower but when if we were just
gonna i think we talked about the same
thing with christian harris he fits into
that same mold as a guy who if this is
what you're gonna ask him to do and
that's all you're going to ask him to do
then he's going to do it really really
well now if you wanted if you wanted
dick buckus
you messed up because he ain't that dog
but if you want a guy that's going to
run and chase and catch you from behind
he's going to do it yeah the two guys
would be jeremiah gimmel i thought in
mind jojo doman i would have taken over
him but once again very specific type of
linebacker they wanted can you imagine
if dick buck kiss was a name in the
twitter era
it would have been different i mean we
had a smoke monday in this draft
every monday uh it is now time for the
first pick
the raiders the raiders are a completely
different franchise devonte adams is
there chandler jones is there josh
mcdaniels is their coach the first thing
i thought is they need to fix this right
side of the offensive line i think
they're going to say that it is drafting
good and they are going with dylan
awesome pick parham parham park
dylan para they need an offensive
library they go to memphis it's not trey
pepkins but it's dylan parham
uh well he's going to the raiders uh
look i don't know can he replace alex
leatherwood right away no i mean give
leatherwood a chance guard center
flexibility with dylan parham really
really good athlete enough length
excellent 40. we know he can move
four-year starter a guard that is
expected to play center at the next
level and he reminded me a little bit of
a former raider and rodney hudson that's
who he reminded me of a little bit so
i look at dylan parham and thought he
should have went well before luke
fortner so i think this has been too
long of a wait for him definitely a day
two player definitely a starting caliber
player has enough movement skills in a
zone scheme has put on a lot of weight
over his time as a four-year starter and
now he's nfl ready so pretty sweet pick
by the raiders this is really really
good value when you look at parham he is
my 84th ranked player we're right around
that point of the draft this is an a
minus they need an offensive line
helping i'm glad they didn't just get
the guy that the type of guy they need
to draft they just took the best player
dylan parham was a tight end in high
school so we know jason kelsey is going
to love that do you love this i love it
listen guy i'm not gonna why am i look
i'll just let's just let kelsey talk
about it you know what i'm saying
i'm going b plus i think he's a good
football player blocked for a lot of
successful running backs at memphis
which is a big positive damn right let's
go ahead and let's let's get to kelsey
it is the first pick in the dave ziegler
era for the las vegas raiders and it's
not a mike mayak where it's a reach what
did you think when you watched parham on
tape kels
i like him a lot um i think he's
a guy that um
you know he's got the versatility he's
played a bunch of different positions
everything from even tackle but
obviously the next level it's gonna be
garter center and in particular probably
more of a center um moves are in the row
great athlete you see him out on the run
you see him come downhill
um
he went but i watched him a little bit
the senior bowl when they moved into
center to see what he could do and uh he
reminds me in like the way his hips and
the way he sinks and the way he uses his
leverage kind of in a similar role like
a brian allen for la interesting
i just like the kid a lot i think he's a
i think he's a good player i think he's
going to be a really good center
at some point
all right interior offensive lineman for
the las vegas raiders they took care of
the outside with tay adams as we've been
calling them and now it's time for the
tampa bay bucks going with rashad white
they went charles oh excuse me tampa bay
bucks tip of eight bucks they started
off with logan hall then luke decky and
now
they are going with rashad white connor
yeah little i mean i knew they needed a
running back right and rashad white
solid player but there's just a lot of
good running backs on the board here he
reminds me of kenyon drake a really good
slice and dice ability he could just cut
in the open field and get down field on
those on those breakaway plays as you
see there i do think it's a little early
for him uh but we know how important
running back was to them even after
bringing back leonard fournette he
tested really really well there is
athleticism
on the film but once again i value
damian pierce and i know these are
different backs these are power backs
damien pierce uh brian robinson jr and i
know they have leonard fournette but
once again they're just way better
players so for me this is a c-plus right
here so i i like this kid because he 43
catches last year and i think that's the
difference here because the guys that
we're talking about that have that have
better those are guys that don't make
catches like that take kyron williams
yeah oh see where i'm going that's a
yeah that's a good point kyron but the
the rest most of the rest of those don't
have that that pass catching production
he's a better athlete he's a i'm gonna
go i'm gonna go b-plus because i do
think he's a better athlete i think he's
also you saw him there the question i
was going to pose is is this a guy that
you think can play out in the slot too i
do think so and that to me adds value
and that value is something that you
you're even though counter rooms
probably a better running back you don't
get that additional value of moving it
around as a piece and i think as we look
at this with respect to
trying to make a run right now yes
having a little bit of a piece a safety
valve and all those things i think you
get that with him and i think that's why
he deserves a little bit more don't go
on to the next pick let me just ask this
as a follow-up better than giovanni
bernard right now at this point of
giovanni's career
because he could be more of a running
threat he just offers more because what
felder just said i thought of james
white and when i think of tom brady i
think he needs that young pass-catching
running back to really stretch a defense
i think white's flawless though in
passport and i i don't think rashad
white is there what rookie running backs
ever are yeah totally fair totally fair
the green bay packers are up the last
time we saw then they took wide receiver
christian watson out of north dakota
state do they go offense or defense and
it is going to be sean ryan with the
92nd pick
felder said ooh connor shook his head
yeah no in a good way in a good way this
is one of the best guard prospects on
the board uh you know a little bit like
the hair
prospect yeah yeah so he played tack
good call out felder he did play tackle
in college he had some struggles in pass
protection at tackle in college but i
think that's all going to be fixed at
guard where for me it's just less
thinking for the kind of player he is i
think i like his feet at guard better it
reminded me of just a heavier version of
cesar ruiz who was the first round pick
for the saints a couple years ago so i
really like how nasty he can be as a run
blocker and i think he's got enough
juice to pull as a guard so for sean
ryan here the packers are for i know i
was hard on them last night they are
phenomenal at drafting day two offensive
lineman some of the best in the entire
league out too they've taken some of my
favorites i mean when you look at elton
jenkins he has been a dynamite player
for them david baktiyari yeah they it's
for a decent fourth round it's
phenomenal so sean ryan this is a really
nice pick here uh b-plus it gives them
some depth and i think it'll help their
interior in the future and he would
slide if he could right in that right
guard spot they need some help there
jenkins and josh meyer what do you think
about this kid no i was that he put it i
was like don't pick the one i was going
to pick
but i was going to go v plus i i think
when you
when you throw out the proposition of
him moving inside being a little bit
protected to his outside that's a huge
plus for him because he he can't get all
the way up field especially with nfl
pass rushers but i do think he was
helped tremendously by playing on in
chip kelly's system where they were run
heavy and he really got to show off his
chops as a run blocker it's pretty wild
that you say he's not the best tackle
but 31 consecutive starts only allowed
two sacks in all of those starts
was the number two ranked guard in that
2019 recruiting class so he might end up
back there and he was a rugby player
growing up i don't know what it is rugby
feels tougher than football sometimes
well less bad no pass
we are now two picks ahead of television
and we're going to continue are we doing
a little rocket mortgage first
yeah you know what let's hear from our
friends at rocket mortgage cause we're
ahead
this crazy suit can give me an edge oh
yeah
huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in the housing game
rocket cam
one
all right here is the last 10 picks
nacobi dean was the eye opener him and
marcus jones we were waiting for them to
go but let me take that back malik
willis is the big story here malik
willis going to tennessee
the kobe dean going to the eagles and it
just makes you just want to take your
shoes off and just go
because
the kobe dean is on the eagles it feels
great uh malik willis is your next
quarterback
i just can't believe what i just
witnessed
i mean if you're not down with salehi
what are you even doing uh
san francisco 49ers are on the clock
they've taken one player in this draft
and it is drake jackson the defensive
end uh out of usc uh we don't know
what's going on with debose saml alex
mac there's a chance he could retire
yeah i don't know if there's a center
out there that you think makes sense and
that fits in kyle shanahan's system
anything i look more at safety for them
with nick cross on the board for our
looking
opposite of jimmy ward let's see what
they go with
put it on the board do we have safety
survey says
lsu running back ty davis price and
there's not one position that i think
kyle shannon has hit less on in these
last few years than a middle round
running back
michael felder just said who i did not
say who i said why
yes i said what running back out of lsu
does he fit that kyle shanahan scheme
not at all in my eyes north south runner
uh power not creative in my eyes had
some mammoth games and you're seeing one
right here against florida where his
offensive line gave a room and he broke
tackles at the second level
i know he this to me says they saw the
testing numbers which you see are really
good there sub 4 5 speed and said oh
yeah you fit the white zone i don't
think he plays like that he is
player 193 for me i did not think they
needed running back help i did not think
they needed running back help on day two
i thought they needed safety help or
interior offensive line help or maybe
depending what happens for their star
receiver that doesn't plan on coming
back capitalize on the wide receiver
draft here get a little bit ahead
i don't like this pick at all i i don't
even if ty davis price is a
average player or a good player
they didn't they didn't need to do this
i don't think he's a good fit uh this is
a d i i don't understand this at all did
kyle shanahan just have to have a
running back and do you have to have one
here and there's what eight better right
now i don't get it
congratulations to dai davis price for
good thank you for getting drafted
absolutely amazing accomplishments
your life is about to change i'm gonna
give this a c minus listen c's get
degrees and
that's what that's that's that's he's a
he's a downhill runner he is he's like
he's like great value leonard fournette
yeah and that's not what you want in
this no and so like so can we wrap this
one up so we can talk about this before
because i that's like that's all like
that to me is
the only note i want to say is
it's very interesting that two years in
a row in the third round a running back
is taken by the 49ers that we don't
think fits their scheme right and last
year we gave them we gave them the
benefit of the doubt we looked at trey
sermon and we said man it's kyle
shanahan they're going to figure it out
and then trey sermon couldn't even get
in the field on preseason yeah now they
take ty davis price and we're sitting
there and we're going i know that you
guys these are
what are we looking these are the
running backs taken
we're look listen when you watch ty
davis price or trey sherman what do we
see we see lead blocking plays like
we're watching lead blockers pull and
lead them through the hole and then they
run through that we're not seeing wide
zone stretch zone outside who is the guy
named joe that the san francisco 49ers
took like three or four years ago from
utah yes
jos is it was his last name smith or
something washington no yeah either way
they have elijah mitchell which is my
bigger point here i i thought elijah
mitchell looks really like also jeff
wilson but my thing is when you when you
run shanahan system i thought the whole
advantage to the the shanahan system was
you could put anybody in there and it
works so then why are we using draft
picks on running backs no offense to
running back well there's two things one
you can't put anybody in there anymore
uh-oh the panthers trade up and take
matt corral
matt corral chris sims right now is
smiling shout out to my guy quarterback
matt corral out of ole miss 6-2 2-12
only fbs player with 3 300 passing yards
and 500 rushing yards the last two
seasons he's responsible for 75
touchdowns in 37 games played the coach
there says kids gravitate towards him
and he's the son of a marine
fixed his interceptions 20-5 touchdown
interception ratio last year
everything i hear about him is that the
ball snaps and he's going to be
competing with sam darnold and so my
question for you connor is when they go
to training camp is he going to look
better than sam darnold right away
physically throwing the football i think
so i think he has a better arm now he's
a guy that needs time as well right a
little reckless at times in college with
the football he played in a system where
everything was very defined for him he
knew where he was going with the
football and if it did not look good
over there it was okay i will run with
the football so
he is a true kind of one read college
quarterback where in training camp in
just passing drills he's going to
impress lefko i think when the bullets
are flying a little bit and things are
going really fast it's going to take
some time for matt corral now i'm
fascinated by this draft pick because
we've heard for the last 24 hours that
they were considering making a trade for
baker mayfield so does that take this
off the table right interesting it's
very interesting matt corral sam darnold
uh you have darnold there who can play
matt crowd was my 49th overall player so
i really like the value here for
carolina you had to take your shot
eventually i'm glad you got a tackle in
the top ten you got the best player in
the draft and icky iquanu so this is a
good pick this is a b-plus for me he's
got a lot of arm talent he's got a lot
of athleticism but being a pro
quarterback he's a little far from that
right now
how do you feel about matt carrell at
pick number 94 yes
eight plus oh
at 94 a plus
where would what it would have been at
pick 49
b-plus okay so why a-plus because he
gets a little bit he doesn't have to
play this upcoming year he can play but
i love what he brings to the table this
is a guy that has true faith in his arm
you want to talk about a quarterback
that has a completely eroded sense of
confidence that's sam donald
so now you're bringing this is the
opposite the complete opposite he
believes you're gonna have like sam
darnold and then you're matt corral
being like what up brah yes yeah yeah
yeah that's well put yes i mean he's i
like it he believed this guy
he he has a brett favion belief in his
arm
and
it's worked for him pretty well and
watching him back when he was committed
to usc watching him be like listen i
don't care that the safety's over the
top and i'm staring down my receiver i
can punch it in there because i'm
special and he has that about him so
watching him play has been really fun
watching him grow to go from
the golden boy that was supposed to go
to usc from southern california to
follow lane kiffin to ole miss to get to
ole miss and really kickstart they they
were one of the most fun teams to watch
if you like offense that's what they
brought to the table so for me i look at
him this is an a plus if you get him at
94. and for the panthers
don't know that you hit your wagon to
him fully but i do know that you give
him a chance to compete right now and
then you can go from there because
they're gonna have a lot of fun it's
gonna be
it's they're gonna listen a lot of folks
don't know about this because
charlotte's a small what we call a small
market but these gonna be the cardiac
cats again yes telling you baby uh two
big story lines come with this draft
pick these are the draft recap kitty
pickett was the only one to go in the
first round and then we had three
quarterbacks go in the third round
desmond ritter malik willis and matt
corral let me just give this point
before we move on to the cincinnati
bengals
matt corral's draft pick does two things
for me number one is something that
connor just said it raises the question
so then where is baker going to go it
lessens the amount of teams that he can
get traded to and now suddenly you're
going you're not going to keep him in
the same locker or mr sean watson
the second thing is what does this do to
matt rule's timeline as the coach with
the carolina panthers right now now he
doesn't want to because he's going but
it's a third round quarterback that's
not my guy
you're hitched
how you develop matt corral will be very
definitive to the amount of duration
that you have with the carolina panthers
the third rounder usually doesn't matter
that much but they did trade for him
and i will say it's yeah you're right
it's got now here's my question or my
fear not to be the glass half empty guy
it's okay if sam darnold goes full sam
darnold again this year and you have
people in the stands cheering for matt
corral to come in because they need a
spark and macaron can give you a spark
yes if anything he can give you a spark
i don't know if that's the best for matt
corral's development and if that team
erodes is that the end of the matt rule
era and they're just starting with a
completely clean slate next year i'll
just say that wide receiver room is
exciting if christian mccaffrey is
healthy it's going to be fun you've got
a franchise tackle now
that can come in and that defense is
young and if they're healthy could make
a run but it is interesting that matt
corral is the ultimate let's give him
time to develop guy but you know what
happens if you throw him out there and
he has success he's so much fun that
it's hard bingo and and that's what's so
fascinating about this is in pre-season
you nailed it the backup always gets
more time than the starter oh yeah and
if he starts going ha ha ha ha
and then david tepper is going to be
there and he's going to be sitting there
and he's going to go play let's play
corral let's play corral
zach carter to the bengals uh at pick
number 95 uh as you know what now that
we got the quarterbacks off the board
it's a little bit more calm here but
defensive lineman out of florida 6-4 282
do we like the value here i do like the
value here he's my 99th overall player
so it aligns nearly perfectly for
zachary carter he is as felder would say
steady eddie right he could set a hard
edge he gives you a lot of effort as a
pass rusher he's tough in the trenches
you see him take on blocks work off the
blocks stack and shed make plays against
the run high effort against the pass
obviously hits like a madman i just love
the fire he plays with
a true five tech kind of player at that
size yeah so and you can kick him in on
passing downs that's a great question i
think he's a really really good run
defender as well so i like zac carter
here for a front that needed some depth
he's gonna be able to rotate in right
away this is a really really strong pick
the value's right on um this is a b for
me for the bengals yeah he listen he's
what he is and i'm glad you steady eddie
i love it because this is a guy that's
gonna show up to work every single day
now listen he he's not gonna get you a
ton of sex no don't worry about that no
but you know what he's also not gonna do
he's not gonna give up five yards per
run right he's gonna shut that stuff
down you're gonna he's gonna be sitting
right there ready to tackle he's gonna
set a hard judge your linebackers are
gonna have to do their job now and you
see him there with a nice club to get to
the interior to go make a play love to
see that he's got a little bit of a move
there are some moves in his repertoire i
think he's at his best lined up right
there over top of that tackle so that he
can set that hard edge if you if you get
him lined up with the chip on the
outside on the tight end he's gonna have
some problems but when you get him like
this look at the strap oh that's nice
you see that you see that long arm
left-handed he was writing in his book i
was was it nice it was a long arm walk
the guy right back into the quarterback
it was beautiful he's got power this guy
is a pure power player and i love that
about him even his pass rush moves where
we often think about a swim or a spin
yeah his passers moves our power the
long arm that walked back that guy into
the quarterback that's the swipe he can
he if he hits you on your outside
shoulder you're falling back to the
inside and then he's walking to the
quarterback what i love is this oh great
i got to get my grade though yeah what
do you got listen i'm gonna get b i'm
gonna do b-plus
[Laughter]
uh i trey hendrickson is a guy that's
like that dj reader's a guy that's like
that that's a monster d-line and when
you're up against the steelers and the
ravens and all that it makes sense colts
are up and they are taking safety nick
cross out of maryland six foot 212. he's
a fluid mover excellent blitzer downside
is he's got some average eyes but what
do we think nick cross safety here going
to the colts an insane athlete i
compared him to laurent landry that's
the kind of player this guy is he can
absolutely fly when you look at him on
tape
now everything's still coming together
in terms of figuring it out at the
position like finding it instincts but
he's got such great burst and speed that
it makes up for the lack of instincts at
times he can come downhill fly make big
time tackles but i like his upside and
coverage if you want to use him as a too
high kind of safety and you're gonna see
it here track the ball it hung in the
air for a while go make the play go get
the ball sideline to sideline range so
nick cross this is kind of that swing
for the fences in the third round pick
you see a lot of safeties go off the
board there good box safeties for sure
fire tackler nick cross it's it's a hail
mary kind of pick of can you make big
time plays on the football because of
your athleticism so for that it's a
b-plus for me because this is the time
of the draft that you do that i'm
actually a little surprised he's here i
heard some rumblings he can go in the
second round colts lost george odom in
free agency they did have some big
additions though in that back end stefan
gilmore will be the corner there it'll
be interesting to see this is a gus
bradley system so it's a little bit of
that richard sherman uh cover cover
three press bail yeah uh and if you got
a rangy safety which is what it sounds
like he is it could be exciting yeah
this is my i love this dude yeah he's a
player yeah i'm gonna give it an a right
now
look dick cross can move cross is able
to move sideline to sideline i love when
they put him on a string right up and
down up and down with it the way they
trade with motion this is a guy that in
the first world three yes at 212 pounds
wow 212 4-3 look at him here move come
get downhill make a tackle i love that
this is a guy when you put him on the
string you go i go he's able to make
tackles behind the line of scrimmage
because of that explosive speed he can
make bad steps which i've seen him do
yes i've seen him take bad steps and
then still redirect and make a pbu so
what do you have to do fix the eyes you
have to fix the eyes but if you fix
those eyes and you combine eyes that are
good with 4-3 speed now all of a sudden
you got a superman back there that could
save everything you know what i think of
when i hear about a 4-3 speed safety for
the colts i think about what malik
hooker could have been yeah and just
with his injuries and all that stuff so
we'll see you know what now's a great
time to take a chance on an athlete like
this and if it hits
you look like a genius this is the time
to do it that's why i'm a big fan we are
now into the compensatory picks of the
third round uh and next up is the
detroit lions we have the pick they have
not given it on tv we'll give it to you
here kirby joseph to the lions our guy
jordan schultz breaks and he gets a
double fist pump from our michael felder
another safety back to back safety and
this dude is explosive 38 and a half
inch verse for illinois connor rogers
the value yeah coverage safety here
player 125 on the board so the value
checks out for him when you look at it
he's somebody that just made a lot of
plays in coverage i think the tackling
was just okay but that's not really what
you're using him for using him for his
range over the top and you see the
ability to go up and win the football so
i like kirby joseph for a very defined
role he didn't want to use him as a
third safety and allow one of your
normal safeties come down in the box and
make plays blitz he can handle
everything over the top he's responsible
in coverage once again he's got really
good range so if you needed a safety
they're going hot and heavy right now
real real fast especially a coverage one
like kirby joseph so for me right here
this is a b-plus pick just a little bit
of how this defense fits before you go
tracy walker is the leader of this
defense on the back end and they have
will harris will harris last year had to
play slot corner and safety but they
really want him at slot corner the hope
here likely is you throw kirby in the
back and now your whole secondary is
filled out you kind of get two positions
for the pickup that's right and walker
could play closer to the line of
scrimmage this is the right mold yeah
he's great single high he's great too
high i'll be real quick here i'm gonna
give it an a minus the only reason
because veronica's still out there i
think he's a little bit better as a
player better instincts better eyes but
here's the reality when it comes to
kirby joseph this is a guy the best play
that he had was against iowa and it's
against iowa and they cinnamon in motion
and what you're gonna get is a run
action they're gonna get it's a running
back give the running back pitches it
it's a philly special essentially and
every it's washed out completely
everyone bites on it and kirby joseph
says no no no sir not me i got the speed
to get on my horse i'm tracking this one
down breaks up the pass just a great
touchdown saving play but that's the
epitome of what he can do he's really
great at getting out of the middle of
the field to get to the sideline and go
make a play richard sherman it's going
to be aaron glenn's defense how does
kirby joseph fit into it
i think he's ranger i think he's
instinctive i think i mean he needs more
reps i think he just needs more reps
it's his first year as a full-time
starter and at times it looked like it
you know at times it looked like he was
he was a bit rusty out there a bit
indecisive but i think he makes big
plays he high points the football
anytime you're getting your hands on the
football he had five interceptions
you can appreciate that he comes
downhill he makes big tackles he plays
the position like you want it to be
played he just needs more reps and i
think obviously in detroit he's going to
have a chance to get that they don't
have a ton of depth in their secondary
he should be able to come right in get a
lot of reps learn on the fly and i think
he'll be a good player for him but i
think he just needs more time you know
one year as a star full-time starter
usually isn't enough and so i expect him
to get more more time and more reps and
be a good player
all right we are now on to the
washington commanders they had jahan
dotson in the first round they came back
in the second round and went with the d
lyman out of alabama washington now with
their third pick pick 98
in this draft what are we thinking here
man we saw them go d-line already right
stack up the d-line and there it is and
i love this pick okay are you really
really oh big bruiser great we'll get
into it
it's awesome brian robinson what are we
thinking a big bruiser a train rolling
down the tracks and you don't want to be
in his path but he's got enough wiggles
right there 225 453 you know how alabama
likes their running backs brian robinson
fits the mold he was patient he waited a
long time to play you see the soft hands
get up field make a move get up field
and he's got the big frame to run
through tacklers and once again so
reliable in pass protection there was no
role this guy could not handle the fact
that he's got that kind of movement with
his feet at 225 pounds six foot two he
just wears down defenses that's what it
is with him so for washington you get a
little antonio gibson obviously i was
gonna say
what do you think there i mean it was a
little bit banged up last year yeah and
once again you're looking for guys that
can close out football games wear down
defenses that's what brian robinson does
he was my 83rd overall player he reminds
me of james connor just a guy that
nobody wants to tackle he wears you out
this is an a for me this is an awesome
pick for washington and this is a three
down runner he truly truly is don't get
mixed up by the side he's size he's got
enough burst yeah he's good he's really
good and he did wait a long time i would
listen to talk about how long he waited
i'm gonna read the numbers for you lefko
2017 24 touches or excuse me 2017 24
carries it's an apic for me
2018 we're talking about a guy had 63
touch 63 carries 2019 96 carries 20 20
91 carries and then 2021 when he finally
got the rock 271 carries this is a guy
he doesn't have as many cares as some of
the other patients he's patient
he did his job he did everything that
nick saban asked him to do waiting
patiently behind the other running backs
who do they have they have obviously
naji the kid that went through the
raiders he got the other guy davey and
harris they got all these guys he had to
wait behind to get his turn and when he
got his turn he can catch the ball in
the backfield he is nearly immaculate in
pass protection really yes he's
remarkable because this is what this is
he's during the phase where alabama
transitioned into becoming a passing
offense so he's very good in pass
protection and he's very good catching
the ball in the backfield and then of
course he can do the traditional thing
to expect an alabama running back to do
he's strong he's willing to fight he'll
pick up extra yards he always falls
forward great pickup for them this is a
guy
who should come in and be a starter
if if if he has an opportunity you give
you give him an inch he'll take a mile
from you nice
891 yards after contact fifth in power
five the cleveland browns are up uh
martin emerson the cornerback was their
first pick then they went alex wright
the edge player and now at pick number
99
the cleveland browns series are
selecting there it is david bell
purdue the wide receiver at 99.
david bell comes in first team
all-american
two-time first team all big ten set the
purdue record with 17 100 yard receiving
games in just 29 games averaged over a
hundred yards per seat receiving every
game only dropped the ball 4.7 percent
of the time and the coaches say he
played through a lot of minor injuries
you like this guy i do like him he
really had a tough process right because
the film is so good contested catch
monster super productive all three
seasons freshman sophomore junior years
not the best separator but he always
finds the ball in traffic i called him
the honda civic of this draft he'll get
you from point a to b there's no flash
here with david bell that four six five
forty it's what hurt him it's why he's
sitting down this late in the draft
really reminds me of jacoby myers right
everybody looks at the measurables the
testing and you sit there and go well
wide receivers are more dynamic athletes
than this it doesn't work on pages so
the guy they just lost jarvis landry
yeah exactly you turn on the tape
possession receiver and a really really
solid one so for me uh this is a b for
david bell he's one of the better wide
receivers on the board sure he's not
explosive but he'll be that checked down
kind of piece for deschamps a nice piece
for deshawn i love this kid he's a he is
incredibly
good at making contested catches that
part reminds me of dj moore
when he was coming out of maryland dj
morrow was a guy who wasn't always
separated fully so i'm going to give it
an a minus he
is willing to make contested catches he
will fight through contact to play to
the football and he does something that
i really really love lefko he doesn't
look at the refs and ask for help
he doesn't look at the reps and asks for
help he is a guy that puts it on the
onus is on him to make the catch he's
not asking for help and i love the fact
that he's willing to play through
context what i love is the makeup of
these wide receiving core right now
amari cooper can shake anybody out of
their shoes
donovan people jones is your big lob
ball guy jacreen jakeem grant is your
shifty dude jacreen
and then david bell is your i can trust
him with a big catch on the third down
because he's not going to drop it uh
what do you think of monroe st brown
when you watch david bell and and all
the analysis that you're hearing from us
you know i love this pick i watched him
a lot at purdue
i think what stands out most about his
game is his hands i think he has one of
the best hands in his class and his body
control you watch i forget what game it
is he had a ridiculous deep ball
so i love his hands i love his body
control after the catch i think he's
really good too he's just not the
fastest and i think that's what hurt him
in this draft um but i think he'll be an
awesome pro
um he's going to find his niche in this
in this league but i think his hands and
his body control is what stands out most
when i watch him play and you know what
and there's a chance jarvis landrieu can
come back to this team but that 4 6
speed is not everything because as we've
talked about it how do you play with
pads next pick is in arizona just went
edge and then they went edge again my j
sanders does a great job finding passing
lanes 13 passes defended over the past
three years knows how to get his hands
up
not only that
13 and a half sacks and another
cincinnati guy off the board for arizona
cardinals one of my best players
available right here this might be lofty
praise but i saw a lot of randy gregory
on film a tall slender kind of guy that
just knows how to win uh with getting
off the snap that's the most important
thing on maj sanders whenever he was
allowed to just go he gets off the
football and puts himself in
advantageous positions against the
tackle where they're a step behind him
and that's what's special about him sure
the sack production is not insane but
the athleticism is good he's a disrupter
he found ways to disrupt plays i love
the outside speed rush arizona needed
pass rush help
they go cam thomas and then my jay
sanders and mj sanders is better than
cam thomas so this is this is a nice
pick this is an a for me uh i think he's
going to be a serious contributor and i
think it's going to be quick
i love him this guy can play and here's
the thing
it's an a plus for me i don't care about
his sack production because that's not
what they asked him to do with
cincinnati no this is a scheme that asks
him to go up field be disruptive and
then we're gonna let beavers we're gonna
let we're going to let do blanco they'll
clean up the mess you just go be
disruptive make the quarterback step up
into the pocket make the make the guy
get off his mark protect our make the
quarterback get out of his rhythm right
our corners are going to take care of
everything
and then the linebackers are going to
clean it up for you are we going to get
to we're going to get to talk cincinnati
with with kelsey are we going to be not
we're not going to get to do that okay
because i was i was going to keep it
short but now i can go a little bit
longer yes you can listen
in the nfl he's got an opportunity to be
a very special guy because now he gets
the rush under more control yeah now he
gets to bend the edge and not get on top
of the quarterback now he can take a
more direct route to the quarterback
instead of trying to play with his hair
on fire and push the guy off the point
so that it helps the rest of the team
now at this level with this approach
that they're going to bring to the table
they do want him to get sacked and i
think that's going to be a difference in
the system that he played in college
compared to now and i like that they're
double dipping to try and replace
chandler jones to see if they can find
something them and the falcons did a
really nice job today
capitalizing on one of the strongest
edge rush classes i've ever seen really
and just get in pieces let's get pieces
uh your team is up the new york jets i'm
looking at their picks they got great
corner they got a great wide receiver
they got a great pass rusher then they
get a great running back they've gotten
arguably one of the top guys in every
single position the only thing i haven't
seen is an offensive lineman is there a
player or a pick that you're hoping for
here or do you in fact know who they're
taking i know who they're taking and
they took the best player available on
my board ironically but if you wanted to
go offensive line route which they
didn't daniel fellaily would have been
interesting right tackle this is the top
guy on your board the best player
available on my board just get right
into it yeah jeremy rucker second round
grade ohio state reminds me of hunter
henry an excellent blocking tight end
that was underutilized in the past game
another help huge catch radius sure they
went out inside cj uzama uh you got
tyler conklin uzama's been banged up a
lot so now this gives you a little
insurance for a team that wants to run a
ton of 12 personnel get two tight ends
on the field rucker another player i got
to see in person this year so good
blocking on the move and ohio state one
of the best wide receiver schools in the
entire country they didn't need to throw
on the ball a lot but when they did he
could be a possession guy in that you
know five to 12 yard area he's got a big
catch radius in the red zone that's
going to be really big for zach wilson
they didn't have a guy that could do
that last isn't he from new york he's
from long island his dad's a jets fan
yeah i'm sure the rucker family is it's
just a cool moment
his dad is a
huge jets fan this is a really cool
moment for the rucker family i would
imagine he wanted to come home
and this is an awesome pick for the jets
there's no way around it he's my 53rd
overall player he's my best player on
the board this is an a i think he's
going to be a little bit more productive
as a receiver at the next level then he
got the chance to at ohio state i was
going to say never had more than 57
yards in a game but i don't think that
was his fault no when you have garrett
wilson and chris olavey yes and on and
on and on like come on and then you have
the running backs that you have to get
the ball to as well you lose some
production so the big key for me with
him is watching the way that he's able
to use that athleticism he's strong too
that's the other part even though he's
athletic it's he's not a he's not greg
dosage he is a full-body tight end and
that's something that is hard to tackle
for safeties and you see him there turn
a five-yard catch into a first down and
that's what you want your tight end to
be able to do see him there as the wing
come back across the formation now he's
an option turn into a blocker help your
quarterback get a first down he could do
all those things rucker for me when i
look at him this is an a-plus because a
lot of people thought he might be a
first-round pick really yes
they thought as a tight end he was he
was he was being projected over trey
mcbride by for some people because he
had big game potential and he had the
body of an actual tight end that said
he's got a bigger body
big time you know thick frame to bla you
could see him i mean you see it all the
time you know what the biggest thing
with jeremy rucker is that i walked away
and said wow is how he handled george
carloftus on the line of scrimmage and i
said whoa blocking him one-on-one
one-on-one so maybe they didn't take the
tackle but they put a they got a guy
that you put next to a tackle and he's
helping out but i mean you if you really
guys think that he could have been the
top tight end in this class you could
make the argument that they got the
number one player at all of those
positions yeah
running back tight end wide receiver
pass rusher and cornerback that's pretty
darn good for joe douglas i'm gonna tell
you ohio state playing at rutgers
helped out our boy yeah connor got to
scout everything
connor got to scout everybody we are now
at the first pick of the draft for the
miami dolphins why because they gave up
five draft picks for tyree kill big
offseason trade for tyree kill signed to
ron armstead sign connor williams signed
chase edmonds science cedric wilson sign
raheem mostert uh they can go a lot of
places here it's their first pick in the
draft i feel like you already know who
it is no i don't but i would think
offensive line i've heard them looking
at this offensive line class extensively
mike mcdaniel's scheme you need
athleticism i look at zach tom from wake
forest compared to james daniels he's
going to move inside to center at the
next level that would be the best
athlete of the offensive lineman left on
the board i'm very curious to see where
they go maybe
they're not happy with that peter it's
in a contract here on armstrong so he's
a free agent after this
yeah that offensive line is going to get
a home makeover they got to ron armstead
a good start um but they're going to and
they don't really have the capital to do
it obviously they had to wait till
outside the top 100. so we're going to
see where this selection goes i know
mike mcdaniel what if it's boston
college's alex lindstrom little early
who played for the o lying coach michael
applebaum in college you never know it's
early for me it is channing tindall
that's a good pitch georgia linebacker
and they did need somebody next to
jerome baker yeah that's a really good
pick they got a lot of athleticism in
the middle of the field it is going to
be the new linebacker for defensive
coordinator josh boyer is channing
tindall
out of georgia four four seven speed
yeah and my player comp forum was jerome
baker so it's wow let's see how teams
obviously and the defensive staff stayed
so let's exactly so channing tindall i
really like the run and chase he's still
figuring it out finding the ball at
times but when you know obviously he was
kept clean at a georgia defensive line
that was loaded with talent where you
can let him run he's excellent at that
he's got excellent see ball get ball
ability i think that's going to help in
coverage as well it's going to have
special teams for them too yeah he could
do it all he obviously waited his turn
to play this guy can run though that's
the most important thing it's going to
be a good a blitz a gap blitzing machine
as well for miami so i like tyndall's
value here as the 82nd player in this
draft i don't think the dolphins would
get this good of a player waiting
outside the top 100 this is an a for me
in miami this is a quiet need for them
in the middle of the defense really
really nice pick i love the jerome baker
comp because i see it it's one of those
things baker especially as a guy that
came in that was a running back in high
school came in converted it it was him
chasing down the play tyndall chasing
down the play obviously like one of
those guys at nicoby dean help get lined
up in the right way going to play with a
veteran like baker it's going to help
him get lined up and be able to play
pretty early for me i look at this i'm
going to go with an a as well listen we
we ragged on the the koi walker pick
because it was too early if you would
have got koi walker down here wouldn't
would have been so bad this is the
opposite of that we're getting a guy
that we thought could have thought we
thought might go in the second round
earlier in the third now you're getting
in the compensatory picks at the end of
the third round this is a big positive
for them and he's someone that i think
at minimum four cores but probably gonna
come in and compete for some time early
at the minimum be a part of a rotation
i'm just sitting here going wow that
georgia defense was pretty darn insanity
so what are we got we got we had two
more today we have three uh two more
ones we had two more get picked today
kobe dean
tyndall
who's who we know that darion kendrick
is left let's see if another one goes we
only got three picks left and the chiefs
take washington excuse me wisconsin
linebacker leo chanel
leo chanel goes to the kansas city
chiefs the linebacker first team
all-american first team all big ten big
ten linebacker of the year led the big
ten and tackles for loss with 18 and a
half he's a workout warrior that bends
420 cleans 385 and he was on punt
coverage and connor's licking his lips i
mean look at the player comp taller
version of nick bolton
he's on the team who's on the team so
it's just easy to kind you start to get
a sense of what gm's like the kind of
player they like i love the value here
the 55th overall player for me uh a
great athlete coming downhill now the
testing will tell you he's one of the
freakiest athletes in the entire draft i
didn't see felder the looseness the
flexibility and gameplay in the gameplay
to you know run with the running back
running a wheel route or things like
that or run down the seam with a titan i
saw a lot of downhill speed a tough guy
a tough guy he does not care he'll take
on contact he'll take on car crashes he
makes tackles he is maybe the best
blitzing linebacker in the draft devin
lloyd may be the best pass rushing
linebacker uh leo chanel the best
blitzer it's the timing it's changing
the tempo it's understanding when the
gap is going to open up i love leo
chanel this is tremendous value for the
chiefs they get another nick bolton who
was pretty damn good for them last year
this is an a plus for me really well
done by brett beach to get value outside
the top 100. heck of a ballplayer right
here this is a guy he holds his water
when you're talking about the blitzing i
was like the thing about him is he holds
his water so he's really good coming
downhill i'll go a plus as well he he
holds his water what i mean by that is
he keeps the disguise up he keeps it up
keeps it up keeps it up unless he's
doing that which is him mugged up when
he's mugged up he can shoot your a-gap
but that's not really a blitz that's
just him going deciding to make a play
to make a decision on those run gaps but
when he's blitzing coming from depth he
holds his water holds the disguise then
he goes he's also great at green dog
which is
waiting until that running back decides
to block want that running back blocks
he adds to the run fit and then he goes
and gets the quarterback all beautiful
things he is very good coming downhill
but i love i i love when he's mugged up
question i have changed the direction
and while he's out there while he tested
well the reality is when you watch the
tape the change of direction is not
there for the redirect to the wheel for
him to play in a sort of appeal scheme
yes where he comes downhill and it looks
like a green dog and the running back
peels out i question that change of
direction to peel with that running back
which could lead to a free first down
for an offense but again i gave it an a
plus because this guy's a really good
linebacker and wisconsin consistently
produces really good linebackers he
knows what he's doing he's been he's
being taught at wisconsin by a pro so
you know they know what they're doing
yeah chiefs entered last year they were
bottom five in past defense they were
bottom ten in rush defense they were
bottom five in sacks and you go man
there's a lot of pressure on patma homes
they go out there and get a corner a d
lineman a safety and a linebacker to
improve every single layer of that
defense the super bowl champion rams
they have made their selection and look
at the push from logan bruss offensive
lineman out of wisconsin they're big
dudes 6'5 309 logan bruss an offensive
alignment that they need do we think can
guard or we think can tackle what are we
thinking here tackling college gonna
play guard at the next level uh one of
my favorite values 91st overall player
reminds me of dalton reisner had a third
round grade on him once again the rams
waiting a really long time you could
tell they did their homework of the
value of the offensive line class we saw
the viral video of them laughing that
cole strange went in the first round
they really liked him they get a really
good player in logan bruss once again a
good athlete and that's gonna that fits
what they want to do on the offensive
side of the ball around an eight
relative athletic score he can move
sideline to sideline he's got good
change of direction he can fit his own
scheme i think he's strong enough to be
a dry blocker as well so once again he's
going to kick inside from a lot of
tackle experience but guard play and i
think he could start for the rams i
really do this is a b-plus for me right
here at sean mcvay's house as they're
making this pick is the retired andrew
whitworth there is some turnover for
this rams offensive line they also lost
austin corbett the right guard in free
agency he went to carolina you think
this guy can come in right away yeah if
you move him inside i don't think
outside i think outside he's gonna have
some problems but if you move him inside
certainly i think he'd come in i think
they want to play note boom at left
tackle so that measures up oh but he can
move listen i think he's athletic enough
to move he's got to work on that
stick-to-itiveness that we want to see
with when it comes to getting blocks
especially blocks that are outside of
the box but he's a pusher and you want
to see a pusher a guy that's able to go
out and move bodies and stay stuck on
them so that he can get him he's already
got the ability to cut them off from the
front side of the play now you want them
to get them out of the way so you can
create bigger holes that's the part
where moving playing the guard he's
going to get a little bit more of a head
of steam if he's pulling or opportunity
to get to the second level if i'm going
to give this thing a grade i think i'm
going to go with a b i think that he's
got a lot of a lot of tools the question
is going to be how does he do kicking
down inside yeah it's it's uh easier
said than done i think a lot of people
don't realize that it's a good point
felder and now the final pick of the
third round it is going to be the san
francisco 49ers with everything with
debo they are going wide receiver out of
smu it is danny gray from the mustangs
danny gray the pick for the san
francisco 49ers the last pick of the
first round what kind of wide-out is
this oh straight gas i mean you just see
him turn up the field they got
manufacturers shallow crossers things
like that drag rats get the ball in his
hands let him run and then you can
obviously push the ball vertically state
champion 100 meter runner in high school
from texas burner before and after the
catch he killed teams on that drag route
catch and run no angle is safe and
you're going to probably see it right
here just no angle is safe the safety
thinks he can come downhill and get him
he gets to the sideline and beats you
downfield so
danny gray man the hands are wildly
inconsistent right but he's a way better
more complete player than taekwon
thornton it's not that all over again
but the hands were a little inconsistent
i just like that straight line gas in
the niners uh niners offense you're
going to get play-action boot working
he's the guy you're going to send down
the field player 103 for me the value is
perfect and i just love the fit in the
offense i was really high on danny gray
not a lot of guys that run the low four
threes like him super productive player
this is an a for me i think shanahan's
gonna have a lot of fun with this one he
is uh a much better pick than the
running back selection of davis price oh
he's a better pick than that for sure
when it comes to my grade i do have to
go with the bee
because i don't know if he can catch and
it's that bad it's not it's not that
it's that bad it's not again it's not
taekwondon bad but it's like it's a lot
of body catching
and as a defensive back if you're body
catching that means i got an opportunity
to get in there yeah and that's the part
that that's a little scary versus a guy
that's catching the ball out here and
he's got it he's got it it looks like
there's more space here but when you got
it locked in right here
you can take it away keep it away from
me but if you're letting it get all the
way in here i can get in there and push
it out that way so that's just a big
thing for me super fast though and look
100 meter state champion in texas
a little bit different than montana yeah
that means something yeah a monroe st
brown what do we think of when you watch
danny gray on tape
yeah watching his tape he's a burner
like like you guys said you let him
catch the ball in stride over the middle
i mean no one's catching him he had a
few focus drops which i noticed on tape
i don't know how good of a route runner
is how polished he is i think if you can
get him in a play action have those
linebackers bite and just dump it to him
over the middle let him run i mean i
think that's his best bet in this league
he definitely has room for improvement
but i mean turning on that tape no one's
catching him he's once he gets it and
there's and there's room in front of him
he's gone um i wish he would be a little
more physical at the point of contact
when people are trying to tackle him i
think he can work on that but other than
that i mean he's a burner you get you
get him the ball with space it's over i
love the fact that we think that kyle
shanahan can create some separation for
him underneath and then you blink and he
is gone
that is the first three rounds of the
draft it's crazy that we finished it i
want to say goodbye to our guys that
have held it down remotely so let's
bring up a monroe st brown man you held
it down it was a big wide receiver class
we appreciate you uh thank you so much
jason kelsey the the legend i know
you're tired from all the yelling
richard sherman
a hall of famer so good let's start off
with richard sherman go down the line uh
first of all thank you guys but richard
uh what did you think of this draft the
first three rounds i know the
quarterbacks hit late
i thought it was crazy i mean it was
crazy i don't know what the record for
trades and movement in a draft is but i
feel like this is one of the most crazy
drafts i've ever watched in terms of
trades up trades back the jets were so
aggressive early they got the guys they
wanted i was really really happy just
because i know robert salah and i i
liked the draft he had um i thought the
corners market was a little different
than we saw was going to be i definitely
didn't see
ritter getting picked as the second
quarterback
it was different you know i'm happy
malik willis eventually came off the
board he went to a good situation in
tennessee and
and i mean it's gonna be good
my man thank you so much jason kelsey
boy did i see a lot of cincinnati
bearcats getting drafted but overall i
feel like the eagles had a great draft
how was the draft from your perspective
uh i mean this is an awesome experience
i uh really appreciate the opportunity
to come out here and hang out with you
guys
really happy for all my
bearcats now former bearcats yeah along
with me
uh welcome to the nfl excited to join
all my teammates in philadelphia my new
teammates
um and man i do not envy you guys uh as
someone who's kind of just trying to dip
his toe in and figure out whether this
is fun to do
and just do an o-line d-line where i
feel comfortable
uh it just makes uh
what you three guys do uh that much more
impressive uh to have to know all these
guys and he's still got another day left
so
good luck i mean it's an impressive
amount of
tape you guys have all watched and put
in so
way to go
you know normally i would try and be
humble but at the same time thanks bro
we
we we not only do we appreciate it but
we deserve it uh and then we'll end with
the monroe st brown
you're you're the young guy here man and
and you came out here you've played with
a bunch of these guys that got drafted
whether it was in high school or college
had to be cool to see a bunch of your
friends get drafted
tell me he froze right at that moment
i was like man that dude is focused
right now
a laser beam into me but amman ross st
brown was great thank you to him jason
kelsey and richard sherman before we say
goodbye because you guys are going to be
here tomorrow yeah i just want to say
one thing really quick and i want to
just toot our own horn really quick
if you guys were checking out the tv
broadcast what you saw in the third
round is the issue with the nfl draft on
national television they're showing
magic tricks they're showing the
fountain like it matters but we know
that complete franchises are changed in
the third round and they didn't care
they don't care they care about ad
dollars we don't okay rocket mortgage
hooked us up to the point where we could
break down these guys and these two
legends right here connor rogers and
michael felder care and they watch
everything and tomorrow when the nfl
network is talking about matt corral and
they're talking about desmond ritter
they're gonna be breaking down every
single picks in round four through seven
and i'm so excited to watch you guys
tomorrow you're gonna kill it but let's
wrap up tonight
the the the picks that have stuck with
you uh not not winners and all that
stuff but the picks that are you just
can't get out of your head right now
connor oh man i think it starts with
ravens getting travis jones it's just
unbelievable to get that caliber of a
first round player to position a need uh
nicoby dean is somebody that
every eagles preseason game i will be
watching because i want to see nikoi
dean play football the way he played at
georgia it was unbelievable
those are the really big ones for me and
just watching you know i want to see
malik willis
grow
slowly in tennessee not be thrown into
the fire not be thrown into a bad
situation he was given that opportunity
so this is this is a blast this day
because i always say it's cliche but
this is when super bowls are
no doubt uh for me
i'm gonna go with four cincinnati guys
you know what i mean i'm gonna go cook
who i absolutely love we i've talked
about him and going to the chiefs yeah i
absolutely love what he brings to the
table alec pierce a guy that we do
wonder how does he have the speed to
separate but maybe it doesn't matter
because yeah this guy can jump and he's
going to go ahead and get over the top
of you
desmond ritter
a quarterback
kelsey called him the best quarterback
of all time from cincinnati yeah listen
you get him in the third round that's a
it's not just a value but that's a guy
that a lot of folks thought could be a
first-round draft pick and then i'm also
going to go with um we got maj sanders
in there as well oh yeah so that's a
that's a lot and we didn't get kobe
bryant and we'll have fun with that one
tomorrow yes we'll have some fun with
that one because everybody's going to
talk about georgia in their first round
but yep to have four guys go on day two
that's a massive accomplishment as well
it really is and i'm excited for
tomorrow because tomorrow like lefko
said it's all about the picks it's all
about the pictures when that clock
starts felder and i we're gonna have
tory holt joining us remote just like we
had richard sherman yeah saint brown
jason kelsey i know he's going to be
excited to talk about some of the wide
receivers that fell all kinds of players
it's going to be great i want to say
thank you to uh our producers our
directors all of the technical staff
this is a very long day for everybody
thank you to all the production crew for
making this possible they're going to
keep doing this for you and so thanks to
everybody here this has been br
gridiron's draft night extravaganza day
two is in the books and don't waste your
time with television because day three
happens right here tomorrow have a good
night everybody hope your team's drafted
who you wanted
[Music]
[Music]
so
you